Hi, good evening. In compliance with
chapter 551, open meetings of the Texas
Government Code, I call to order an
information session of the board of
trustees of the Austin Independent
School District for Thursday, November
6, 2025 at 6:05 p.m. A quorum of the
board is physically present at Austin
ISD central office to conduct this
meeting. This meeting is being broadcast
on cable channel 22 through Spectrum
Estound Broadband and on channel 99
through AT&T Universe. Closed captioning
in English is available on these
platforms for individuals who are deaf
or heart of hearing. Welcome and thank
you for joining us. Um Trusty Kintana
will be joining us by Zoom tonight. Um
normally we have public comment at the
very top of our meeting. Comments were
coming in until um very close to our
meeting today and so the staff who put
the voice files together need a little
bit of extra time. I apologize those
aren't ready. um instead of beginning
the rest of our meeting um by law public
comments need to be at the top of our
meeting. So we are going to go into
executive session first get some of that
work done and as soon as the voice file
is ready we'll come back we'll listen to
public comments and we'll move forward
with the first agenda item after that on
our meeting. Um and we will if anyone
wants to walk into the lobby do anything
we'll make sure to come and let you know
before our meeting starts um the public
portion. So, we will now recess the open
meeting at 606 PM and move to executive
session pursuant to Texas Government
Code sections 551.074,
551.072,
551.073,
551.087,
551.076,
551.0821,
and 551.071.
When we finish with executive session,
we will return to the open session.
Thank you.
Hi everybody. We will now reconvene our
open meeting at 6:47 p.m. The public
comment file is ready. So now is our
opportunity for the public to share
comments with the board. This time
allows speakers to comment publicly on
any topic of their choosing because it's
an information session directly to the
school board. We have time for up to 60
speakers. As a reminder, the district
continues to provide time during regular
voting meetings of the board to hear
from public uh the public about agenda
items for consideration and vote. Uh
tonight is an opportunity for the board
to take part in listening to our
community. And while we wish we could
respond or provide feedback, TE Texas
law requires us to limit our questions
and request uh to request for
clarification or followup directly to
the administration. Members of the
public wishing to participate in the
public comment portion of our meeting
called a dedicated Austin ISD phone line
in advance of the meeting to sign up to
speak in person or to audio record their
remarks. And tonight we have 11 people
signed up to speak in person and 49 who
left a recorded message. and we will
begin with in-person testimony to
provide as many opportunities for input
as possible. Uh each speaker will be
allotted one minute. No substitutions or
yielding of time to others is permitted.
[snorts] Callers who signed up to speak
in person are welcome to come to the
microphone when your name is called. And
as you come to the microphone, please
press the button to turn it on. A device
will light up as you move through your
one minute of time. When the buzzer
sounds, please make a final thought in
one sentence. And again, we ask that
whether you come to give a complaint or
praise, that you reference the staff
member by any staff member by position
or abbreviated last name. And we ask
that all of our audience members,
whether speaking or not, please show
respect at all times. Thank you. Uh, our
in-person speakers tonight are Stacy
Woodburn, Henry, Delicia Mlan, and Joe
Ariyaga for our first three.
Okay. Hi, I'm Stacy from Becker and I'm
here to speak about process integrity.
In a recorded Zoom September 18th, Dr.
French spoke to Becker families about
the amount of influence that you all can
have. Quote, and our answer is like, no.
The same evening, Miss Gileruchi was
overheard gossiping and complaining
about our school outside this very
hallway. In the past two months, several
Becker teachers who helped with advocacy
letters and translations told us that
they must remain anonymous since they
are not supposed to voice opposition.
The October 31st, I'm sorry, 31 areas of
exploration tracker omitted many of the
topics mentioned in Becker's comment
cards. We asked French for clarification
regarding nuanced language around dual
language transfers, but received no
response. Similarly, our FOYA requests
have been delayed. Now there is an
integrity investigation and both of the
aforementioned people are on leave.
Trustees, I ask you if to question if
Becker's successful, cost-effective and
beloved school was given a fair chance.
Were any of our suggestions properly
considered as this plan was created?
>> Thank you. And I'd like to thank you for
your comment, but I would like to remind
our audience, please don't mention staff
members by name. Um, by last name,
please, unless our council feels like
there's an exception to that. I
understand names have been public, and
I'm not saying [snorts] that for you,
just saying that um because that's our
our practice. Thank you.
Delicia Mlan, Becker, parent. I've heard
you say, sir, that you're trying to do
big things with this draft plan, but we
must ask big for who? This plan closes
now 10 schools. And for what gain? The
data isn't clear. Our most vulnerable
students continue to be marginalized,
shuffled from school to school. The
wall-to-wall campuses are being closed
in order to redistribute those resources
to similar student populations. All for
a mere 2.99%
increase in DL access for EB students.
That big disruption for almost no
impact. It feels like every problem in
this district is seen as a nail. And the
solution is the same blunt instrument.
Closure. Utilization problem closure.
Budget deficit closure. Inequity
closure. Tap closure. But where are the
solutions that build up rather than tear
down? Where is the student focused
community centered decisionmaking?
It's not for lack of ideas or community
willingness. You have both of them.
We're here. You get you've you have the
Gibson report, the TEA Senate bill 560
strategic plan calling for growing our
own teachers by building pipelines and
expanding bilingual programs.
[sighs] Sorry, I'm going to try to
summarize so that I can get off the the
thing.
>> [snorts]
>> Um, you even moved in that direction in
2024 with Teach Austin. Uh, it was
launched in partnership with the new
teacher project until it was cut the
year before the cohort was able to
graduate. You talk about big things, but
the big things isn't it's not closure.
It's collaboration. It's investing in
what's working and fixing what's not
without throwing communities in the
trash. The boldest move we can make is
not to divide, but to unite to create a
plan that truly serves all students.
Hi, thank you.
>> 530
comment cards all for one row in a small
paragraph that misrepresents our actual
ask. and lacks the metrics and
thoroughess in its response.
When every fiber in our parental being
told us to get loud, we followed the
rules. We welcomed you into our schools
uh with the utmost Bobcat hospitality,
but what we've gotten back does not feel
like collaboration. Just to clarify,
we're asking the district to consider a
fifth wall-to-wall dual language program
in South Central Austin. partner with us
to truly elevate the emerging bilingual
experience districtwide. Our plan
outlines several ways to do so. This
isn't something that we feel entitled
to. Um but if this plan is going to go
one go against one of its own core
tenants and tear us apart by not uh by
not keeping us together.
At least give us real numbers to back it
up. Thank you.
Thank you. Our next in uh inperson
speakers are uh Selena Martinez,
Munavara, and Steve Swanson.
Thank you, Selena Martinez, Becker,
parent. Uh three things. One, uh, the
changes to the dual language policy
you're you're going to see tonight
involve the goal or include the goal of
50-50 emergent non-emergent bilingual,
which is great, but any change to policy
should involve community input, at least
the multilingual educational advisory
committee. Uh, to Superintendent Matias,
I urge you to reconsider your decision
to move forward with the plan for dual
language schools despite everything that
happened this week. Um, I emailed you
and the trustees back in September. Um
during a back door conversation, we were
told that there was nothing we could do
to change any of the plans and this
definitely swayed people to give up
before this process really got started.
So someone who is being investigated
impacted this part of the process for
us. Last, I urge you to reconsider our
proposal for a fifth dual language
school located in South Central Austin.
We have the EBS in the area to get to
50/50. Becker is the only school of the
four wall-to-wall campuses that is being
broken up. Thank you.
Okay. Do I just press the button?
>> Okay. Um, Mona Baret, UT Austin student.
>> Okay.
>> Then I press it.
>> That's it. Turns right.
>> Okay.
>> We often define family as our blood
relatives, but that's wrong. family
consists of our community, our teachers,
parents, and of course, students. I have
to wonder, if the schools up for
consolidation are performing well, why
would the board members of AISD close
these schools? A child's educational
success takes a village, and closing
community schools only to sell them to
private interests endangers students'
education. Generally speaking, this
decision is not what's best for our
district. As a child of Somali
immigrants, I have watched how political
issues and displacement have negatively
impacted people, being forcibly removed
from your community into one you don't
know, being ripped apart from your
family, and feeling abandoned. The
consequence of such displacement is
trauma. Public officials work for
Austinites, not the corporations that
would profit from private education, but
the families that you're trying to rip
apart. Austin is watching. Hear us. It's
not consolidation. It's school closure.
You're Austinites when we say no to
closing these schools down. Thank you.
>> Is Is it working?
>> Okay. Good evening. I'm Steve Swanson.
Our AISD lawyers and superintendent are
to be recognized for initiating
professionalism in the planning of our
schools. Working together, our AISD
lawyers have obtained the support of
TEA's general counsel to the Supreme
Court's mandate for professionalism, the
Texas Lawyers. And regarding school
planning, our superintendent has been
quoted stating, "Integrity of the
process has to be held throughout the
entire process or else it's difficult
for me to provide my support and take it
forward.
Professionalism integrity includes TEA
and AISD starting to fulfill state law
for the planning of schools, including
11.02, 11.051, 11.254 of the Texas
Education Code. Had this been done in
2008, Johnston High School in East
Austin would not have been closed and
renamed East Side Memorial. Integrity
demands we ensure TEA serves AISD, not
controls us. Do not be afraid of TEA. Be
professional. Stop school planning.
Learn TEA's and AISD's obligations and
start following state law to prevent
harm and loss on our schools. It's more
important than just test scores. I
welcome your questions and hope you read
the handout. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Next up, we have Adam Sparks,
Anita Sigler, and Mary Alice Ruiz.
Hello. I'm here on behalf of the
Maplewood community. We are feeling a
lot of things right now. We feel relief
for our students and our faculty and for
our staff. We feel whiplash that the
unchangeable plan all of a sudden was
changed in such a random way. And we
also feel guilt that we are being given
the time that we want for all students
in AIST. We are two weeks away from a
vote. We have no idea if it's going to
be Go Valley or Zavala. We have no idea
if Black is going to get put on the list
at the very last second. There haven't
been meetings with these communities. We
are two weeks away from a vote. So our
community is going to keep advocating
what we've always advocated for. on
November 20th, please vote for the only
thing that is required to be voted on on
November 20th, which is the turnaround
plans, which is a herculeaning task in
and of itself to get that right and
execute that faithfully. Please put all
of your energy there. And if there is
going to be a one-year pause, don't just
make it a pause and pick up where you
left off in April. Let's try to fix
enrollment. Let's put uh monatory prek
in underutilized buildings. Let's go to
the Austin Ed Fund and say, "Hey, we're
gonna make a fund just for
interventionists and title one schools
and challenge the Austin community to
say, let's fill this with $5 million by
the end of the school year." That's what
Austin Parks Foundation does. That's how
you get around all the limitations on
funding is you go to the community and
you lead. And so, we need the
superintendent right now to clarify what
the heck went on a couple of days ago
and lead us into a better solution that
focuses on turnaround plans and limits
uh discussion until the community can be
engaged on the other issues. Thank you.
>> [applause]
>> Okay, I gotta figure this out. Oh, it's
already on.
>> Okay. All right. Um, good evening. I'm
Anita Sigler. I'm the librarian at
Pickle Elementary. I want to speak from
the heart about the proposed change from
our dual language program to a
wall-to-wall model. Pickle's dual
language program is more than a
structure. It is a community built on
being biiterate, bilingual, bicultural,
something Pickle that has been nurturing
for many years. We would gladly welcome
Richtop to join us in this current
model. But converting pickle to
wall-to-wall would mean all of our ESL
students must move to heart along with
our turnaround plan. Which means that a
camp an F campus would be taken on a
turnaround plan of another FC campus.
Let's merge Ridgeop and pickle so both
campuses can grow together as a dual
language campus. Resources combined,
staff united, and we still retain our
title one benefits. Pickle is making
real progress. Please slow down this
change and look at our students, not
just the numbers. We have solutions and
we have suggestions. Please make us part
of this transition team and talk with
us. Thank you for listening and for your
dedication to our children. I can't see
them.
Is it on? Yes. Uh, excuse
[clears throat and cough] me. Don't
start yet. I gotta clear my throat.
[sighs]
Breathe. Okay. Good evening,
Superintendent Matias and esteemed board
members. Thank you for keeping our
Sanchez students hopes and dreams alive
with the proposed changes that we've
discussed. Um, these changes will
continue to ensure equal access to
transportation and programming during
the transitional period for our emergent
bilingual students, English and ESL
students and our special ed population.
By giving our current third and fourth
grade English, ESL students an
opportunity to complete their elementary
journey is paramount to fulfilling their
dreams. Would you also consider granting
our first and second grade English and
ESL students the same opportunity? Will
our ESL teachers be given an opportunity
to continue serving them at Sanchez? In
closing, I would like to acknowledge
each of you for your advocacy work and
countless hours dedicated towards
achieving this monumental task. After
decades of serving in public education,
I never dreamed that education reform
would be so challenging.
We must remain united in our collective
efforts to make AISD the best in the
state of Texas. Thank you for all you do
on behalf of our district. I am AISD
proud.
Thank you. We [snorts] have two
additional insperson speakers. We have
Cheryl Bradley and Bertha Rendone
Delgado. Thank you.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
Can y'all hear me?
Actually, first of all, I want to uh
start by saying thank you to the
superintendent
uh Chief Montgomery Chief Drinks for
coming out October the 28th and speaking
with the community at Great Greater
Calvary Bible Miss uh Bible Church. Um
it was hosted by e east side social
action coalition and um it was very
wellreceived. Uh the community was very
pleased with it and it was actually
meaningful engagement.
So we appreciate that. But then also I'm
here to say and it's going to be quick.
If there is a question in the integrity
of the process
then you need to stop.
It shouldn't go any further until you
can clear that piece up. You don't want
it to go any further. The district
already has an issue with mistrust. You
don't want to dig it any deeper because
the thing about it, if you're still
fighting the issues that happened in
1971,
today,
30 years from now, you will be fighting
this issue now. So if the process if
there's a integrity process for three
schools is an integrity process for all
of them.
[applause]
Good evening.
It's good to see you Matias.
Uh my name is Bertha Rendon Delgado. I'm
a city of Austin former housing
commissioner. I'm also an alumni of
Martin Middle School, uh, Mets
Elementary, which is closed now, um, and
a longtime native of East Austin, 46
years. [snorts] We are very disappointed
in the direction of you, our leadership,
this board.
The plan is racially, economically, and
geographically segregated,
and it calls for lawsuit.
Diversity benefits everyone.
And what you've done to East Austin and
District One and District 2, the East
Austin schools have been closed. This is
now going to be our sixth school in the
decades.
The boundary changes that you're making
do not give our schools and our kids
diversity. You are de stabilizing our
children and displacing our families. We
ask that you postpone this vote. We ask
that you do not close any more schools
in this district and we ask for your
resignation if you continue and a class
lawsuit against AISD. Thank you.
>> Thank you to our speakers. Uh, we will
now play the recorded message for public
testimony. So, please listen carefully.
>> Hello, my name is Ben Prince. I am a
Becker Elementary School parent. I am
actually alumni of AISD and I live in
the Balden Creek neighborhood. I'm
calling to strongly support uh Becker
Elementary School as a successful model
of dual language education and AISD.
It's also a very successful neighborhood
school. In fact, it drew my wife and I
to move our family uh to this
neighborhood at tremendous sacrifice and
I realize that all community members in
Austin are sacrificing right now. But we
need Becker and schools like Becker that
are positive, successful models of
public education to attract people from
other areas. If this is not possible to
keep Becker open as a dual language
school or merely as a local elementary
school, please um allow Balden Creek
Elementary students uh to merge with the
Zilker community as this is a community
that's close, walkable, and has um a
similar um quality of education. Thank
you for your time and
>> hi, my name is Laura Hampton. Um, I have
a future AISD student. Um, and we're in
the Zilker Elementary area. Um, I just
wanted to thank, um, in particular
President Boswell and Superintendent
Zakura for the um, for [clears throat]
the flexibility and listening to our
community feedback. Um, it was great to
to watch the last board meeting and see
that um, that the plan is to draft an
amendment for our area to keep our
communities together. Um Lynn was great
and came to our area and and drove
around and saw some of our safety
concerns. Um so really appreciate that
there are a lot of families in our area
who walk to school, bike to school and
really want to stay together um and
specifically sought homes in this area
for uh the diversity that Zulker
Elementary has to offer. Um so thank you
very much um and looking forward to
seeing those changes in the next draft.
Bye-bye.
Hi, my name is Ellen Price and I'm
calling on behalf of Becker Elementary.
I have a kindergartener and then I have
a one-year-old and hoping to be in this
district for the next 17 years, but this
process has really made it feel like
that's not going to be possible for my
family. I'd like to advocate again on
behalf of Becker Elementary School
staying open throughout this process.
It's clear given the changes that were
made just today to pause most of the
process that it is possible to untangle
things from the taps and to make changes
to the plan at this point. Becker
Elementary is being fended chances
elementary which we do not want wish to
take over. We actually wish the best for
that school and for that school to be
given more resources to succeed.
However, as many as 86% of us at Becker
Elementary have are not able to feasibly
and logistically drive to Sanchez
Elementary every day. We're the only
community on the remaining closing
schools that are being fractured into a
million different pieces with this plan
with so many of us unable to make the
move. uh um I35 has been used as a
natural boundary, but that seems to not
be the case for our school. I'd love for
you to take community feedback and
proposals that we've been coming to you
with into real consideration. It feels
as though the district has not been
listening to us in
>> Hi, I'm call my name is Nikki. I'm
calling to make uh a comment on the
consideration
of the closing of Becker Elementary
School. It's a school in my neighborhood
that uh I really feel is a gives people
a great sense of community here is very
safe for the children to get here and
really has forged the community around
it, the neighborhood around it as a
really um excellent inner city school.
uh it just has a lot going for it and
and I uh I really can't imagine that
there isn't money that couldn't come
from somewhere else besides closing a
school that's performing so well and
does such a service to our community in
Ben Creek. Thank you for your
consideration. I hope you will
reconsider
>> there. My name is Catelyn Zuniga and I
am a parent of a Zilker Elementary
student as well as a resident of Zilker
East. Thank you so much for taking the
time and listening to our community
feedback. We truly appreciate President
Boswell taking the time to drive through
Zilker, Galindo, and Becker and to see
firsthand the transport transportation
safety concerns and the limited access
points across the railroad that we have
expressed. We are also grateful to AISD
staff for visiting Zilker to review
enrollment capacities. One of our
concerns if boundaries revert back to
the 103 version is that Vilker could be
significantly over capacity with both
grandfathered families as well as
additional families coming from Becker
through the new amendment allowing all
in all-inone transfers to continue to go
to the new school. Our community is
hopeful for a finalized amendment that
supports the district's goals of
balancing enrollment, minimizing
disruption for families, and continuing
to keep our schools strong and
accessible for all students. Thank you
again for your work and your thoughtful
consideration.
Hi, my name is Doa. I'm a Zilker East
parent. I'm also a person of color and I
did not want to choose between diversity
and quality of education. That's part of
why we bought a home within the Zilker
zone for my child.
This boundary change that you're
considering takes the most accessible
neighborhood in Zilker, which is our
neighborhood, South Lamar, and displaces
us with the wealthiest neighborhood in
the area, Ben Golden Acres, the Becker
zone. And that destroys the very thing
that is special about Zilker. It is one
of the only very high performing schools
that is very, very diverse um in a
meaningful way. So, please don't cluster
the wealthy neighborhoods in our area at
Zilker and send the rest of us to a tap
school in the name of equity. It's not
fair. Um, and I'm sure there are there
are other solutions. Thank you for
considering. Bye.
>> AISD needs strong dual language programs
to support emerging bilingual students,
provide the quality education every
student deserves, and to draw local
families to public schools. There is no
reason to dismantle the successful DL
programs that took over a decade to
build and hope they somehow regenerate
and flourish in new locations, all while
kicking out historically marginalized
communities from their beloved schools
in the process. Becker's only challenge
has been access, helping EB families
learn about our programs, navigate a
difficult enrollment process, and obtain
transportation. These are barriers we've
been asking you to address for years.
Now, you've committed to fix these
issues, but not at our campus. Why must
we dismantle our school and move to a
new building in order to get the
district's help? Trustees, we urge you
to push for sensible alternatives to the
current plan. The Gibson report to AISD
stated the existing campuses are
uniquely capable of implementing strong
DL instructional practices and
supporting emerging bilingual students.
Let Becker remain the hub where dual
language students from Dawson and Zilker
can come together in a central location
with dedicated teachers, a historic
building, an exemplary garden, and a
deeply committed community. Fix the
enrollment and transportation barriers.
Don't dismantle what works. Support
communitydriven solutions that build on
proven success instead of erasing it.
Hello, this is Andrea Schneider and
Brett Close. We are residents of the
Balden neighborhood and our daughter is
a second grader at Becker Elementary.
We would like the reszoning of the
Balden neighborhood to be to Zilker
Elementary, not Galindo. This makes
sense because it's a walkable
neighborhood school. All Balden Creek
residents live within two miles of
Zilker versus two plus miles to Glindo,
which would require buses and additional
travel.
Zilker also has comparable quality
education that matches the education of
what Becker and Balden families have
come to expect of their neighborhood
school.
We hope you will take this into
consideration and confirm that Balden
residents will be reszoned
to the Zilker Elementary School. Thank
you.
>> Hi, my name is Barbara Passmore. I'm a
Becker Bobcat parent and a member of the
board of the school garden, the Becker
Green Classroom, which was founded in
1989 and is the oldest school garden in
Austin. It's hosted trustees, the
superintendent,
um, politicians, Alice Waters. It
inspired the edible schoolyard program
and it has inspired multiple programs in
the school district including the garden
to cafe program which allows kids to eat
in the cafeteria what they've grown in
their own organic garden and it also um
it has not been taken into account in
the plan making that has taken place so
far. I think these plans have been made
too fast and haven't taken into account
the communities that will be terminated.
um it hasn't taken into account the
proximity of public libraries. There are
numerous other factors and I just hope
that we can implore you and convince you
to take a pause and reassess. Closing
Becker is not the way to make Austin ISD
better. It's
>> Hi, my name is Sarah Spitz. I have a
student that was supposed to start prek4
at Ridgetop next year. Um, I urge the
district to come up with a plan for
Riley Elementary due to the
consolidation uh that parents in our
neighborhood can feel excited and
confident about that this will be an
excellent neighborhood school next year.
If you all cannot um be able to make
this an excellent school in the next
year or two years, please consider
reszoning our area to Lee and the Riley
area to Brentwood while you figure out
how to manage the consolidation. Um,
thank you.
>> Hello, my name is Greg Hayes, parent to
three students as zone 2 Becker
Elementary School. Becker is an
awesomely diverse school, and because of
this, there are many groups representing
the future, the repositioning, and the
support that Becker can give to the
larger Austin ISD. All of Becker wishes
to keep the school open.
However, Becker is not only a dual
language school, it's also a
neighborhood school, and keeping local
kids going to neighborhood schools is a
top priority of the district. The Becker
Zone students have not had a strong
voice in these discussions. In the event
that Becker does close, Becker Zone
students will be adversely affected by
losing two things, their dual language
school and their neighborhood school.
There's a petition now with more than
100 signatures and a proposal to best
serve these zone kids by combining with
the Zilker Elementary School as
originally proposed by the district.
This was a good plan in this difficult
situation. The Bolden neighborhood
shares parks, playgrounds, and friends
with the Zilker neighborhood on a
regular basis. Please don't ignore the
minority voice at Becker and the zone
student population in your
consideration. Thank you. Bye.
>> Hi, my name is Pen Mayo. I'm a Richtop
Elementary parent. We had uh Mr. Sigura
at school today, but unfortunately we
weren't all able to answer questions
about the consolidation plan. Um some of
my questions are about whether or not it
was considered that Ridgetop being a
wall-to-wall program and perhaps just
retain a track or two of dual language.
um therefore alleviating you know some
of the need for all the bilingual
teachers who are there and also what is
the plan for pickle's title one status
and will merging these schools result in
a large loss of funding of title one
funds for that school and also what is
the future plan to get more teachers
certified in bilingual education uh is
the plan to continue filing exceptions
for those teachers or to somehow assist
them in obtaining certifications and how
can the parent community support those
teachers who want to become bilingual
certified. Thank you.
>> My name is Lane Ralph. I am a parent to
two children that attend Ridgetop
Elementary.
I would like clarity around initially
this plan was proposed because of a
budget crisis and yet somehow we were
able to magically fund three schools
getting off of the consolidation closure
list. Where did the funds come from that
are allowing these three schools to stay
open? We were also told that the dual
language wall-to-wall programs needed to
move to be closer to the emerging
bilingual population and improve equity
of the program.
Are these programs tied to turnaround
plans associated with the receiving
schools?
>> Hi, my name is Elizabeth Michael and I
am a parent at Ridgetop. I have two
questions. One is I overheard I believe
in a Zoom meeting that you are thinking
of opening up a wall-to-wall middle
school. Unclear if it's one or two and
where it would be located, but many of
us would like to know if this is the
case as it would help with our decision-
making. Second question is, "My son is
in kindergarten. I have talked to almost
every single kindergarten parent at
Ridgeop. No one I know is planning to go
to pickle because of the location
of Luton, Brentwood, Lee, Riley, and so
on based on where they are zoned. My
question is, are you doing anything to
encourage non-emerging bilingual to
attend Ridgetop in those younger age
grades, which would not be just starting
out in elementary school? As you can
imagine, we want people coming from
other highly rated schools or just, you
know, other folks who might already be
in a school that's not closing. So, what
would encourage them to move to pickle
so that it really is a true mix of
emerging bilingual and non-emerging
bilingual? Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Vicki Deusk. I'm calling
in regard to the closure of Becker
Elementary. I live in Balden Creek. All
three of my kids attended Becker
Elementary and I am currently the
president of the board of the Becker
Green classroom. If you close Becker
Elementary, you are also closing the
Becker Green classroom. We are a
volunteerrun nonprofit organization that
was first established in 1989 by pioneer
Carla Marshall who wanted to get kids
outside doing learning outside instead
of in the classroom.
The Becker green classroom has been a
leader in district-wide innovation
inspiring dozens of school gardens
around Austin. Outdoor learning um the
children's outdoor bill of rights and
environmental sustainability have become
core in AISD's plan for the future and
are two fundamental aspects of our
volunteer-led program. The Becker Green
Classroom is an independent
volunteer-run nonprofit organization
with deep ties to the local community
and Austin's arts and gardening
communities. Keeping the Becker Ring
classroom open to students and community
members does not just allow us to keep
our mission and our history alive. It
has the potential to support children
across the district in line with
district level goals. Outdoor learning.
If you close My name is Bianca Gonzalez
Conrad and I am a Becker parent. I've
lived in Balden Creek for 16 years and
both my children are students at Becker
Elementary. Each kid started in pre-K so
we've been at Becker about almost seven
years. Uh my number one ask would be to
keep our thriving elementary school
open. Becker is both a dual language
school and a neighborhood school. The
Becker transfer families elevated our
enrollment numbers and are integral to
our community, but also the Bolden
neighbors who aren't fluent in Spanish
have invested in Spanish classes and
immersion preschools for our kids over
these years to support this program.
We just ask if you choose to close the
heart of the neighborhood, please
consider everything Balden is losing
when you stick us somewhere else. Thank
you.
>> My name is Aisha Dero and I am a
resident of Balden Creek. I'm calling as
a parent of an AISD student um who
currently attends Lata High School um
and who attended um Dawson and Lively
before that. The reason for my call is
I'm very concerned um about the decision
made to close Becker primarily for the
Balden Creek community. Um and as an I
AISD member, I just want to make sure
that I'm advocating that it is mine and
our community's position that you should
invest in what works, that Becker has
been a strong school um for the
community. And um first and foremost,
we're interested and I'm interested in
keeping Becker open. However, if Becker
cannot remain open, then I want to
strongly advocate that we move to Zilker
Elementary instead of the new proposal
for Galindo Elementary School. Um our
priority is walkable schools that are
part of the community and also that are
comparable um to the educational
opportunities that have been afforded at
Becker. We only have 168
>> Hi, my name is Natalie Betts. and the
parent of two children at Richtop
Elementary. I'm calling to ask the
district why concerns brought up
regarding the refinement of the
consolidation process, a refinement
process that took place over a matter of
weeks, warrants a change and a delay of
a full calendar year for some of the
components of that process.
I understand wanting to take time and
review those considerations, but I would
ask the district to reconsider and look
at only a few weeks delay.
We were engaging in good faith with the
district under the understanding that
these major changes all had to happen
together.
But now we've seen that that's not
necessarily true and big pieces of the
change have been set aside for a full
year. I would ask the district to please
consider either only a few weeks delay
or looking at all the entire process to
see whether all of it could be staged
and implemented. Moving dual language
schools, moving all closing all of these
schools are very challenging processes
and all schools deserve time if time is
available. Thank you very much for your
consideration of this comment.
Hi, this is Shishi Zang, Zilker parent.
I just wanted to first thank the Austin
ISD board for considering the boundary
amendment for Zilker Elementary School.
We're hoping to see it in final form. We
asked President Boswell to drive the
traffic routes between our community,
Zilker, Galindo, and Becker, to assess
safety and accessibility, and she did
just that. We also appreciate that the
staff from Austin ISD came to Zilker to
assess the space as our families had
concerns regarding significant
overenrollment with continuation Zilker
students and new students from closing
schools, which now includes inzone and
transfer students as of the 1031
amendment. I hope there can be a
solution found to keep dual language in
South Central Austin as the Zokro dual
language program is recommended to close
and hope the board is looking at
Becker's proposal to keep a dual
language program open. The Joslyn and
Odum programs will be 5 minutes apart
from each other, but we will no longer
have a program in our area. Thank you
for considering adjustments that would
be beneficial to all communities.
>> Hello, my name is Elizabeth Orur. I'm a
parent of children at Rididgetop
Elementary. I am calling to express my
disappointment with the Austin ISD
consolidation plan. Um, in particular,
Ridgetop parents feel lied to by the ISD
and we were asked to accept uh the
closure of our school as part of a
grander plan to realign feeder patterns
and to address systemic issues within
the ISD. We were sold that bill of goods
in September and we bought in to support
our community. By bifurcating this plan
and pushing off all of the wider changes
outside of just the TAP program and the
bilingual education program, you are
asking now a small part of your ISD and
school communities to shoulder some very
difficult changes. While you do not make
the systemic changes that you told us
were so necessary, I hope you consider
this and I hope that the trustees
consider voting no on this plan. This is
Michelle Herd, a ridgetop parent. We
have learned that there is a reversion
clause in the original 1917 deed for the
Rididge Elementary property under which
it seems that if the district ceases to
use the property as a public free
school, ownership reverts to the
successors of the original owner. As a
result, it seems ASC cannot sell or
monetize the Ridgetop property to
support district finances. Rather, if
the campus is decommissioned, instead of
gaining a financial cash asset, ASC may
simply lose the asset it has in the form
of the Ridgetop property and school that
is currently available to serve students
and provide a public good. We've been
told by AISD leadership that how the
property will be used in the future is
not considered at this stage. However,
if AISD is legally prevented from
generating revenue from the property,
that seems short-sighted, especially
given the dire district finances are the
reason we've been told the ridgetop
school must close after the dual
language program is relocated. I ask you
to please investigate this deep
restriction, share the limitations it
puts on the district regarding the use
of the richtop property, and ensure any
financial implications are factored into
the district's analysis and
decision-making before the school is
consolidated.
AISD, you are taking away my
neighborhood school, both neighborhood
schools in closest proximity to where I
live and giving me no neighborhood
option. You say you have listened to
comments from families, but when it
comes to the four wall-to-wall dual
language campuses, nothing has changed
from your original plan except you have
added transportation for some students.
Why not transportation for all students?
The district should not put any child in
harm's way at the very minimum of your
responsibility to all parents.
Particulate matter is a real thing.
Health outcomes for communities that
live by highways and heavily congested
thoroughares is a real concern. Data and
research have been sent via comic card
to the district. The district needs to
publicly confirm that they have read the
scientific research and are at a minimum
comfortable sending all kids to Sanchez
Elementary School. Knowing these risks
and the potential future health impacts
to any student who attends Sanchez
Elementary School, especially with the
commencement of the I35 Capitol Express
Central project that will specifically
impact this school due to its location
and proximity to the highway.
>> Okay. My name is Maria Gomez and I I've
been in pickle for almost 20 years as a
teacher, as a teacher assistant, as a
substitute and it's so sad to love this
school because the school serves a lot
of community and people of the community
and we need to save this school as the
other one the other three that you
saved. Please, please save people open
and we don't we don't want to see people
from another communities coming to this
area. So, keep people keep keep PE
people
uh save it open.
>> Hi, my name is Kristen Davis. My
daughter is a fourth grade dual language
student at Joslin Elementary. I wanted
to take a minute to thank the district
for working so diligently to address our
community's concerns about our potential
shift to a non-zoned campus. We
especially appreciate that the October
31st draft of the plan allows for all
current fourth graders to finish their
elementary experience at Joslyn,
provides for citywide school buses to
Joslyn, and leaves room in the foreign
language immersion program for students
to receive special education services.
We are also grateful for the thoughtful
approach to reassigning our current
attendance boundary to new neighborhood
schools. Our school community also
appreciates those district staff and
schoolboard members who took the time to
visit our campus and sit with parents,
teachers, staff, and campus leadership.
We appreciate the long hours and late
nights that we know the board and
district staff have put into discussing
what is next for the district and for
our school. Thank you again for all your
hard work.
I am a Silker East parent calling about
the uh boundary changes. Thank you,
Trusty Boswell, for meeting with and
spending time in our community and to
all trustees and district employees for
hearing our community's concerns. I
would like to urge the district to move
forward with the recommendation to keep
Vil Stone in Zil as proposed at the
10:29 board meeting. This aligns with
the district's principles um and
minimizes unnecessary disruption.
Additionally, it is almost a certainty
that Zilker will flower exceed its
maximum student capacity if the entire
Becker Zone community is moved to Zilker
in addition to all grandfathered
students and siblings. It is untenable.
However, if there is a small subset of
the Becker Dolphin Zone students that
have particular needs or benefit from
programming that the district believes
Zilker is in a better position to
address, we continue to support moving
that group of students to Zilk Zilker
while maintaining current Zilker zoning.
I have two questions today. First, can
you please state with clarity exactly
what your plan or recommendation is for
Zilker as of today? Second, if there are
any topics still being explored around
Zilker zoning, please state with
specificity what concerns, issues, or
factors the district is still cons. Hi,
my name is Lauren, a ridgetop parent.
And if you're going to blow up our
community and our school, at the very
least you can support the staff, the
coveted bilingual teachers and put them
in a brand new school. Something shiny,
something awesome, something rewarding
of their dedication to the community.
I'm thinking Wooten or Harris and please
pay attention to the Riley shell of a
school. If you have nothing planned in
place, you should put us in a system
that is already working. again take care
of our bilingual educators and our
staffs and our community.
>> Good morning. This is Nick Blue. I'm a
parent of East Stilker and I wanted to
start off by thanking President Boswell
for driving our community and listening
to our feedback recently. I also want to
urge Superintendent Matus and President
Boswell to follow through with the
proposed plan to reinclude Eve Silker to
Zilker Elementary that was recently
brought up in the last work session.
This is a common sense plan. One, it
prevents displacing two communities. The
Becker community is going to have to
move with their school closing, but it
does not make sense to displace our
community that has a longstanding
history of attending Zilker. Second, it
prevents both communities from having to
cross the train tracks. Not to mention,
East Zilker is closer to Zilker
Elementary. Many of the homes in the
community on the same road, Blue Bonnet,
or half a mile away. Our community looks
forward to seeing this proposal in the
next draft. Thank you for your time.
>> Hi, my name is Erikica Bowden and I'm
calling to talk about Garza High School.
Um, I'm a Garza parent. I know that
looking at the new proposal, which
really came out of left field for us,
um, I know that AIC isn't calling it a
closure, but that's what it will be. If
Garza goes away in its current form, a
lot of students who don't fit the
traditional mold are going to lose the
one place that actually works for them.
And GARS is different because it's
small. It's relational. The staff have
the training and the support to actually
listen to students and center their
agency. And that's why kids who were
ready to give up on school find a way
forward there. You can't recreate that
with the changes being proposed. And I
guess what worries me the most is that
the idea was rolled out without asking
any of the Garza community. No students,
families, or staff were asked for input.
Um, this is not a numbersbased decision.
Garza has been changing lives for
decades. We don't want to dismantle the
most inclusive, one of the most
inclusive and effective schools in
Austin ICD. Please protect Garza and the
students who depend on it. Thank you.
>> My name is Maria and I am a parent of a
middle school and elementary school dual
language student. There needs to be a
pause for more work to be done on the
dual language plan across the campus
before changes and closures are
implemented. The superintendent has
stated that the district has struggled
to implement plans successfully. That
will happen here and students
communities at nine campuses will
suffer. This plan does not incorporate
feedback from families who have built
these programs and the professional
consultants who do not recommend closing
thriving dual language campuses. At
minimum, there should be a successful
pilot of a non-zone wall-to-wall in a
new location before all the current
thriving programs are destroyed. Issues
include the dual language plan goes
against the recommendation of the Gibson
report to invest in the current
programs. The district has not said how
they will get buyin for programs on
campuses that do not want them. Pickle
ODM. These campuses have not even had a
meeting with the superintendent.
Transportation to non-zone schools is
not equitable across the district for
dual language and emerging campuses and
will prevent students without
transportation or family resources from
accessing the program if they are not
emergent bilingual. There are not clear
plans presented for keeping the new
wall-to-wall campuses from gentrifying
in the future and or ensuring enrollment
levels for a costefficient campus. There
has not been confirmation of where
nonwala language programming will be
offered.
>> Yes. Uh my name is Spencer. I'm calling
as a community member of the Zilker East
neighborhood. Uh my comment is that the
uh proposed resoning plan um in which
our community is reszoned to Gindo
doesn't seem to align with uh AISD's
guiding principles for the reasonzoning
particularly as it pertains to the
natural boundaries which would be the
train track. It seems that um they are
breaking up two communities with the
closing of Becker to relocate to Zilker
and moving our community out of Zilker.
So, I'm proposing or requesting that
that we be continued to be zoned for
Zilker. It seems to uh make more sense
with how AISD is approaching the
reszoning. Thank you. Bye.
>> Hi, my name is Adam Hockenberry. I'm a
parent in the current ridgetop zone. My
primary comment and sort of my primary
concern at the moment is really the
future of Riley School. So, Richtop is
closing down. We're losing our dual
language program getting reszoned to
Riley, which is also, as my
understanding is, losing all of its dual
language programs and actually being
restarted. Um, if my understanding of
the new process plan is correct, we are
still the only restart that's going to
be happening amongst any of the schools
that are not like on a turnaround plan.
And I just really want some assurances
that like the restart of this school is,
you know, recognize that this is
different from a turnaround plan. These
other schools that are getting restarted
are again my understanding mostly
failing schools that are getting
restarted for very particular reasons.
Whereas Riley is just getting restarted
because of the shuffling that's going
around and this was a good school
previously and really are just looking
for assurances that you know we're going
to do the best that we can and provide
resources so that Riley actually
succeeds as a school and hits the ground
running with a head start as opposed to
just being treated like all the other
restarts that are you know due to the
tap. Thanks.
My name is Emily Pitzick and I'm an East
Zilker parent. We plan to start our
daughter at Zilker Elementary School
this fall, but instead this plan would
reson us to Galindo, a C-rated school
which is farther from our home and would
require us to cross a railroad boundary.
Um, after seeing the proposal, we've
already started applying to private
schools and neighborhood surveys show
that many of our neighbors would do the
same. As a former Houston ISD teacher, I
know firsthand what school ratings mean
for kids and combining C-rated Galindo
with F-rated Dawson does not set anyone
up for success.
This plan just does not feel equitable.
True equity would mean expanding access
to high-erforming schools in 7874 which
would be Zilker, Barton Hills, Becker
and Travis Heights, not taking those
opportunities away. You cannot solve a
budget crisis by pushing more families
out and sending kids to lower performing
schools does just that. So my question
is how is reszoning east to Zilker to
Galindo actually going to help them? Hi,
my name is Ashley Connell and my
daughters will be future students of
Zilker Elementary. We are part of Zilker
East that now is reszoned into Galindo
Elementary and I'm calling to voice my
concern about the railroad tracks and of
of getting from where we live to
Galindo. Um, also just sharing a
personal story about our family. We have
been walking our daughters to Zilker and
talking about going to Zilker with the
neighborhood kids who have become our
family since both of our daughters were
6 weeks old. It has become something
that my four-year-old who will be going
into prek next year uh talks about all
the time when she goes to Vilker, when
she goes to Vilker. This has become more
than a school, but really a culture and
a family to us. And all of the other
kids on our street will be grandfathered
in, except for my daughters. Um, and so
I I just hate to tell her that. No. My
name is Nancy Mossman and I'm an AISD
taxpayer and I am concerned about the uh
consolidation plan especially
the idea that Garza is going to be uh
merged with Martin. Garza is a very
specific program for very specific needs
and it's been very successful. I have
friends who've participated in it and um
it just it seems to be very
inappropriate for the Garza students to
who have had a campus all to themselves
um 11th and 12th graders to be added to
a campus that includes sixth graders.
So, um I I'm very concerned about that
plan and hope that um that part of the
consolidation plan will will be deleted.
Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Shelby O'Donnell and I am
a parent in Southwest Austin of a
current third grader and a student that
graduated Austin High School this last
year. I'm calling about the proposed
boundary changes moving our students
from Austin to Crockett High. I am very
concerned that reszoning our kids to a
lower rated high school will negatively
impact their educational and athletic
opportunities, split up established peer
groups and our community, and could
ultimately hurt property values and
future home buyer interests in our area.
I strongly urge the district to
reconsider this plan and explore
alternatives that don't disrupt families
or diminish educational quality. You are
moving families to a high school that do
not live anywhere near or have anything
to do with that high school. Please
reconsider allowing our children to
continue together at Austin High. Thank
you.
This is Sharon Bain, the parent of two
AISD graduates. As per usual, I have
many questions, but I just want to
center this one tonight. What lessons
have you learned from the community
engagement on the GRA draft
consolidations plan that you will adopt
moving forward both with this plan and
in key endeavors such as the district's
academic vision? We are seeing so many
thoughtful and community centered ideas
bubbling forth from the ground up right
now and it's hard not to wonder what
this plan would look like if we could
have heard them earlier. How will this
be different as we move forward? Thank
you.
Hi, this is Ruben Gandu. I'm a proud
graduate of Gonzalo Garza Independence
High School. The first Garza student
ever accepted to the University of Texas
at Austin. The school changed my life
and gave me the chance to break barriers
for my entire family. I know AISD isn't
calling this a closure, but it what it
that's what it is. If Garza is moved or
reshaped, students who don't fit the
traditional mold will lose the one place
that truly works for them like myself.
Garza Garza's model works because it's
it's small, personal, and built on
trust. Teachers there listen. They help
students find direction and hope. You
can't recreate that by affording it into
a middle school or expanding it without
resources. What worries me the most is
that this plan came without real input
from Garza's community. These aren't
just members numbers. They're real kids
and real futures. Please don't dismantle
what's working. Protect Garza's protect
students and take it off the
consolidation list. Thank you.
My name is Jamie Thompson. I'm a parent
at Zilker Elementary. I am uh urging you
to remove Zilker from the Dawson Glendo
Becker Asante Tap and dual language
proposal. The recent decision to delay
portions of the consolidation plan did
not only create confusion and anxiety,
it significantly eroded trust in the
process. Proceeding now with a
non-essential boundary change that
further destabilizes a strong connected
school community would create
unnecessary disruption for two
communities instead of one, especially
in the wake of s such a sudden shift in
plans. Before the timeline changed, AISD
was close to affirming a more balanced
solution, assigning the Becker
attendance zone to Galindo rather than
to Zilker and restoring the Zilker
families who had been resoneed to
Galindo back to Zilker. I urge you to
move forward with and finalize that
approach. Superintendent Sagora had
expressed confidence in Glenda's ability
to succeed under this plan. Please
follow his leadership, affirm this
proposal, and keep Zilker's boundaries
stable. Thank you.
>> Hi, [clears throat] my name is Kelly
Cruz. I am a parent of three children at
Rididge School. I am zoned to Ridgtop.
Currently, my school is reszoned as
Riley Elementary right now. Uh, no no
plans for Riley, which element for Riley
Elementary, which concerns me since the
amount of students will go to Riley is
small. I would prefer to have choice
either Lee or Brentwood so that they
some of the neighborhood kids could see
some familiar faces. My other concern is
Riley will close because there will be
un under enrollment.
Um please think about um our our
students. Thank you.
This is my uh parent and community
member. I am concerned about the
stifling of voices, both community
voices and staff voices and forced
support and cheerleading behind this
plan that is very unpopular. Um, I have
concerning information about a person
over um,
elementary
um, as well as multiple people in comms
and administration
preventing community and staff voices.
Um, I also would urge the district to
get its house in order at headquarters
um before trying to roll out big
changes. Community trust is uh low and
we are not inspiring confidence that the
district can roll out these changes or
implement them. I'm concerned about the
top campuses and I believe that they
should be the focus rather than
shuffling around children and
reassigning children and changing pro.
This is Sai Salazar, a Becker parent.
Um, I just want to uh let the staff know
that um growing up I move around often
which made it hard to build lasting
friendships.
Because of that, I have made a stability
a top priority for my daughters. My
fourth grader uh attends Baker
Elementary. Um I chose the school
because the strong sense of community.
Um she began her education online during
the pandemic
and now with the social facing um with
the school facing the closure,
she won't have a chance to graduate
fifth grade uh with her classmates.
Instead, she had to spend her final
elementary school adjusting to a new
environment. I would like to request to
please save Becker. You don't understand
how hard is to create a community like
this in the US. Thank you.
Marilyn Faulner, AISD parent.
Superintendent Sigora, please directly
address and provide clear directives to
the entire AISD community who submitted
7,000 plus comment cards on plan
feedback. Do these comments need to be
resubmitted as a result of the breach to
fidelity in applying community feedback
to the updated plan as you shared in
your most recent district-wide email?
Without faith in the process and without
all community feedback accurately read,
recorded and considered, we the AISD
community and the trustees cannot have
faith that our voices are being heard by
the district, incorporated into
planning, or properly presented to the
trustees. Without resubmission, how can
we be assured our points and thoughts
have received fair consideration? Do you
direct us to resubmit all previously
submitted commentary so that we know our
voices are properly recorded and
respected? Thank you.
>> Hello, my name is Victoria Rios. I live
in Rosedale, five houses down from the
former school. We attended the October
20 meeting at Yarborough Library for an
update from AISD and OHT regarding the
planned 435 unit development and the
petition to reszone for highest density.
We were shocked at the rendering that
was shown that night and dismayed at the
regular reference to being like other
developments on Bernett. This is not
true. OT could not reference any
properties like what is planned for
Rosedale. They referenced the Clark
which is 226 units. Also, this site is
not on Burnett. It is accessed by three
regular neighborhood streets. OHT's own
estimation of upwards of 800 vehicles
accessing the property is unthinkable.
Please visit the site to understand what
is true and playf fair with Rosedale
neighborhood. Respect the deed
restrictions held by neighbors around
the school and work towards a more
reasonable development. We will have to
live with the consequences of whatever
is developed. Thank you for this
opportunity.
>> Hi, my name is Meg Halpin. an AISD
parent and I just wanted to share some
concerns about the current plan to close
10 schools um next summer and then
extend the timeline and propose to close
three more schools the following year um
which I understand is like the current
plan and thinking um and as a family
with a student who is currently in prek
at one of the wall toall dual language
programs that's closing proposed to
close at its current campus and move to
a new campus um our family would be
looking at starting him in in our zone
school for kindergarten next year. Um,
but our zone school is one of the ones
that, you know, we're talking about then
closing potentially the following year.
So, for a kid like ours, he'd be
starting in a third school by the time
he was in first grade. And I know our
family isn't the only one that would be
facing multiple disruptions um if the
current plan passes with schools planned
to close two years in a row. So, just
curious how the folks designing the
consolidation proposal are thinking
about mitigating those kind of cascading
disruptions for families like ours.
Thanks so much. Hi, I am a Garza High
School students parents and I'm calling
to leave a message for the board
regarding the possible relocation of
this program and about the additional um
middle school program being tacked on to
the existing program. Currently, Garza
High School's program is such a lifeline
and such a highlight for our district.
It is functioning so well and serving so
many vulnerable students and helping
them graduate. I would really like for
the board to consider the current makeup
of Garza students. It seems antidotally
like it is quite a few north um area
students and I'm wondering the
percentages of those and the impact it
would be to them to move to a more
southern location especially if Garza
does not provide transportation and it
is up to the students and their families
to get them there daily. The other
question I have is how a middle school
program might fit into the existing
program at Garza. Um, it really seems
structured around, you know, getting
kids to that graduation level and I'm
not sure what that would look like for
the middle school level students. It
also seems like there hasn't been much
discussion with the wonderful Garza
staff about Hi, Anna's uh concerns about
a community member. Uh, we were told
that there would only be small boundary
changes, not closing campuses, entering
into non-zoned campuses for our area.
Yet here we are with Zavala suddenly on
the chopping block and our families have
been given no time to respond. Zavala is
a thriving community school that has
worked hard to improve itself to a C
rating while nearby campuses are
failing. Um turning Zal into a monastery
campus for families from across the city
would erase the very heart of this East
Austin Latino community. This is not
transparency. It's not justice. Please
vote no on turning Zala into a non-zoned
campus. I'm a 60-year Austin resident,
Washington Gardenner Selby. Schoolboard
members, thank you for all you do and
good on you for recently removing a
couple neighborhood schools from the
shutdown plans. You're facing a tough
one. You're pinched by state
expectations, limited revenue, declining
enrollment. I'm speaking as fast as I
can because I'm urging you to preserve
every neighborhood school on the closure
list. You could stun and impress
everyone by saving money in creative
ways. Maybe first making all central
administration virtual. Try some new
ideas.
I'm a Balden resident. If this plan goes
through, you'll be cutting the heart out
of near South Austin by shuttering
Becker and Dawson elementarymentaries.
Do everyone a favor. Just go by and
listen to the students at recess. Now
imagine no such signs of life. Show off.
Show your strength by finding other
savings. Maybe start with a parentled
task force. Give them a hard deadline.
Again, thank you for all you do and
please do better.
Yes, this is Patrick Rosenthal. I want
to urge the board to put academics in
our district first. School closures will
never be the way to get us where we need
to go. What will move us forward is a
clear, strong academic framework, one
that every single campus can rally
around. Let's build resources into our
taps and focus on instructional quality,
not just facilities and numbers. We have
to set our district up for long-term
success by strengthening our academics.
Prioritize academics, invest in proven
teaching models, and be sure our
enrollment goals are built around
excellence and hope, not austerity. Our
students deserve a plan that's driven by
learning, not loss. Thank you.
>> This is Nika Ernnandez or Veronica
Hernandez. I am a former student and
current community member and current
Zeala parent.
Three generations of my family have
attended Zeala. This has been our home
school for generations for over for
decades.
If the monetary program were to come to
Zavala, this would mean that Zavala
would no longer be available as a home
school for my son who is currently
attending and doing an outstanding job
with our campus staff.
If if the monetary program were to come
to Zavala, this would also mean that
Zavala would close as a neighborhood
school to our children that are
currently attending and those to come.
This would also mean that we would not
have a neighborhood school within miles,
which is unacceptable.
Currently, the monetary program has
definitely proven not to meet
expectations at its current campus. Why
would we continue to bring a failing
program to a school that's not failing?
Thank you to all of our in-person um
speakers and all of our callers. This
concludes our public comment. Trustees,
are there any questions seeking
clarification? Trusty Hunter.
>> Yeah, I just want to clarify this. Um
one piece that I keep hearing over and
over because I'm not finding it to be.
So, uh Mr. Superintendent uh several
people over the last couple of weeks and
have mentioned and even in uh
communication we received in our email
have stated that uh employees are not
allowed to speak about the process. I
drop off at Garza every morning. They're
talking to me. Um I also have visited um
several different schools over the last
couple well all of my schools actually
that are in this part of the
consolidation and teachers have felt
free, principles have shared really
great stuff with me. So I'm not sure how
where the disconnect is.
>> Uh yes, Trusty Hunter, that is um not
any directive I've given at any point.
Uh we encourage engagement from all
staff, all community. Um I've been to
many many community meetings and at each
and every one of them I am certain um I
can say with confidence that there were
staff there um sharing with us um their
thoughts, their ideas and their
concerns. Uh we've also had a series of
meetings um that were led by uh Brandy
Hosk and her team um to have specific
conversations around um kind of the
transition process uh if the plan were
to move forward. Uh just to provide kind
of more of a kind of uh intimate
conversation because those are all
personnel conversations. Uh but
absolutely comment cards that we receive
are for both community and staff. Um
we're we're we're always always welcome
uh we always welcome um engagement from
staff. I I have not seen that as a
limitation
>> and I appreciate again I have an
invitation tomorrow uh from the pickle
uh uh staff to come and speak with them
and to well to listen to what I'm going
to be doing. And so um I I want to be
sure that staff understand that we are
here for them as well and that they can
speak to us uh through the systems that
we already have set up. Um, and I don't
know if we're going to have a chance to
do our two-way communication. So, even
that we're gonna have uh a chance to
kind of share like a I guess a state of
the district or whatever. Um, and then
still uh kind of do a little dream
walking with the staff if if we are I
think we are going to be doing that. And
so, um, just if you are feeling some
kind of way, then you can always DM me
like, you know, name. I won't share your
name. I just share the information. if
you're feeling some kind of way like
there's going to be some kind of
retribution and I'll still get your
ideas and it don't have to go any
further than the fact that I got an idea
and I can share that idea. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Additional uh comments for
clarification. Trust
>> uh one of the callers was asking about
the comment cards and whether they need
to be submitted again. Can you speak
speak to that piece?
>> No. Uh they do not need to be
resubmitted. Um I have reviewed all of
them. I um they all share um they all
present a perspective in our community.
Um I I recognize the value of community
voice. It's something we've always
believed in. There is no need uh to
resubmit uh any comments if you already
have done so. Uh all of those are
archived, preserved, valuated, and I
spend lots of time on the weekends going
through them um and making sure that we
have uh responses. Um there was a
comment also around the number. you
know, we do have um in many in many
cases, you know, several dozen if not,
you know, more than that that are all
around one specific um you know, topic
uh and and they can be distilled down to
kind of one response. So, it just the
number doesn't always equate to the same
number of responses because they all
sometimes are very similar. Uh, so just
wanted to make that clear because
sometimes, you know, someone will say,
"Well, there's been 500 been lots and
lots of comments around a specific item,
but they're all the exact same
comments." And so we'll have one
response because it meets the need the
request in all those comments if that
makes any sense.
>> Yeah. So maybe just to tag on to that
was that some of the additionally on
that end they were sent it seemed like
some of the comments were reduced down
or that it's was a summary statement or
you know can you
>> Yeah, I mean Yeah. So um what we do u we
produce this in our in our documents is
uh sometimes we get uh comments that um
have lots of things in them and we have
to kind of break them down into
actionable uh areas to explore and so we
will then kind of say well when I when
we review this comment these are the
things that we can take action on these
are things that require response and so
that may be what the caller was
referencing it's it's a process really
to understand all the different um you
know comments and ideas that we've
received. Um it's it's a process.
Do not manipulate any comments. We keep
them as they as we receive them.
>> Trusty Singh, um we had [clears throat]
a question about the the deed for
Ridgetop Elementary. I don't know if
there's anything you can say right now
if that requires additional research.
>> Um so, you know, in Austin ISD, you
know, we have 130 properties actually
with 136 I believe. uh many of them were
transferred to AISD well over hundred
years ago. Um many of them have uh you
know restrictions, commitments, uh
different things. Uh we are very aware
of where they exist. Um and you know as
as I think was mentioned by the caller
uh that is not a starting point for any
comprehensive uh work. It is something
that we understand and we work through
with our community and with our board uh
if we look at repurposing. So, um, we've
run into that in the past. We run into
it quite often, in fact. Um, so I
anything other than that, I would want
to share an executive session.
>> Thank you. Anything else?
>> Okay.
>> I I'll try to be brief. I just want to
make a comment and I want to commend you
and thank you, Matias, for the respect
with which you refer to every one of our
communities. um what I've seen, the
genuine listening and genuine attempts
to respond to questions and concerns
from every single community that's um in
this district, the respect that you pay
to every school and every um
professional community within our
district as well. And I just think that
is incredibly important. Um it is hard
to listen and hear comments talking
about failing schools, talking about a
lower quality of education, talking
about not wanting their kids to go to
that school. um when I know from every
school I visited that each one every one
of our schools has um many special
things going on regardless of what the
letter grade is and I know there's a
commitment by the district to attempt to
level out those ratings so that we can
make sure that our our schools are all
high rated according to the state system
but the fact that you see beyond that
rating and recognize the strengths that
each campus has um again it just hurts
my heart to hear community members who
probably have never visited that school
talking disparagingly about our
educators, our students, and our
communities. So, I appreciate that you
set the model, uh, set the example to do
different.
>> Thank you. Any additional comments,
clarifications?
All right. [snorts] Um, thank you again
to everyone who called to comment and
uh, please feel free to share any other
comments or questions with the board by
email at trusteesaustinisd.org.
Um, have a president's report as part of
our agreed order with TEA. requires that
we have to publicly report at our first
meeting each month the percentage of
time invested in student outcomes during
the prior three-month time period
according to Lonear governance and the
total time spent in closed session
during the prior month August September
and October three-month average board
meeting time spent on Lonear governance
defined student outcomes and special
education monitoring was 56%
and for October 2025 we were at 36% %
and the board spent 200 minutes in
executive session in October. We will
now move to information reports and
updates. Uh Mr. Sakura.
>> Yes. Um thank you, President Boswell and
board of trustees. Uh I'm going to do a
two-part um kind of overview um uh
presentation. I'll start first with
consolidations and then and then invite
the rest of the team up to provide an
update regarding our turnaround plans.
And so, um,
you know, we've said this and and we've
shared this, uh, but I think it's
important that we bring this, um,
forward again and and and the and that
is that, you know, our objective is to
ensure that every family in Austin has
access to an excellent neighborhood
school. Um, you know, and we know right
now that that's not the case. And that
was the driving uh force behind doing
something comprehensive.
uh and doing it at a time when there are
so many pressures uh within our system.
uh whether it's you know the pressure
from the federal government and how you
know changes in uh immigration policy
has impacted um our families whether
it's the state's inability to fully fund
public education whether it's the you
know evershifting accountability system
um the declining enrollment um the
increasing cost of of of of just living
in Austin uh these have put just extreme
pressures on the system and So to
achieve this goal uh of moving the
system forward through all of this, it
required something something bold um but
something uh very thoughtful. And when I
think about taking on these types of
efforts uh as we've done before with the
TRE order and special education or the
long-range plan or the 2022 bond program
or the effort around the tax rate
election, uh what I say often is that
process is everything. Um it has to be
uh we may not agree at the end of the
day the outcomes of a process but we
absolutely have to be um comfortable
about how we arrived um at that outcome.
And people know me as a you know process
person or someone that that really
believes in uh you know doing things
ethically doing things uh with integrity
and um that's just how I operate. Uh and
so when we think about this effort it
was important for me that each and every
each and every step along the way um we
ensured alignment with our values. Uh we
relied on the best data that we had and
we were always thoughtful um about um
how we collected community input and
voice and ensure that where we could we
would incorporate it into the plan. And
it's not lost on me that these decisions
that we're making are not, you know,
short-term decisions. These decisions
and the changes that we're recommending
will change this district really
forever. Um, you know, I talk about
50-year decisions or generational
change,
and I am someone uh that does show up.
Um, if community is there, I'm going to
be there. Uh, it's important that we,
uh, as a district commit to engaging
with community, listening,
understanding,
uh, offering, um, feedback um, as we
kind of process what we receive.
And over the last several days, uh,
there were things that were made, um,
known to me that, um, caused me to, to
pause, um, and really try to understand
if community voice during the refinement
part of the process, specifically around
boundary changes or balance enrollment
that um, included consolidations,
was fully being considered. And so
um because of that uh you know we
evaluated um all the work that had been
produced over the last many many months.
And uh for those of you that may not
know me I say I stay very close to all
the work. I'm very familiar with the the
you know 20 plus uh leaders um in our
steering committee. I am familiar with
the partners. I'm familiar with the
data. uh and I have extreme confidence
uh in the path that led us to a point
where we were beginning to pull in
community feedback. And so, uh, based
on, um, what we received and what, uh,
and the concerns that were brought to
me, um, and after a review, I was, um,
very confident that the work tied to the
turnaround plans, which was largely led
by school leadership, um, and our
academics team, uh, and the work, um,
tied to, uh, programmatic, um, changes,
which was largely led by our
multilingual education department as
well as our academics team. uh were
[snorts] sound uh and had incorporated
um feedback and were able to to proceed
um by way of a recommendation um for
November 20th. The workaround uh
refinements to boundary changes and
balance enrollment that includes
consolidations. However, um you know,
there were uh ideas from community and
there were um strategies that were
shared [snorts]
that I could not confirm had been fully
vetted, uh understood and considered um
as part of the plan. And so, uh because
of that and given where we are in the
process, uh I made the the very
difficult decision, um to modify the
milestone schedule. I want to be really
clear. Uh this had nothing to do with um
uh any community, any advocacy, any
voice, any the magnitude of emails. Uh
it is truly a function of my ability to
support a process uh that is completed
um all the way through um you know with
confidence, with fidelity uh and with
integrity. And so based on that um I
made some adjustments um as I said I
reviewed um all the related work
elements um to date um very long weekend
investigated an investigation has been
initiated uh and staff has been placed
on leave uh created a modified timeline
uh which hasn't been um finalized. We'll
seek to get feedback from the board um
before we uh come to a specific date. Uh
and then uh also update a list of
deliverables acknowledging that you know
when breaking up um deliverables it it
is quite a complex feat just given the
kind of denseness of the overall plan
and the complexity of it. And just to be
really clear, um this work uh is
continuing. Uh it is it is not canceled.
Um the need to align our school system
to improve feeder patterns is something
that I am committed to doing. Uh it will
be done. um ensuring that we have um you
know balanced enrollment across the
school system uh to just respond to the
decline in enrollment and ensure that we
have the resources deployed where they
need to be to ensure every student gets
what they need. Uh that work is
continuing. Um so I know that uh the
milestone changes have been received a
certain way but I want to be very very
clear uh this work is continuing.
Um I am committed uh to processes um to
our our goals and our district values.
Um that's that's not going to change. Um
as we move forward um just a couple high
level uh milestones for our community.
Um as you can see the um changes around
policies the changes around um
boundaries or consolidations associated
with turnaround plans or programmatic
moves um will continue. Uh we are still
refining uh as we get feedback even as
callers call in um just to make sure we
have the best version of a plan uh at
these milestones. And as you can see uh
on the bottom uh boundary changes and
balance enrollment consolidations will
continue but I do want to get feedback
and input from the board before we set a
specific date. Um
and as a um kind of an overview just
where we are. Uh there have been
adjustments but I do want to um identify
kind of where we are with the
consolidations that we expect to move
forward with on the 20th. You can see
here um Bington Elementary School,
Becker, Dawson, Oak Springs. Uh as I
said in the deliverable on the 31st, I'm
continuing to work with the Oak Springs
community in Black community. We had a a
a great meeting last night. Um so
there's still work going on. Um you
know, uh as Trusty Kaufman said, um
engaging is is is something that maybe
he's observed me do a whole bunch of. Um
these are meaningful conversations. is
they they absolutely
uh inform the work and so um even prior
to that meeting and since then there've
been lots of conversations uh and we're
trying to make sure that we have the
best solution possible given the
milestones and the constraints that we
have within the system uh ridgetop uh to
Riley Sunset Valley Cunningham and Boone
as you can see Rodriguez and Houston
again that's also an area of exploration
uh as we continue to have conversations
and then uh win monastery. We had a
conversation on Monday uh um with the
community. Um new ideas, other ideas
have been brought forward. Feedback from
the trustees and the last work session
uh has also been considered. So uh there
are still um some areas of refinement.
Uh but we are continuing on and I feel
confident we'll we'll be in a good place
um to get these um approved by the 20th.
And again, these are many of these are
tied to turnaround plans that are
required to be submitted by the state no
later than November 21st of this year.
Moving on to the programmatic um changes
uh the schools that um would be uh
receiving those programs and the changes
in assignment of students. You can see
those here. This slide has been
presented before. Um I'm not going to go
through each of them. Um but just want
to show any revisions on percentages. Uh
we did seek to reduce splits. We that
was one of the comments that we um uh
had heard and and so you have there are
some adjustments in the percentages. Um
and just as a um kind of clarification
on the bottom you can see uh Go Valley
that is still very much an area of
exploration. Um in the board work
session we heard about you know perhaps
exploring other schools. Uh it's not
settled. Um we're trying to get this one
uh right. Uh we understand the concerns
the board shared with us as well as the
community. Um so kind of taking that
coupled with the information we received
from the wind community uh is driving us
to hopefully a modified um plan. But it
these last weeks there there is a lot
going on, lots of conversations to get
community together to try to um progress
um the work um to get to that um
deliverable deliverable date which is
again required by the state for many of
these uh middle school closure and
reassignments. Um Betachch Middle
School, this is one that did change uh
previously.
Pedic Middle School, again, um this is a
turnaround plan requirement, was going
to be uh reassigned to four different
middle schools based on community
feedback. Um we've been able to reduce
that to three. Um Cington's still um
having the majority of the students um
from Betach and thereby receiving the
turnaround plan. And then Martin Middle
School, you can see what the breakdown
um in student populations again based on
assigned uh within the attendance
boundary. Uh I also heard loud and clear
um that there is a a desire and I
certainly have the expectation that we
move forward um and uh build out um
programming at both Martin and Betachch.
Uh there's this balance of not wanting
to create certainty around something
that has yet to be um explored with
community. Um so we're trying to find
that balance of this is what we heard,
this is what we know we can do, this is
the timeline we think we can do it in.
um but leave it, you know, open-ended
enough to where we have the space to
engage with community and truly bring in
um do something that is uh powerful in
the community but also um meets a need
within Austin ISD.
And then lastly, uh um secondary program
reassignments. Uh I I want to be really
clear um many of these do not require
board vote. Um we we've said this um
before. It's not often said though is
that you know programs um do move our
our schools and boundaries you know
they're static. Um international high
school uh we've we've mentioned this
before but given the number of students
that we have and the changes at the
federal level regarding immigration
um uh it's been we've seen a significant
dec decline. Uh it's unfortunate it's um
it's it's it's challenging. Um so we are
going to kind of reposition the program
at Navaro Early College High School. Uh
but it it will not um continue on in the
same way that it has, but we certainly
recognize the the importance of that
program. And then uh the alternative
learning center in Garza High School. Uh
this came up um by way of a work
session. As the callers mentioned, there
hasn't been a lot of engagement uh
around this um mainly because of all the
other uh conversations that have been
taking place and the fact that these are
programmatic moves. We will be engaging
uh we are have we want to have those
conversations. the alternative learning
center um moving to Mendes was was going
to be a short-term solution and as we
think about Mendes moving forward uh we
want to you know ensure that we have um
a school and and a program that can
meets the community need and also uh is
aligned um with um you know our school
um our school system and so just wanted
to provide that um update and to our
community I just want to apologize for
for the disrup ion. Uh I know this is um
challenging. I I'm I'm going to be
attempting to provide more clarity.
There are certainly things that I'm not
able to speak to. Um but I can promise
you, you know, I am um steadfast in
ensuring that the uh process that we go
through um is protected uh and is of the
um you know, highest integrity. And and
that's how I've always been and that's
what we're going to continue to do. And
so I'm there's a kind of a pause here.
We have about an hour for the total
discussion and I want to make sure we
cover turnaround plans, but I wanted to
see if there was needed to be a pause
here to talk about this specific part of
the conversation or if you wanted to
move towards and discuss turnaround
plans and then do it all together.
Is there a preference because I can the
team is prepared to come up to continue
on the turnaround plans with the time we
have remaining and then leave plenty of
time at the end for for questions.
>> What is our total time allocation again?
An hour
>> total and we've done 15.
>> We've done 15. So we could go, you know,
there are 15 on taps and then ask 30
question 30 minutes 30 minutes of
questions. [snorts]
>> Would that sound approp?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. All right. Team um please
transition. Uh we're going to have uh
Dr. Latana Emerson, assistant
superintendent of school improvement,
Dr. Wilson, assistant superintendent of
secondary school leadership, Jennifer
Pace, assistant superintendent of
elementary schools leadership, and then
[snorts] Joshua John, executive director
of governance, accountability, and board
services.
Um, all right.
>> Good evening, President Boswell,
Superintendent Sagura, and board of
trustees.
>> Is the mic on, Josh?
>> I think so. Might be too far away.
>> A little closer to you.
Uh all right, trustees. I wanted to
cover kind of a general timeline for the
TAP development. Uh August 13th uh was
the day that the 24 uh and 25 school
year accountability ratings were
released. The next day on August 14th,
TEA released a to the administrator
addressed correspondence. And in that
letter, they gave us guidance around
what to do or what kind of a campus
would qualify to submit a turnaround
plan. Uh some to develop and submit,
some to develop, submit, and implement
uh the turnaround plan. Right away, our
um team here drafted a SOP for the TAPS
um including a timeline for the TAP
development and then right away uh
getting into the work of forming a
campus intervention team at each of
those campuses.
Uh September 8th, [clears throat] TEA
gave us a helpful uh workbook, a TAP
workbook, which served to be a uh guide
for us to be able to build out a
template. And so we took that, built out
a tap template, and then we offered it
up to our campus intervention teams to
use uh to develop their taps. Um and the
at the same time September 11th through
the 30th uh we held community and staff
meetings at each of our uh campuses that
were required to develop a tap. Um and
from September 21st uh 1st uh through
October 13th, we continued to receive
some uh revisions to the TAP workbook,
to the success criteria. Um and so we
had to continue to make some changes to
our TAP template. Um,
and the last uh couple of uh items
there, uh, the Qualric survey, which is
the official way we're going to
ultimately submit our TAP plans, that
was released October 16th. Um, and that
was helpful. It did cause us to make a
little more refinements to our
templates. And then October 31st, uh, we
did receive some helpful feedback from
TEA on, uh, submission principles, and
that also helped us, uh, make final
refinements to our, uh, tab templates.
So currently we are receiving feedback
from the community. Uh we've received a
couple of versions of the taps and
posted them and um our um survey for the
second version is online and we're
receiving feedback through next Monday.
I wanted to talk through some of the
partners along the way. Uh we
[clears throat] uh were fortunate to
have uh experts in us um at some of our
partner organizations give us feedback
on our draft taps and that uh has helped
us in our development process. Uh region
13 has been helpful um and uh Texas
Education Agency Dr. Coleman um also has
been giving us feedback along the way.
today she confirmed that uh we're on the
right track um and gave us uh positive
feedback. Uh we also had uh curriculum
and instruction partners that we've been
working together with for the last
couple of years and uh we are continuing
to work through what that partnership
might look like um as we think about TAP
development and TAP implementation. And
finally, we have uh some technical
partners. uh we do have some
requirements depending on the tap
strategy uh for technical partners. If
it is uh an uh restart then we do have
to have uh commissioner approved
technical partner uh that we uh work
together with. Um and for schools where
we're applying for a grant as uh which
I'll cover later on, we do also have to
have some technical partners as part of
the application process.
Good evening, trustees. Superintendent
Sigora. I was going to talk through our
school improvement strategies. So, our
campuses that will um implement a
restart, also known as an ACE model is
Linder Elementary School, Wooldridge
Elementary School, Pareetis Middle
School, and Pan Springs Elementary. And
then our campuses implementing a
reassign strategy. Bington Elementary,
Betachch Middle School, Dawson
Elementary School, Oak Springs
Elementary School, Martin Middle School,
Sanchez Elementary School, when
Montasauri and Wedane.
And we have two campuses um that are to
UA that will also implement a reassign
strategy um but it's by way of program
moves and that is Wooten Elementary
School and Pickle Elementary School and
our school improvement uh strategy
schools. This is also known as intensive
curriculum and instruction strategy. TA
Brown, Go Valley, Hart, Houston, Jordan,
Norman, Sims, Overton, Hadron, Saddler,
Means, East Side. [clears throat]
Um, and strategy selection. I just
wanted to share a little bit about how
that was uh what influenced the strategy
selection. Uh, first was just a
commitment to serve students and their
communities. Additionally, capacity at
nearby campuses impacted the decision.
empty seats in the region, modernization
projects and facility condition,
accountability ratings at nearby
campuses,
availability of TIA designated teachers
and leaders with turnaround experience
and program changes such as campuswide
dual language uh moves.
We know that stakeholder engagement is
foundational um to the sustainability of
school improvement work. And so over the
past few months, we've prioritized
authentic community engagement. What you
see listed on the slides are um what all
three UA campuses, two UA campuses and
campuses that are proposed to receive a
turnaround plan have committed to and
engaged in which includes the um
community meeting held by the
superintendent. Uh CAC meetings,
principal coffees, staff meetings,
surveys, uh schools also allotted for
printed copies of the taps at certain
central points throughout the school so
that parents community and community
members could give feedback. uh was
posted on the school improvement page.
There were also tap surveys and feedback
forms given out and then staff and
student mental health and well-being
support. In addition, many principles
have gone above and beyond by leveraging
their own school-based communication
channels such as newsletters, um their
own family nights or community forums to
include teachers, student, staff, and
parent voice in the improvement process.
Through these ongoing conversations, we
are building stronger connections with
families and we're also ensuring that
our school improvement work reflects the
needs, values, and aspirations of the
communities we serve.
I wanted to cover, uh, some of the
grants that we'll be going out for. Um,
and so,
uh, we have a variety of lasso grants
here listed, uh, for school improvement,
for curriculum and instruction support.
Uh we're considering Sadler Means um and
Parades Middle School. Uh we
uh specific to restart uh school action
uh we're considering Linder, Pakan
Springs, Waldridge, and U Parades again.
Uh and for reassign uh Bington
Elementary uh one thing we're
considering for um a number of our
campuses uh at the elementary and middle
school levels uh is the adsy calendar.
Uh that is to get to a base of 175
school days and then beyond that there's
some flexibility on adding half days for
subgroup of students. is no uh not a
compulsory day for students and so we
can be strategic about uh how to support
students. Uh it could be uh uh at the
beginning of the school year um perhaps
inviting students back earlier than
everyone else um including summer
school. Um another thing we're uh
considering at this time and vetting is
the opportunity to apply for the TEA
resource designation. Uh that um would
mean that those campuses there there's a
variety of um requirements, but uh we
would have to at least get to 181
calendar days for those campuses. Uh but
it provides for the funding levels of an
1882 campus um in perpetuity. Uh once we
get this designation uh and we're in
good standing, uh it will provide that.
And so we're looking at all of these uh
ways to be able to support our campuses.
>> All right. And I just want to talk
through some of the key implementation
strategies. First of all, all of the
campuses engaged in a comprehensive
needs assessment, analyzing quantitative
and qualitative data, longitudinal and
disagregated data, campus comparative
data, um observation data, PLC data,
campus scorecard data. [snorts] And from
that some of the tr the root cause
analysis trends that were identified
included the need to increase
instructional leadership capacity
um to improve instructional management
systems, a variety of staffing needs um
stemming from vacancies, certifications,
waiverss for class size ratios um and
then increased need for student supports
and services.
So you'll see at the top where it says
the school improvement strategies. These
are strategies that we would implement
at all of our TAP campuses. That would
include the lighthouse model um just to
expand that support for all TAP
campuses.
Um capacity building develop which would
include developing ILT and instructional
leadership through professional learning
and instructional rounds.
implementing an aligned curriculum
consistently through the use of HQIM and
implementing it as intended and
wraparound and transition supports that
would be supported um through our bridge
team planning and then attendance and
engagement planning uh using our MTSS
system and data tracking to plan
individualized supports for students.
And finally, our effective schools
framework. Um, strengthening leadership,
strategic staffing, welcoming uh having
a welcoming campus culture with high
expectations.
And then in the middle, you'll see uh
the section about campuses moving to a
campus that has a D-rating or an
unacceptable rating. Those campuses
would receive the same um supports as
above. However, we would include
strategic staffing supports to increase
the number of teachers who have TIA
eligibility or that meet highly
qualified criteria. We would also
increase instructional um staff support
and have smaller class ratios, student
teacher ratios.
Additionally, we would provide
differentiated transition support and
student support. And that could look
like additional counselors,
restorative practice coordinators, and
increased access to community resources
[snorts]
and increased coaching and monitoring.
And finally, campuses moving to C-rated
campuses would include the same
strategies above, but we would
differentiate the intensity of support.
>> Good evening, trustee. Superintendent
Sigerta, I'd like to offer an update on
our three restart campuses. Um, they
were district managed and, uh, the
implementation of the school models were
aligned to ACE. Um and the presentation
that I'm going to offer this evening um
will be in alignment with the five
pillars. The first pillar is effective
leaders and teachers um in order to
build leadership capacity at the restart
campuses. Uh one of our uh community
partners provides uh on-site
professional development to the campus
teased and this is at all three
campuses. The sessions are on-site and
virtual. They're cyclical in nature.
They offer immediate feedback, action
planning steps and followup. They create
short cycle goals in order to monitor
process, excuse me, progress. The
executive directors also visit the
campuses a minimum of two to three times
a week based on the calendaring um and
what's going on uh with the rest of
their their schedules, but a minimum of
two to three times a week. And they also
work with the partner to ensure that
they're all engaged with the work uh
together. For coaching and feedback,
this is a push-in model. It involves
observations, modeling, coaching
conversations, corrective feedback. They
offer monitoring tools, coaching
protocols, and um all the things related
to ensuring that they understand how to
effectively lead tier one instruction.
The campus leaders are strengthening
their capacity through intentional
coaching, feedback cycles aligned to
instructional priorities. For PLC's,
they're leveraged as a key structure for
collaboration. Teachers and leaders
engage in lesson internalization. to
analyze student work and then make
instructional decisions based on
evidence of learning. The next pillar,
instructional excellence, involves first
high quality instructional materials.
Um, for English language arts, they're
using my perspectives or SAVAs. For
math, they're using STEM scopes. The
leaders and teachers are receiving
ongoing training and support to deepen
their understanding of the curriculum
and to ensure that they're embedding
research-based instructional practices.
The training sessions incorporate
district created protocols and involve
the ACS's from the academics department
to ensure that we're always always
working with our internal departments.
The implementation of high quality
instructional materials with fidelity
ensures that all students have access to
grade level content. When teacher
created materials are introduced into
the less into lessons although they c
they can also be high quality do risk or
may compromise the rigor level of the
TEIK and we don't want to compromise
that unintentionally
data-driven action plans instructional
decisions are driven by data in order to
close learning gaps and accelerate
student growth. Teachers use the data to
revise intervention groups, to tailor
their small groupoup instruction, and to
address specific areas of need. Um, they
use the data to provide opportunities
such as before and after school
tutorials, extended week, also known as
Saturday school, and also to uh continue
progress monitoring so that they can
make instructional uh adjustments as
needed. The next pillar is the extended
out of school time pillar. This is that
one day out of the week Wednesday where
they stay for the additional hour.
During the day um the students engage in
lessons created by academics team in uh
reading and in math and uh also
character strong. Those are done on um a
daily basis. I'd like to point out that
our special education team has also
created specialized lessons for our most
vulnerable students to ensure that they
are able to engage in those
opportunities as well. The next pillar
is character development. This is
formerly uh social uh social emotional
support. Uh the district uh prioritizes
holistic development of students through
a focus on character development. Uh
again I mentioned those lessons that can
also happen during that Wednesday also
happen every single day. I also want to
point out that each of the restart
campuses were allotted a wellness
counselor. So, we wanted to make certain
that those students also had um in
addition to the other caring adults,
another person that specialized and
trained in that area. Last but not
least, the LA the pillar of parent and
community partnerships. Strong
partnerships with families in the
community remain central to student
success. The parent support specialists
lead efforts to engage families through
workshops. The DCCE department provided
a scope and sequence to all of the
restore campuses, giving them topics
that they could share with the uh
parents for the remainder of the year.
They do so by way of CAC meetings and
other coffees or any other um evening
activities that the school may offer.
The family resource center continues to
provide critical support services like
access to food, clothing, vaccinations,
payment assistant, and just reduce any
barriers that our families could be
facing. And we do have F FRC's at each
of the restart campuses.
In addition, we do have quite a few um
volunteers interested in supporting
these campuses. So, we've had um leaders
from our OSI office train in volley so
they could help our uh parents and
community members sign up to volunteer
uh at these campuses. An example would
be UT Math tutors that currently serve
at Dolby. Uh lastly, Austin Voices has
been a dedicated partner. They provide
direct support to all three restart
campuses. They offer bi-weekly virtual
meetings to strengthen coordination to
give our families and community members
a space to share their thoughts and that
is provided back to our campus leaders
so they can make uh adjustments.
So what have we learned from this
process and what can we apply as we
continue to create uh future plans with
our high quality instructional material.
Having more time in advance uh would
have helped the teachers in the
preparation period. Uh we know we had a
short runway um an accelerated timeline
in order to staff um but had we had more
time we would have done more preparation
um in response to that. um in uh
partnership with the academics team, we
did create a PD cycle to establish and
incorporate trainings for late hires as
people that came on board just to make
certain that all of our teachers were
equipped. Um the curriculum is new to
some and we wanted to make sure that
everybody was comfortable with the
material. Um in terms of funding uh
considerations, Dolby Webb and Bernardet
uh teachers and leaders uh have been
incentivized, but with the number of
turnaround plans that uh we're creating
right now, we will have to revisit um
stipens and how uh leaders and teachers
are incentivized, we may need to make
adjustments um to those amounts and we
may also need to revisit the pay
schedule. Right now, um the stipens are
paid out every pay period. We may need
to look at each semester. In terms of
staffing, I did mention the accelerated
timeline due to the time of year and the
accelerated timeline and full
transparency. Some of our campuses had
vacancies at the beginning of the year
and they still do. Uh with having more
time with the upcoming turnaround uh
plans, uh we see opportunity to make
sure that we can adequately staff our
campuses with teachers and leaders. Uh
principles are being creative um with
these situations. For example, some of
the instructional coaches may have to be
teachers um and they may have to be
teacher coaches as well to cover
classes, but we're making sure that
every student has a caring adult. Uh in
terms of uh department collaboration,
what we've learned is that in Austin
ISD, there is a shared sense of
[clears throat] urgency and that has
been a very intricral part in moving the
work. departments from academic
staffing, talent development, etc. have
all been hands on deck to ensure that
the work move forward at this uh at
these campuses. Last but not not least,
professional development. Um we found it
very beneficial to um create
opportunities for the resource to learn
as a cohort. Um that's the model that
we've used and what it's done is created
a PLC across the campuses uh like a
horizontal PC if you will and teachings
helping teachers and leading uh leaders
helping leaders has been uh most
beneficial.
>> All right, we're about to we need to
finish this up. Tarter, I mean sorry Dr.
John, [laughter] can you get in 10
seconds summarize the last slide on
milestones?
>> Yep. Uh the I think the key date is that
November 21st is the deadline to submit
all of our tabs and so we have that uh
to up to vote on November 20th.
>> Thank you very much. Um trustees
questions about this and I would like to
say um before we have questions I had a
conversation with Ashley our lonear
governance coach. It is entirely
possible to have a workshop about this
where we focus on the student outcomes
piece of it um very specifically in the
same way we've done with our budget
before in the same way we did with
consolidations. I think given the
importance of this, I know we are
spending an immense amount of time staff
and trustees right now talking about all
of this, but it is also really really
important. I would like to propose that
we have a workshop between now and the
20th. Um, so we have the opportunity to
really talk in depth about these
turnaround plans. Um, we have an hour,
we have 50 minutes left for conversation
tonight. I think we take what we can um
but also might benefit from an
additional chance to talk about this
together and Ashley said she would help
us.
>> Let's just nail that down right now
because uh what's the time for posting?
>> Well, that's what I was say the we would
need to post by the 14th um ideally.
Correct. Is that correct Josh?
>> Yeah. So, we would need to post three
business days ahead and the day of the
meeting is day zero.
>> Well, but I don't think we want to do it
on the 20th. No, we don't want to do it
as quickly as we can.
>> But the week of the 20th is out because
So it's next week. So like if we could
post tomorrow, we could have one next
week.
>> So
>> yes, so we'll we'll coordinate our
calendars with Josh. So and get it as
quickly as we can. Thank you.
>> Okay. So first question.
>> Oh, well just to be clear, I mean I
think there's only probably two days
given where we are posting now that you
could actually have it
>> Thursday or Friday
>> of next week. So it's not Monday or
Tuesday and Wednesday are out.
>> Okay.
I will make myself available. Okay.
Thank you.
>> Okay. [snorts]
>> Um I'll be um super brief. Um just a
noticing I heard um adjustment to
stipens. Um that's been a big piece of
our staffing. And so I'm I'm hearing rec
there's dollar issues at hand. Um I'm
also hearing um teachers as coaches.
Is that what a teacher?
>> No, instructional coaches.
>> Teachers as instru.
>> Oh.
>> And so they may have to be teachers but
also be coaches of the teachers.
Instructional coaches
>> retaining the title instructional coach
but having additional
>> if they need to cover
>> formal teaching responsibilities. Okay.
>> And and Trustee Foster, just um so
you're aware, this is a an ongoing um
opportunity for the district. We've
actually had lots of principles, lots of
staffs actually request this because it
allows an instructional coach to also
get the stipen. It allows flexibility in
the system. So, I know it sounds like
it's a cover because of a gap, but we
actually addresses a a much larger
desire in the system to create
flexibility for those who want that
siphon.
>> Awesome. and and so that I'm already
getting a little more clarity, but I
will enjoy the time when we can talk
about it more in depth because that
sounds um rich and complex and fraught
and maybe a font of opportunity. So
that's cool. Um lastly with regards to
all of this, one of the pieces of the
puzzle uh for the retention and
celebration and lifting up and well the
retention of talent has been retire
rehires and there's been stipens
associated with them. Is there anything
going on with that? It's it's um so
Brandy um our chief and talent uh off
talent strategy officer it's not a
stipen t in since the pandemic what we
did was actually offset the co the costs
that the employee incurs to be a retire
rehire um and so that before the
pandemic I don't I understand that was
not the case after the pandemic we put
that in place um we we have to get off
that um because it is a pretty
significant expense uh so it's it It
wasn't a stipen. It was just for a
period of time in order to get, you
know, staff the way that we needed to.
We offered that. Um, so we're looking at
going back to the way that it used to be
before the pandemic.
>> Would that be an effective pay cut?
>> I mean, we are it would be a
total compensation would be adjusted,
correct? If they chose to stay with us.
>> All right. So, this is an area of of
deep concern
>> and this is an area comment on that real
quick before you express that concern.
The challenge, as I understand it, has
been that because of TRS rules, when a
teacher is retired through the teacher
retirement system, they're receiving a
full pension. If they come back into a
school district, then there's a penalty
for that because the district now has to
incur the costs of paying for their
double dipping. There's a search charge
that they now have to pay because
they're benefiting, they're drawing from
the fund at the same time as normally
people would be paying in. So, I would
just like to frame it in the sense of
people who are drawing a full stipen
with a full pension would have the
opportunity to have a full-time job at a
full salary with a minor percentage cost
of paying the the penalty themselves. I
I think it's I I I would not frame this
as a negative thing for the people who
are able to rejoin their the career they
love and receive a substantial double.
>> Got it. So, I guess that would have to
be um And thank you for the
clarification which I'm still like
[snorts]
third grader trying to understand sixth
grade level stuff here. Um
an area of exploration because it has
been raised as a concern. So if there's
an explanation and you know you can help
me understand and let's not do it
tonight be um I I mean no unless it's
advisable to do it tonight or
>> I think Trusty Coffin did a great job.
>> Just really fast. We can also job share
that to 19.5 hours and nobody has to
incur a cost. him about the 19 hours
where you don't lose the
>> right there. Everybody was schooling me
on like um
>> but one thing I'm just noticing with all
of that is the strain on our budgets is
leading us to in some ways innovate in
really interesting ways. But it also is
just such a powerful strain. I can feel
the ways you all are trying to make
things work which
requires investment of dollars that we
basically don't have. So I appreciate
your hard work on this and I'm hearing
that we need thoughtfulness on all the
plans but we're going to need backend
thoughtfulness on how we finance these
plans as well.
And I I will limit myself to that.
>> Thank you. Trusty Hunter,
>> these are actually questions uh that I'm
actually gonna forward uh to Josh. Um
I'll give you the whole thing and if
there's one you can tackle now um
regarding um the turnaround plans uh
trustee um Kintana uh says uh how is the
district scheduling? Have you scheduled
a meeting with Go Valley? She wants to
know about transportation uh when it
comes to the um monastery program. She
wants to know about uh the why the
monastery was not included in the
financial appendix of the plan. Um is
there interest from the community to uh
expand Gar's program. I think she
probably has her answer if she's she's
not feeling well, but if she's still
with us, I think she understands that
one. Um how will expanding Garza's
program hurt the current program? And if
Garza is not moved to Martin, what are
the options for Martin? So you have
those now. If there's something you can
um sum up or the superintendent can
answer quickly, I think we'll be or in
time.
>> Yeah. Um I we'll provide a complete
response to Trusty Canthana. Um on the
quickly for the um go valley uh so when
monasori already receives districtwide
transportation um and I I did from uh
the conversation on last Wednesday it
was clear to me from the trustees that
there was a real concern with having
students in the neighborhood who were
going to the neighborhood school to be
displaced right because they not able to
access the full monastery program um so
we are still exploring other ideas um
the feedback she shared and the feedback
that I've gotten from trustees in the
community is and latest feedback from
the wind monastery. Um so we'll provide
a response to her uh and to the board
regarding that on the um ALC Garza
Martin. Uh you know, one of the things
that we've heard was that the Garza
program um is a very it's an incredible
program. It's unique program and there's
been a desire to expand it. We have not
had those conversations u because it is
programmatic. It doesn't there's no
boundary change there. There's nothing
of the sort, but we do want to have the
conversations. We want to be
transparent. Um we right now we are um
going to still have those conversations.
So it's too early to tell what support
exists, doesn't exist, um what it will
look like. One of the things that we
have to consider is that the
accountability um process and system for
Garza is very different than every other
high school. And so if you expand, you
know, how do you expand um what impact
does that have on accountability?
Typically the high school is what
anchors the accountability, but when
it's a a unique program, what will that
look like? So there's conversations to
be had in full transparency. We haven't
we haven't gotten into the the details
of that those moves. So um I we built a
team to do it. Um we're going through it
but we're not quite ready to give you
all the details on how that would work.
Uh and also if there's support um but
it's going to again in an effort to
create space at Mendes with ALC with
Martin wanting to be reactivated sooner
than later based on we heard from
community it seemed like an option worth
exploring. Again, back to the community
input, community voice, you know, trying
to find solutions that meet multiple
needs. So, still work to be done.
>> Thank you. I'll just go next since I'm
already got the mic. Um,
regarding the taps. Um, thank you for
the update on Doby Web and Bernett. Uh,
we've discussed Garza. She has shared
some of my questions. some of the same
questions I have uh for when Monasuri
but I do want to lift up that um and
you've heard this because you were
standing right there when the community
member made the comment that with our
dual language programs we are moving the
programs to where students are but as it
refers to Monasuri we're moving the
program away from where the students are
um I had a really thorough explanation
uh about Monasuri with uh scholar Dr.
Far must almost gave her a honorary
doctorate degree with principal farre
and I do understand now how monastery
fits within the tea system and that it
has been done and it can be done. I
still have
reservations
because I haven't seen the support to
that degree. It's like a one-off, right?
Like if you make pies all the time and
then you you like somebody's like, "Can
you make me a cake?"
>> And you're just like, "Sure, I can make
a cake. I make pies, but it's not the
same thing. And right now, AISD is
making pies all day, all day long. And
this community, they want cake, and I
want to give them cake, but I'm not
sure.
I'm taking this metaphor that like our
kitchen is prepared to do this, right? I
have no doubt in the parents because
they built it from the ground up. I
don't have any doubt in the leadership
because they have done the work without
the support. if we have some magic
secret sauce that's going to happen in
the future, why aren't we using it now?
So, that is my concern and my question.
Um, I'll bring it up again when we have
our workshop. Um,
>> well, so just just to be um so uh I want
to be really clear, you know, if if
we're going to have a program moving
forward, we will support it. I I think
Lkesha um during the work session
mentioned um you know and even being at
the wind community meeting we talked
about what occurred in 2223 with Bridget
Farre uh principal far coming on board
the work the community has done the
progress that it's made it has been an
uphill battle for sure uh but 2223 isn't
that long ago I I know it feels like a
long time ago but in terms of schools
and systems it really isn't that long
ago um I did hear from the community as
you did trustee Hunter that the desires
to stay in the area. Um the question
becomes what would be a alternative
location that we could kind of get
consensus from the community that would
be acceptable. Um and I think you know
that that is I don't want to say a name
because then it creates a disruption and
there's just a lot of things that go
with it. But that's what is like
occurring right now. like I need to
understand, you know, kind of where that
opportunity exists or doesn't because as
I heard from the wind community, if if
the opportunity is to stay low in the
area and then I'm hearing from the
community around Ortega, Zavala and Go
Valley and from trustees that that is we
do not want to disrupt neighborhood
schools there. Then you quickly get to a
place where you know to address the tap
and you don't have a home then then is
it viable? Right. So so that that is
what we're quickly running into. So it
sounds like from trusty hunter from your
perspective there's perhaps support for
win monasuri if it can be done locally
and there's a commitment from the
organization to ensure that it is
implemented with fidelity from the
administration side. Is that correct?
>> All right sorry that was a longwinded
way to just kind of like [laughter]
>> and um lastly as as um concerns the the
tap I'll go quick and then I I just have
a quick comment. Um there's a great
concern about international um I don't
know if you remember but when I was just
Miss Hunter Northeast uh Reagan mom uh
and they were going to move um
international from east side like they
had talked to nobody and we seem to have
trouble with that part um and I called
Dr. I was like Elazald's office and I
was like no you have to have meetings
and I went to all those meetings like I
was the only person with English right
because the meetings were majority in
Spanish but what we said is if they went
to northeast that would be their forever
home
>> now I understand that the current state
of our country has reduced that number
down at that school and I understand
that it's totally logical to move it to
Navara one of our most like kind of
international schools like organically
My concern is and the concern of the
people at international is do we just
become ESL like how are we still
international which what makes us
international IHS how do we continue
that program so I in our workshop I
really want to as as much as we can have
detail on that because there's a lot of
concern that they're just going to be
absorbed into the high school and just
be teaching ESL
>> and so um I know you probably have some
questions about that also so in our
workshop if we can have that prepared
and ready to go. I'd appreciate it.
Finally, my comment. Josh, you're
supposed to have two clocks running.
>> Um
>> um but trusty Hunter, just on on that
question,
>> um there wasn't necessarily a concern
about not having it be its own high
school.
>> Um because, you know, we made a
commitment to you know, International is
[snorts]
a very slow small student population at
the moment. I mean, it is very very
small. Um, and the plan was to move away
from having its own CDN number and being
its own school. Um, just because we
don't, it is very, very small.
>> Um, so what I'm hearing from you, not
necessarily concerned about going to
from a school to a program, but more the
location and perhaps what it turns into
if it's not protected.
>> No. So the location makes sense. Okay.
Right. The concern is international just
being
>> absorbed.
>> Absorbed, right? like and if like if
it's a program like what what what
program is it? Like how is it like
there's no specificity around it being a
program, right? Is it ESL? It's not dual
lang. I mean like what is it, right? Um
and so that's the the clarification that
uh again teachers are asking me. So um I
I want to be able to give them answers.
I I think the administration um I think
it's important because again it a lot of
we're talking about closing schools
right now and moving people and this is
a group that has already been moved.
>> Yeah. And that decision was made in
April of 23 for like a move in August of
203. Um so you know we're we're we're
going to get it right. We're going to
spend the time. Um just
>> I don't want I don't want the time to be
the same. It was different that time.
>> I I know I I was there man. You remember
when I call your office every day to get
the signs up every
at Northeast? Um I just want to talk
about two two pieces two documents that
have kind of been guiding me in this
process and I'm happy to share this with
any board member. Um this is about
closing schools and it's basically like
don't close schools and it has like
these false narratives and it has like
if the administration says this yes or
no and it's literally like got a little
yes no yes no and I've gone through it
and we have a lot of yeses, right?
Right. And so when you get to them,
they're like, "Okay, so you probably
need to close a school. This is how it
must be done." So there's been and I've
had this since when did we go to
Chicago?
>> July.
>> July. I've had this since July.
I first mentioned school closing in
November of 23
because I kept hearing that we didn't
have when Ed was sitting there saying,
"We have money troubles. We have money
troubles." And I asked him at that time,
I said, "Hey, does this mean we're going
to close schools?" Right? And so I have
been thinking about it and having sat
through another school, having been
through a school closure once before, I
know how painful it can be. The second
thing that has been guiding all of my
work is this document. I don't know if
you guys have read this, but this is
what we already know, what every black
family has known for years, what every
Hispanic family has known for years,
what every poor family has known for
years. This district is lopsided. And
David already stole my thoughts over
there. Granny Way would be so very proud
of you because it hurts my heart to hear
people say
a more quality. What you think these
people are fighting for? You think
people are happy? No. We have not served
them well. And this is an attempt to
serve people well.
And I said it in 2019 and I will say it
again.
If you have racial, economic, or uh
educational privilege, there is
something going to be asked of you. And
I said then and I'll say it now. It's
going to feel like you're being done to,
but all we're asking you to do is just
share the load. And it's not lopsided
where we're saying only close A or B or
C schools. It's what can we do to make
it better for everybody. Cuz I promise
you, the B schools and the A schools in
Houston wish they had have been on the
front line. The A and B schools in Fort
Worth wish they had have been on the
front line. San Antonio nine. No, San
Antonio 18.
>> I think it's next. It's like uh
Edgewood, North Side. I never even heard
of the other school. There's This is not
something that's just happening in
Austin. There's something fundamentally
wrong with the system. All the way down.
There are schools in Texas having to do
these tap turnaround plans and they're
all due on the same day.
Uh Colleen just voted already November
25. They just voted on their turnaround
plans. This is an epidemic and we need
everybody. I used on the podcast that we
are on the Titanic and we are trying to
change it. Some of us have been down in
Steridge bailing water for a real long
time. And some people have been in the
dining room listening to the orchestra,
but guess what? We are on the same boat.
We have got to do this together. Thank
you.
>> That was really good. Thank you, Trusty
Hunter. um
second everything she said.
Um so my comments fall mostly in like
into two categories. One is we do things
the AISD way and the other thing is the
other bucket is implementation fidelity.
And so that's what my comments on the
tap are about. So I'm just going to run
through um so implement under the bucket
of implementation fidelity. Um, I'm
really excited to see the budget for
each tap that, you know, when I see a
detailed budget, that means I know we're
actually going to do what we say we're
going to do. And so I know that's, you
know, TBD in the draft taps that we
have, but I would love to have some
semblance of budget available for the
workshop so we can ask questions
specifically about that. Um the other
thing is related to um so this one's
about um the Austin way summer
programming um for community building so
kids are ready to learn when school
starts. So for these schools where we've
got kids splitting up into other
schools. Thank you by the way for
reducing the splits. Um but still like
we got to pay attention to all the stuff
the previous board when you know with
the previous board we did so much with
Dr. Bruce Perry and social emotional
learning and trauma-informed education.
And I feel like we have an opportunity
to revive that as we think about the
taps. Um, and like we know that when
kids are experiencing big change or
trauma, um, we need to do a whole lot to
help them be sure that they are
available and ready to learn. And I
don't see much of that at all in the
taps. And part of it is because the tap
form does not really have a category for
that. But that's the Austin way is to
put it in there. And so I really really
do want to see um I know we're I know
we're all thinking about it. I can just
tell by looking at your faces that this
resonates. Um let's if there's a way to
put that in the official tap, let's do
that and hold ourselves accountable to
it and have budget associated with it.
That's really important um for our
kiddos. Um the other one was um do we
have an estimate on the number of
transfer ARS um that are going to have
to take place at our TAP schools for
students that are going to another
school and um what is our capacity to
handle that and what does that actually
add to our expenses? Um and I want
numbers details um with all of this
because again this this falls into the
implementation fidelity um piece of
things. Um, this one goes back to the
Austin way parental involvement. Um, you
know, we we took this off of our our
scorecard recently, which was the whole
um the dual capacity framework and I
would love to see us talking about that
in the taps itself because um all I see
really even in the needs assessment at
least for the ones that I kind of spot
checked it was talking about PTA
meetings and CAC's and we know like that
just scratches the surface. That's
nothing about the things that many of us
trustees and many of you all have talked
about as well which is do parents
understand how their child is doing
academically.
>> I want to know like how we are making
sure that happens. Um I just I don't
think just having a PTA and a CAC is
going to cut it. um
you know wi with our TAP schools you
know so anyway and again the TAP does
not ask for a robust plan in the TEA's
form but I know that's the Austin way
and so that's why I'm I'm bringing it
up. Um the other thing that would just
be helpful to have prepared for trustees
is just like a one paragraph summary of
like how this tap is going to be
different from already what already
exists at the school. It's hard to
discern that from the the format that
TEA provides. Um but just like if you
were just talking to me like hey what
are they actually doing different at at
you know this school or that school. Um
I just want to know in a nutshell um
what that is and that I think that will
help our community um also understand.
Um the last well one of my last
questions is how many parents at schools
um at that are being closed and split
know that their child is going to be
reassigned to a new school next year?
Like
do we know?
>> I mean we've sent letters. I mean I I I
don't know of an exact number. I mean
>> yeah. Okay. Because like I I'm just
asking
>> I mean that would require confirmation
of of their I mean like I I don't
>> Yeah. Okay. So I I think what I want to
know like we didn't hear from any
parents really tonight from cap schools
who are in this situation, right? And
and so I don't want to assume that they
know just because you know these are
also oftentimes parents who are um you
know have the least amount of time to
make a public comment. So, I just want
to make sure that we're going the extra
mile and preparing students and families
and making sure that they understand
their child is going to a different
school next year and and having a really
good conversation with them and a
personal connection so that they stay in
AISD. They don't feel like we don't care
about them anymore. Um, this I don't
want to none of us wants to see our
families leaving, but again, um, it
would be really reassuring to see that.
um
academic framework. I know that we're
going to be doing a lot and none of the
you know um I just wanted to shout out
to a resource that I think could be
really helpful as we're doing our
academic planning is the learning policy
institute has an equitable whole child
um design which you know falls under the
Austin way I guess um heading and I
don't know if there's space for just the
staff to take a look at that or or at
least state like if there's some sort of
cohesive framework that we're looking at
that mentions the whole child. Like
that's what I'm looking for because
right now when you read the taps it just
looks like a bunch of programs that that
like don't have a whole lot of heart to
me. Although I know they're good but tea
just is looking like do they have TNP
TNTP? Do they have an HQIM? Do they have
this or that? But like what is the real
thing that a family um like that's
really making sure that we're looking at
the whole child. And then the last thing
promise um is
uh somebody asked I think this in public
comment
was how are burn and web doing um and
what are we learning from that I I
appreciate your presentation Dr.
Emerson. That's that was really great to
see. Um I specifically want to see the
beginning of year test scores for those
three schools. Um and then compare that
to how they did last year. And um same
thing with attendance. And I think that
just gives us some real tangible data to
really think about what we're doing is
actually the right approach. Um oh and I
sorry I do have one last thing. overall
um the transportation and budget for um
whatever we're going to be voting on
because now it's been changed. So
whenever you bring us that package on
the 20th um I just want to make sure
that we have like a really clear budget
um with all the new costs and stuff. So
just a few you know just a few little
things if you have time uh would be
really [laughter] but that that's what's
top of mind.
>> Yeah. And I think on the um so if the if
the work session um makes on Thursday
that would be the appropriate time to do
the deeper dive on dobby burn and web.
We have all that and we know what it is
and we know that we we yeah that be we
can create a section in the conversation
specifically for that.
>> Thank you. Um trustee Will.
>> Sure.
All right. Um, so I had some additional
observations of of root causes when I'm
looking at the data. Um, and so I'm
noticing
that,
let me pull up. I have so much data
right now. Um, a root cause I'm noticing
is elementary schools where sixth
graders were were held at the campus um
for
accountability of neighboring campuses.
So, I'm noticing that as a root cause. I
am also noticing um that the Mendes
attendance zone had 800 students that
were served in Austin ISD. 200 of them
were served at Mendes.
Um the schools that
um were the majority of Mendes students
were served. Um so
are um are on this list.
Um I'm noticing that that's
one out of one in every three students
at Sanchez is receiving special
education services. So um I have I have
a question about I would say like why
are um our elementary schools so
imbalanced
um in that way?
Um and also at Dawson one and three.
I am um noticing chronic um absenteeism
is about one in three at the schools on
this list.
Mobility one in three um attrition uh
greater than 30%.
and that a very high number of students
um are emergent bilingual one in two
years in the United States and um most
of the schools with multi-year F ratings
over 90% of the students are
experiencing poverty
um so I would like to know how
isolating um our students who are
experiencing poverty and emergent biling
and who are emergent bilingual um is
being addressed by the plan.
[snorts]
>> So on the um sixth grade you're
referring to the sixth grade students
that were held back from Mendes and
Martin at those [clears throat]
elementary schools. Is that
>> Yes.
>> for Okay. So for the 20
>> from 32 24 um because they came back.
Yes. So, so they started this year 25
26. Um, so you're thinking
>> so for three years
>> the correlation. Okay. Yes. Got it.
>> Um, I'm also seeing like one year
one-year principles, brand new
principles um and where principles that
were performing well were were moved out
of the school.
Um,
with Martin um this the school was left
with almost like very very few students.
they were moved out. Um so everyone who
yeah very very high number of students
were were left Martin. Um and
um the district like highly controlled
how teaching was done at Martin as well.
Um yeah so I I have I have questions
about
let's see also looking at the top plans.
Um
it TEA I guess this is TEA's. Is that
like a general form from TEA that we're
answering?
>> Yes, we modeled it after uh their tab
workbook.
>> Okay. So none of the students who or
none of the schools that are being
closed and moved to another school as
part of the plan. It so it asked was an
A or B school considered. It says yes.
Um we let us know which ones
and why. we didn't move them there or or
if we ask the families if they would
like transportation there.
>> I mean, I'm happy to produce a
statement. So, yeah, I can do that. It's
fine.
>> Um, yes. I would like to know why
um we'll put in it's okay to put entire
schools in portables to give them a
nicer building. Um,
>> it's part of like a swing space
solution. Yes, but but not for um
academic purposes.
>> You mean short-term versus long-term? I
mean, for swing space solutions, they
they are construction is usually, you
know, 24 to 36 months and then we get
rid of the portables. uh they're they're
not meant to be permanent solutions, but
we can provide more kind of detail
around
kind of the the types of spaces that are
most conducive for for learning and you
know and why portables are, you know, as
short-term solutions are not that.
>> Do we think that's like a a root cause
of
like students being in portables versus
new buildings?
Are we seeing a correlation?
>> I'd have a correlation. Yeah, I don't
the way that it's it's asked, I'm not
sure I can respond across all the
different school types
because I'm not sure aware of the number
of schools that were being modernized
that were in swing space solutions
between 22 23 23 24
um versus the ones that are now. Um so I
I would need to look at that a little
bit closer.
Okay. And I can save the rest of my
questions um for our work for our work
session next Thursday. It sounds like
we're trying to do it.
>> Yeah. And I think the the principle um
you know that that's one that uh you
know we have been um trying to to
address and I think we have done a very
good job over the last couple years of
um stabilizing the principal ship in
Austin ISD. uh you know in 22 23 and 23
22 23 uh and really 21 22 we had huge
numbers of vacancies for principles um
you know hiring you know well over two
dozen uh in the 23 22 23 school year um
and I think at that time coming out of
the pandemic um the administration at
the time um you know just had different
practices uh we would hire midy year
opposed to you know waiting towards the
end of the year to build up a you know
stronger pool of candidates. Um and so
for a period of time you did see you
know lots of first year principles
entering our schools. Um and they've
done many of them have have done great.
Um but the reality of it all is you know
when you're everybody's a better I'm a
better superintendent in year two at
least I think I was in than year one and
everybody grows. uh and so there's
definitely a correlation um I would say
to
principal um retention and tenure uh and
performance um and that's been kind of a
long-standing relationship in Austin
ISTD and you're right where you see that
tenure instability you don't necessarily
see the same type of um impact on
academics and outcomes
>> but we can provide more
>> thank you and and and from the workshop
I think it' be it would be very helpful
to hear from the educators who have been
serving in these schools
um what would have helped to support
them better so that we can do that going
forward
um like and to thank them for how hard
they have worked in in spite of the lack
of support
um of of adequate support I won't say no
but you know it obviously was was not
enough support
um
and I think it would it would be really
helpful to hear from our teachers at
Dolby and Web and Bernett. Um what is
working well there and um what adj what
you know what isn't or what adjustments
um need to be made or what what
challenges they are facing. Um that
would be really helpful um to to hear in
the workshop as well.
Thank you.
>> Thank you Trusty Deodor.
Um, okay. First off, the one that I
think you'll love the most. Um,
>> I know I know Trusty Singh already asked
this uh in in a larger context, but just
for for our purposes tonight, ballpark.
I'm not holding you to it. Just just
idea, how how much do you think each one
of these taps would cost? Just just
roundabout. So, we budgeted um for Doby
Burn and Web um 800 thou um 1 point 1.4
4.7
>> 1.7
>> 1.7 U for these um less I think 800 is
what we're budgeting
>> for yeah for for staffing 800,000
>> so times 18
>> uh no the two UAS are going to have a
slightly different um kind of buildup um
budget wise
>> so just for tablecloth math though say
500,000 average
>> I I think um normalized out we have the
number. Katrina, do you have it?
>> 14 at a million dollars each.
>> Okay. So, 14 million. Um, so I'm going
to borrow a little bit of the Titanic
analogy, but I'm I'm going to twist it.
Um, I think it was appropriate the way
you used it for the context of that. Um,
you know, I I get worried I I think I
spoke to you uh in a different
conversation about Titanic psychology.
Um cuz this isn't the Titanic. You know,
I think totally appropriate to think
about that. I think the reason that it
comes across like the Titanic is because
it gets people into thinking that
they're man manning the lifeboat and in
this context I you know how it how it
ends up is they're trying to get people
to pay for the private lifeboat and I'll
guarantee you a spot if you're willing
to pay for me to go in the private
lifeboat. And then we get left managing
the free lifeboats that everybody's
running towards because not everybody
can afford the private lifeboat. And I
think that is uh really um what clouds
this situation. You know, going to
another conversation that we had um you
know, we were talking Yeah. Yeah.
Talking about early childhood literacy
gains, right? That's a systemic solution
that we've applied, right? We're seeing
systemic gains. It's slow. It kind of
works over time. we'll see it ideally
propagating through the grades as that
effort continues and those you know
students metriculate. Um you know the
taps and the way that this is coming
across is all granular on specific
campuses. It's not the systemic solution
and I think uh what trustee Whitley Chu
was just pointing out was some of the
systemic natures of the failures that
we're seeing right. It's it's
populations across campuses. It's not
just oh you just go fix this one thing
at this one campus and you know I think
that that's built in to the way this is
being applied not by our choice but you
know the framework that we're being
given on a very very short uh you know
short notice and so what we've seen in
the early childhood from the you know
conversations we've been having is the
systemic approach on the district level
is what's working and so for whatever
we're doing with the taps and turnaround
plans and you know all this stuff it's
it's not really addressing the
underlying you know the overarching
issue and I think what trustee sing uh
Singh was bringing up was you know the
broader prospect of like how are we
going to address these things across the
board um you know to then move to
another part um you know I I was talking
to someone outside of the district in a
different context as for my advocacy
part and they were bemoning how many uh
LSSPs and diags they had lost to AISD
because we had aggressively hired
offering, you know, compensation
packages and, you know, staffing to, you
know, correct that issue. And so really,
you know, that was a systemic solution
to a systemic issue that was presenting
across the district. And at the end of
the day, really what the solution was
was paying people more to do the work
that we needed to get done. And I think
that's kind of what gets missed in this
conversation because now we're getting
you know put uh you know into these
positions where we're paying more money
for solutions that are not systemic
solutions, right? When that's that's
really what we need to be applying. And
so I just wanted to to highlight that
part and make sure you know we still
have community members that have you
know stayed here for the meeting that
have been you know this far into it. And
I think it's uh you know bridges into
issues that we're having in other
conversations where people keep looking
um you know understandably at just the
campus or just the one school. You know
we're trying to talk about this
framework that overarches the entire
district and it's because it is a
systemic thing. And so that's why it's
not just about whether this school got
an A or a B or any of that. To fix
everything takes an approach that's
going to fix everything. and and you're
not going to just fix one school and
then the other school and then you know
um so you know I I wanted to highlight
those pieces and to bring it back to the
turnaround plans and to what's going on
here is you know the solutions are I
think going to be beyond just what are
in these plans right even though we're
doing this and you know we're following
the TI TA guy guidance we're you know
adhering to the timelines doing the
things that TA wanted but again to trust
Singh's point is the AISD piece of it is
what are we doing beyond all of that and
[snorts] uh and you know to acknowledge
the people that are you know still here.
I think the community piece is is really
big on that and uh you know kind of
delving into the communication part so
that it can empower those those families
and those communities around what's
going on on those schools. And so that's
one of the things that we're talking
about is these accelerated timelines and
and you having to get the taps through
get them approved. Um that's not really
going to be the long-term solution. And
it's going to be tying in this
communication piece uh you know so that
people know that they're getting
reassigned as new schools. They know you
know the sped piece that's going to be
coming. They understand uh you know how
much work is coming. And I think that
also ties into this budget piece um
because it's not going to be done at the
end of this semester. It's not going to
be done at the end of next semester. You
know this is going to be an ongoing
thing that we're going to keep working
on. And so um I just want to encourage
that we start using these things that
we're doing now. Like we have to do the
taps. So, we need to start focusing on
that communication piece on every single
thing that we're doing from here moving
forward because it's it's at least
another year if not longer, right, of
of, you know, consolidation and redoing
the plan, all this stuff.
>> Yeah, I think um no, I appreciate that
comment. Um and I I love your analogies.
Uh they're they're very they're very
good. Um, a couple things and and this
is something I I've shared when we go to
these committee meetings, uh, that I I
enjoy very much is that, you know, we
have been doing a lot of work to improve
the system, right? And and we start with
the educator. We've we've been we've
really I think over the last two and a
half years as we've come together been
very intentional about you know putting
in place those um those systems that are
aligned with our values that we know
will move outcomes but do it in a way
that is aligned with who we are. um you
know and it it takes time you know and
there's evidence that the system is
responding and and to your point like
the taps are kind of on top of that
because they're they're building on the
work that's been done over the last you
know year and a half two years that
we've put been like really really
intentional about um and so I think it's
just you know worth noting your point
like if you go campus by campus by
campus yes you may ultimately break the
accountability chain but really what
we're doing is putting this on top of
what all the other things that we have
been doing and we need to be better
about addressing some of those things
that trustes singing and trustee Willie
Chu brought up that we are aware of but
don't find themselves as clearly in the
plan um but they are things that we have
been like very intentional about right I
mean like the hiring I mean like all
these things that we talked about like I
can go back in my brain and think about
decisions we made along the way um that
were different than what we did you know
three years ago or four years ago and
there's real evidence that they're they
are working um yeah so so I I I
appreciate appreciate that. The other
thing that you you going back to a
conversation you and I had uh
implementation matters um you know
having a plan um you know agreeing to a
plan uh whether it's consolidations or
boundary change whatever it ends up
being like you have to be able to
implement um with fidelity and if you
don't then you know you're you're just
you're roing more trust in the community
you're um not you know ultimately going
to reach the outcome that you desire to
to meet through the plan. And so for me,
it's really important that we are very
intentional about what goes in the plan.
We're really honest about what we can
and can't do. Um because I I 100% expect
to be able to implement the plan. That's
that's what I'm here for. Um and so
implementation is really really
important and and that's why the
thoughtfulness in the plan is a is a
critical conversation and look forward
to continue to have it with you all.
>> Yeah. I'll just bookend it with uh with
one more comment on the on the
communication piece for for all of this,
you know, underlining it is going to be
that the the community is going to be
more empowered the more they understand
what's going on and that the dialogue,
you know, the the trustees have been
doing the two-way communications and
we've been committing to do that every
year, you know, that to become a regular
thing. And I think in that spirit is
just, you know, the more that we're
empowering the community on those, um,
I' I've really enjoyed this second round
that we've done of the two-way
communications has been much better.
And, uh, and I want to see that kind of,
um, that that spirit of improvement kind
of across the board. And I think the
turnaround plan implementation like
you're talking about is a really good
opportunity to start demonstrating that
um so that people can see the
improvement um and and so that we can
kind of toot our own horn and get credit
for the stuff that we're doing.
>> Thank you, Trusty Hoffman.
>> Thank you. I will try to be quick
because I know we're way past time.
>> We had [snorts] two and a half. Uh one
and a half. One and a half. Sorry, not
two and a half. Okay. Uh, I will still
try to be brief. Um, I just wanted to
follow up on the the communication piece
with the community. Um, because I think,
you know, from the emails and the phone
calls we've received, I do not see
evidence that our communities are aware
of what's potentially happening to their
schools. So, I would really like to just
know that even in these final weeks
before the plans are due that we've
mobilized all of our resources,
including our parent support specialists
and the, you know, true community
engagement model that they at least used
to use and that we've enlisted our
partners who help us with community
engagement to do the work to ensure
that, you know, on a face-to-face basis
that our families are aware. And I, you
know, I was at Northeast High School on
Saturday, I was at Go Valley on Sunday.
And in both situations, I, you know,
kind of heard from people saying, "We're
talking to families and they don't
know." So, I just really want to make
sure that we're using all our available
resources who are good at that work to
make sure our families are engaged. Um,
and I would, I guess, my request is that
you provide that information to us
about, you know, what how that has been
or will be done. Um, particularly in
regards to the
>> before the vote for the the taps. And
then I'm curious about the um the public
hearing that is scheduled for next
>> for the day of the vote. Um so I
understand I'm reading I'm looking
through the statute right here and it's
very you know
>> there's no timelines given there's no
kind of things. I'm curious what are our
options for the hearing? Um, and are
there options available that would not
have the hearing, you know, literally an
hour before the vote so that the
feedback that we get during the hearing
is actionable rather than performative.
>> My understanding is you can have the
hearing before. I just want to make sure
like well before I just don't know.
>> Yeah, the hearing is is statutoily
required um in order for it to be as you
say like meaningful i.e. prior to the
day of the vote. Um really our biggest
constraint at this point is just time
and the new requirements around open
meetings posting. So the only real
availability is going to be that same
around that same time frame as what
you're thinking of for a work session.
So you could perhaps double it up on
that night, but otherwise
um you don't have a ton of options.
And I I understand there was a timeline
of other engagement um both that was
required but also that was you know done
but I just really worry about that
hearing being you know not an actionable
moment. So I I am here that was my next
question was whether if we do hold a
workshop would it be possible to have
the hearing then um and just in order to
to make to do our best effort to make
that a meaningful hearing.
>> Yeah. Something to consider.
>> Yeah. At this point, your only other
available meeting dates are the 13th,
14th, 17th, unless you want to meet on a
weekend.
>> 13th, 14th, 17th, 18th, and 19th.
>> Yeah. Um, right. And I just I guess
so. The other question on that is that
um
whether
I just want to be aware of the timeline.
I understand that in order to post what
we might be voting on the 20th, I
believe you would have to post that on
the 14th
>> and the date we're talking about
potentially having this workshop would
be the 13th which would really mean that
the day before you're trying to finish
up a massive
submission we would be creating another
you know set of preparation for that
meeting keeping staff here late for that
meeting etc. So I just want to be it may
be something we have to do but I just
want to acknowledge uh the the time
constraints for your team as well. Oh
yeah, there I mean
I appreciate you acknowledging that and
I also you know I I understand why we
want as many things in the documents as
possible but there are many things that
we do that are not in TA documents. Um
just to be clear like I mean there there
is a lot that we do. Um so I think you
know if there's feedback that we know
will absolutely inform the the
submission you know we're happy to make
the change. Um, I'm just not envisioning
something so significant that we
wouldn't be able to manage it within the
time period that we have. Anything that
was really nuanced, it would actually
probably wouldn't even fit in the
template itself. It would have to be,
you know, something that we do that is
tied to a milestone in the plan. And in
the plan, it would be a just, you know,
text or, you know, an element. So, I
just I think there's opportunity to to
continue to develop and evolve. Um, the
template is is a template. you know, we
can build on that even after the
submission because it's our work, but we
just have to be in alignment with that.
So, I don't know if that's helpful, but
I'm not expecting every single thing
that comes out to be incorporated. It's
just it's just not that type of
document.
>> Thank you.
>> Um, thank you for all of this. Thank you
to all of my colleagues for your
comments. Really appreciate so much of
what I've heard. Um, I want to just make
one quick comment about um
consolidations and closures and then
move on.
Um, I know the Becker community has made
a really what I think is a really
thoughtful proposal. Um, and I would
love to just have a response to that.
Would love to make sure it's considered
and understood and responded to. Um, it
could potentially involve not just
Dawson, but Galindo. And I think as
we're talking about TAP plans and a lot
of our TAPs sending students to F-rated
campuses, D-rated campuses, C-rated
campuses, there are potentials there for
a lot of things. So I would love to
understand more about whether
>> um that is possible and if if not why
not um with modifications or as
presented. Thank you.
>> Um
uh thank you for reaching out to
partners. I know we have u a fierce
amount of knowledge that we have access
to through through memberships through a
lot of things in our community. I would
love um just for the guidance you got to
be shared with trustees that would be
helpful to understand what those
organizations shared and I would really
like to understand um you know kind of
whether they've been invited to help
understand our data to take a deep dive
into the modeling we've done and just
that thought partnership I think we
can't have too many minds involved with
this and would really like to understand
were were models shared with them were
they given access to all of our data
have we run um kind of as if projections
of what these populations were putting
together, what the star would look like
if they took the star now. Um based on
what we know from from beginning of year
or map testing, um reviewing this
>> are there answers?
>> Um I mean I So um I I worry it's a lot
of questions. Um I worry about taking
someone's verbal
>> um comments to us and kind of
>> putting their name on. So what I can I'm
happy to
>> have something written that can be
shared or just general ideas even not
attached to people.
>> Yeah. I mean I think we're we're happy
to because we had lots of meetings and
you know and great feedback but a lot of
it was you know looking at the data and
then having a dialogue and then taking
the ideas. Um so I think we can
summarize and we can talk about who we
met with. Um I worry about
>> that's fair.
>> Anything more detailed I'd have to be
almost putting words in their in their
>> just summary and what we did with it
would be helpful and then um kind of
what was done to really share that deep
data and that deep modeling
>> go back
>> and as many minds and and what modeling
have we even done
>> to know would be helpful. Um
>> when it was appropriate
>> when it was appropriate. Yes. Thank you.
Um I really want to understand
um when I look I think we're we're our
taps are when at the ones that we're
reassigning we have three taps where
[clears throat] we're sending students
from F-rated campuses to D-rated
campuses. My understanding is that is
not acceptable under TEA rules. I'd like
to understand why we think that will be
accepted and why we think that will
work.
I think um the it is listed that it has
to be an AB or C campus. Uh but uh in
conversations with the agency uh when
there are extenduating circumstances and
with sufficient support plans uh to
surround um sending off students to such
campuses. uh we uh received the signal
that um when all those things are in
place that it would be acceptable.
>> Okay.
>> And and to be clear, I mean they have
reviewed in draft form these these
documents. I mean we're we're you know
region 13 I mean we're constantly
getting feedback so that we're not ever
progressing something that we believe
will not be accepted.
>> Okay. I and I want to I hope we're also
not progressing something we don't think
will work because I know until recently
it had to be an A or B- rated campus and
now we have three taps that are going to
D-rated campuses and three that are
going to C-rated campuses and I would
say as one trustee that gives me real
concern and I think especially where we
have considered a higher rated campus
why haven't we done that and to trust
Willie Chu's point have we really leaned
into the possibility of maybe students
traveling a little further. Maybe that
being at, you know, a temporary for a
couple of years. I understand we have
swing spaces that go on for a couple of
years if students traveled a little
farther for a couple of years, had
access to a strong more strongly rated
campus and perhaps a better chance of
breaking that chain. We have a whole lot
at stake here and I'd really like to
understand in more depth why we haven't
considered that. I understand geography
and a lot of other things and
um F-rated campuses to D-rated campuses
give me profound concern um because I
know the commissioner likes to say
poverty isn't destiny and I agree with
that. We have some thriving schools that
are meeting the state's requirements
under this system with students with
deep economic need with you know with a
lot of mobility with a lot of things and
I've looked at the statewide data. I've
looked at campus bycampus data. I've
taken the giant spreadsheets and
downloaded them from TEA
um and there's a lot of correlation and
um we do not have limitless resources
and I'm very very concerned.
>> I I can um if we want kind of a
description of the thought process on
why we didn't want to move those student
that student group to a school that was
AB um I'm happy to provide that. um
because
>> or in the with the D's even a C and and
understanding this isn't about
>> D to C
>> well or even the Fs that are going to
D's why the Fs aren't even going to C's
and and I understand I have complete
faith in our students and I know that
when people when we have 30% mobility
when we have high um you know rates of
chronic absenteeism that have nothing to
do with what our students are capable of
when you know right now our country is
denying food to our students
um and our state denied food to our
students over the summer. Um a lot of
our students don't have healthcare. This
is not just a school issue and we can
implement as well as we can and offer
all the resources we can and we
[snorts and clears throat] can't fix
those things and those our students are
bringing those things and that really
gives me profound concern
um that we're setting ourselves up to
fix much bigger issues with high quality
instructional materials and fidelity to
programs and and other things. But I
just really want to understand why
there's confidence. I I trust that you
have confidence it'll work. I just want
to understand that before I vote for
these things that give me real concern.
So, [snorts] thank you for that. Um
and um somewhere I thought I saw someone
say Martin the TAP was receiving 46% of
the students, but then when I look at
the plan, it says 61. It has to be more
than 50%. Right.
>> Where did you see that at?
>> I don't know. I I have it in my notes,
but that doesn't mean I don't I can't
find it again. So, I must have written
it down wrong. And the term they use I
think is plurality where the campus that
receives the most students from that c
sending campus receives the tab.
>> Okay. But it has it can be a plurality
not a majority.
>> It's split three ways. Yes.
>> Okay. Thank you. I appreciate that.
That's helpful. Um, and I have asked
several times from modeling um, the
populations that we're creating if we
can have state data with similar um,
similar
circumstances, not just racial data,
economic data, linguistic data, but also
what we know about mobility, what we
know about how long students have been
in the country, um, what we know about
special education percentages, students
receiving special education services,
and understand what that A throughF
distribution is and if we're creating
campuses, especially with those F2D
campuses, if other um schools in Texas
with similar populations tend to do
really well or if we are creating a
really big hill to climb and I haven't
seen that, but I would really very much
value understanding
um what the likelihood of of doing well
is at other campuses with that kind of
makeup. um that would be extremely
helpful to me as I decide you know kind
of as I help to understand these um
appreciate the conversation about
beginning of year to beginning of year
data web and burn I know we're learning
a lot and understanding
um student mobility understanding just
is what we're doing working um do we
believe that it's working that would be
extremely helpful if we are able to have
um that workshop um
I I also really want to echo what
trustee Singh said about the dual
capacity framework and I really
appreciate seeing family engagement here
and see I know that's one of TEA's
levers I think it's one of TE's levers
for really good reasons um and I see a
lot of things that we're doing for
families but I don't see a lot of
leaning into our families as experts and
that's our policy for a reason and our
families we want good things for our
kids you know the teachers who know our
kids want good things for our kids I
know everyone in this room wants good
things for our kids no No one wants good
things for our kids more than their
families. Um, and we have a history at
many of our campuses of really inviting
our families in as partners no matter
what kind of educational background they
have, no matter what, respecting our
families as experts. And I don't see
that in this plan and would love to
understand that. And then I'd really
like to see a financial breakdown of how
the $800,000 per campus will be used and
really more detail about the wraparound
services, especially campus by campus.
This campus has high mobility. This
campus has high chronic absenteeism.
This campus has an extraordinary
percentage of students receiving special
education services. How are we tailoring
the investments that we are finding ways
to make to the needs of those individual
campuses? That would be extremely
helpful to me as well. Um,
and then I also have a question. I
understand with our Doby Web and Bernett
um that our 18 that our TAP plans
included the option to bring in an 1882
after a year. Are we writing that into
these plans?
[snorts]
>> Yeah, I mean we haven't they're not in
there now. We've talked
>> Well,
>> yeah.
>> Will we be writing that into these
plans?
>> Yeah, I I'll verify if that contingency
needs to be written in or if that's
always an option for us.
>> Sounds like trustee President Baso would
like it written in regardless.
>> If it's an option, I'd love it written
in. Yeah, I think it would be great to
have it written in and it is what we
did. It's I'm asking because I know
there's precedent and I think it was a
very wise choice and just I think the
more options we give ourselves the
better because the timeline is short.
Um, and I do have high hope that the
great I know a lot of great work has
been done and I really do hope you know
we talked about the hockey stick and we
talked about it starting to bear fruit
and we we have to get this right at a
whole bunch of campuses um not just for
our students but for our whole district
and I know you feel the pressure
[snorts] in a huge way but it um yeah
the the more we understand I think the
more um the better positioned we'll be
to offer support and um the backing that
you need to get this right. Um
and I think that is it for me and I
really want to thank my colleagues for
um being willing to spend even more time
um you know here together and and thank
staff for being willing to go there with
us. I know that's a big ask when you're
already being asked to do so much and I
think we can't understand this too
deeply. Um it's a big deal and I know
good work's being done and our community
needs to know that as well. Um so thank
you for that. Really appreciate it. Um
and not taken lightly that people are
willing to do that. Um thank you.
>> Thank you.
And I'd also love to add just to thank
you to um Ashley Paw for offering some
clarity by phone about how we can have
the time to talk about this and to tea
for making sure we understood that as
well. Thank you.
Um, all right. So, this ends our section
on information reports and now we will
move into the preview of agenda items
that will be considered for a vote at
the next board meeting on on November
20th. Um, staff is available to answer
any questions and we are going to begin
tonight with item six, which is the
agenda preview for upcoming academics
and curriculum items. Any questions on
those?
Whoops. Thank you. I just want to thank
the administration for the continued
work um and the investment on 6.2 on
college, career, and military readiness
with our students who are in most need
of that support. These are the kind of
things that that need funding and it
costs money, but it ensures that kids
have actual choices when they complete
our high schools. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
Um all right. Next section uh se number
seven board administration. Any question
for our TCAD um allocations of our
points? Next is section 8 business and
finance. Any questions?
Uh thank you. Um my only question um 8.2
to just want to ask um I know we made a
commitment to have some regular updates
about the progress made toward keeping
the promises made when we adopted the
budget and how the um the savings were
being realized. And I know we're seeing
budget amendments, but I would love to
just make an agenda request to to have a
more in-depth update on how we are
keeping the promises we made when we
adopted our budget to find the savings
[snorts]
that had not yet been realized.
Thank you.
And find a time to do that.
>> I'm I'm just thinking about what we
presented last time. Um just it's okay.
I'll continue on.
>> Yeah. I I just think we can't talk about
that too often. Um yeah. Uh next section
is nine facilities trustees. Any
questions?
All right. Uh next is 10 talent
strategy.
All right. Uh, next section 11 policy.
And these um some of these are policies
related to
um the closure and consolidation
process. So I know our community um is
seeing these for the first time in this
agenda item. Thank you to the policy
committee for the work on that. Trusty
Singh. Yeah. Um I wanted to ask about
the um 11.3 the bilingual education
um document. I have a few questions
about them, but I'm wondering if there's
going to be an opportunity like is the
policy committee going to meet on this
again or have [snorts] y'all can can
y'all just share a little bit more about
um who was involved in this and why?
>> Sure. Uh Dr. Maxwell,
Victoria, welcome.
I'm not sure if the I think the policy
committee has already re I'm not sure
it's going to go back to policy
committee. So I think this is the
appropriate time to
>> Okay, that's what I thought.
>> Hi, good evening, Superintendent Sugura
and President Boswell and board of
trustees. Um yes, this has already gone
to the policy committee. Um and uh as an
additional um document, we just wanted
to also share kind of you know like a
little bit of what it is currently um
what what the proposed changes are and
kind of a little bit of an explanation
of those changes. Um I know uh that
Kadanas has been working a lot with uh
this policy and to reflect um what we
would desire in our programs and so are
there any specific questions?
>> You have some specifics. Um maybe I can
just go through some of them and that
way you can have them. Okay. Um, I
wanted to know just,
you know, we crossed out the definition
of the one way versus two-way, and I
just didn't I just thought that was um,
you know, sometimes that is helpful to
have in there. So, but that's just me. I
like have I like having things well
defined. Um, the the
um language about the 5050 ratio, I
appreciate that. I know that's what the
research literature says is really
helpful. Um I did have um you know a
teacher that I respect a lot take a look
at this and give me some feedback and
she said that she was worried about the
specificity here um because some
campuses um might not have large numbers
of English speakers that attend them. So
it kind of puts an additional
recruitment burden on them to kind of
get to that. And so I just wanted to uh
just wanted to share that with you
because it feels a little bit it could
feel a little bit binding maybe um for a
campus that doesn't have um currently a
whole lot of English speaking or
non-emergent bilingual students there.
So
maybe if you could respond to that that
would be
>> Thank you for that question. Um, so, so
you're right there. We do have one way
and two-way. That hasn't gone away in
terms of how we code our students,
right? And really one way and two-way is
about the makeup of of the classroom.
So, it's the students that are
participating in in that dual language
classroom. Um, this is primarily where
it's written to achieve that up to 50% u
non-emergent bilingual and at least 50%
um emergent. I think I said it the other
way around, but that really is uh about
a two-way dual language classroom or
environment. So, we do have campuses
that really already look that way or can
look that way. Um, one of the big ones
are the proposed um, schoolwide dual
language campuses, but we have some
others that that can get there because
they're already serving students that
are both emergent bilingual and
non-emergent bilingual. When we're
talking about the campuses that have
really large numbers of emergent
bilingual students where we know that
that is going to happen and that is
traditionally more of a one-way um, type
of program.
>> Okay. So is so they would still be
allowed to deal with that. Okay. So
maybe it might be helpful to have some
language that kind of clarifies that a
little bit.
>> Um
>> there were there were a few other
comments. It might just be easier if I
just share this my comments with you all
directly and then you can just um take
those and I'm happy to have a
conversation with you offline if if that
seems to be the best thing. But I think
overall I'm I'm glad we're looking at
this. Um,
I do just want to make sure that we I
appreciate that you all shared with us
an update like you know the annual
update that we're supposed to get and it
would be really helpful to just kind of
better understand
to accompany this policy like what our
actual you know data around bilingual
education is. I don't know if there's
anything in this policy that speaks to
um an issue that I've heard over the
years, which is if you have a two-way
um dual language program, you don't need
you don't need to have a a dual language
certified teacher to teach the English
portion of it. And I just want I don't
know if we have any specific
um maybe local policy or something on on
how we're going to do you know, how we
kind of treat that.
>> So, um, the Texas code in chapter 89, it
does talk about being able to utilize
partner teachers in dual classrooms
>> where we would have a certified
bilingual teacher partnered with an ESL
certified teacher
>> and and functioning in in that um kind
of configuration.
>> So, that is included in chapter 89 right
now.
>> Okay. Okay. Um, and we can always refer
to that as well.
>> And is that a model like do we do that
in our school district?
>> We do have campuses that utilize that
configuration.
>> We're looking at that in third, fourth,
and fifth grade because by third,
fourth, and fifth grade. Our language
allocation plan, right, shifts to a
50/50 in terms of about 50% of the
instructional time is in English and 50%
in Spanish.
>> Okay. Okay. And so um so we do have
campuses that utilize that dual language
um bilingual certified teacher partnered
with an ESL certified teacher.
>> Okay. And I would be curious um
superintendent to know if um if we're
what the configuration looks like at our
wallto-wall programs generally speaking
versus um our non-wall to-wall programs.
I don't know if you have that in your
head already or wish to comment on that.
>> Yes. Uh I don't have that data readily
available. Yes, but we can get that.
>> Okay. Appreciate it. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Anyone else in this section?
>> I just appreciate those questions and I
I in discussing the policy changes. One
thing that we on the committee we talked
about was the importance that the policy
does not block emergent bilingual
students from participation in the most
effective dual language programs. And so
that is, I think, a worry to think about
when you're looking at the state
requiring, but but the chapter 89
requires a district with two-way dual
language to have a policy that speaks to
aiming for a 50-50 ratio. So that is
something that's kind of required by the
state. But I think then implementing
that we just have to keep our values
forefront which is ensuring that we are
providing the program to all emerging
bilingual students and not to to fall
into the trap that some districts with
only a limited number of programs do
which is to say we're going to have an
application process and these emerging
mining students didn't make the cut
because we can only take 50% of them.
Like we have to have seats open for
every single emergency student. So, I
don't want anything in the policy that
would suggest that we're not going to do
that or prevent us from doing that. Um,
I think it actually is a really good um
I'm very curious based on the the the
internal audit report as well talking
about the importance of placing teachers
um I don't know how they said it
exactly, but the importance of making
sure our teachers are are allocated and
placed correctly. I really do think
maybe not in policy, but I really do
think we need to explore having um a
staffing plan that explicitly
is based on partner teachers in third,
fourth, and fifth grade to ensure that
we can place bilingual teachers instead
of having exceptions at other campuses.
And so, um you know, as a as a
principal, I certainly stockpiling as
many bilingual teachers as you can is
the goal because you want to have them
and that's great. But when we have them
at one campus at the expense of other
campuses having them, particularly if
those bilingual teachers are not serving
a majority of students who are emerging
bilingual is ethically challenging.
>> Thank you. Other questions about this? I
have a quick one on the Thank you to
Trusty Singh and Trusty Kaufman about
the dual language policy. Really
appreciate those questions. I have one
about the transfer policy. Just a
couple. Um I know we've talked about in
the past um freezing transfers at
campuses. The policy refers to freezing
transfers but doesn't refer to a date by
which that is announced. Uh does that
belong in the policy? I understand we've
had a practice of that in the past. Um
but wonder if if we need to put a date
in the policy so families understand
when that information will be available
as they're planning.
I I um
affirm date. I'm I'm just trying to
think. I'm not sure if what that would
look like in the policy. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. Um so in um the section that
relates to um you have pointed out
something that's made me think because
in the section that relates to staff
transfers and then student transfers. Um
we did put something in that said prior
to the opening of the general
registration round. Um and uh I think
that it would be um potentially a good
thing that we can take back and discuss
moving that higher so that it's not just
related to those two transfer types. Um
but we'll discuss it internally and um
and and decide if we want to make that
global. But thank you for raising that.
>> Thank you for that. I appreciate that.
And then um I noticed there were some
changes to hardship transfers or return
to campus midyear and would like to
understand why that change was made and
what options there are if we do have a
student. I don't know how often that's
used or or kind of what the issues are,
but just wonder if there are some
students who do have a transfer. They
think it's going to be great. it doesn't
work or they have a situation with
family job, you know, transportation or
whatever that is and and why we've
closed that door and what we hope to
gain [snorts] and and what the risks
might be for our students.
>> Yeah. Um so in the interest of um you
know stability for the students, the
policy does say that um it's at the
start of the next semester. However, um
there is also language in there, I
believe. I will double check that
relates to um the best interest of the
student and the and the sending
principal and the receiving principal um
coming to an agreement. And those are
circumstances that are handled case by
case in the best interest of the child.
And if it really is that a need uh a
change needs to be made quick more
quickly, we can definitely do that.
>> Thank you for that. I appreciate that.
Uh just quickly, Victoria, on the um
freeze, I know two years ago we got away
from the word freeze. Um and so I think
we just kind of revert to, you know, um
a weight list. And so I guess as we look
through this, I just want to make sure,
you know, I don't think we're
envisioning bringing back that term. Um
just to be clear, um
>> that was my term, not a term in the
policy. The policy says suspension of
transfers, and I use that for people who
that's a new word, so I use the new word
and the old words. Sorry. Thank you. I
appreciate that. Um, and then speaking
of new words and old words, I also just
wanted to say thank you for the new word
continuation transfer um to replace
grandfathering. I know we've talked
about that word um here on the DAS and
in our community. So, thank you for
coming up with a new word. Um, and I
think that's a very clear word. So,
thank you for that. And those are my
only questions on that one. All right.
Um, next up is uh, no that's Oh, I have
a question about um Oh, next is section
12. Anyone have questions about that?
And I'll ask section 12 other
and I have one question about that. I
see approval of the turnaround plans.
Maybe I'm missing it. I don't see a vote
listed for the rest of the closure and
consolidation plans
on our agenda. Yeah, I see it either.
>> Okay, just flagging that.
>> Okay.
>> Um Okay. Any other questions about this?
>> Say those will be for separate vote like
will they be two different
votes? One is going to be the taps
and the closures and [clears throat]
consolidations associated with those and
then another would be for the special
programs. Are you going to do it all
together? I talk to the board officers.
Yeah.
>> Kind of structure what we think works,
you know, based on the desire of the
board. I mean,
>> and the whole thing, whatever they
whatever you all decide, it would be a
separate vote, not on consent. Correct.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
>> Cool. Thanks.
>> Yeah. I I've I've
It's not the exact same question, but
the the it comes from the same place.
Um, from the superintendent's report
slide nine, we had some timeline pieces
um and there was a TBD and so I'm
kind of want to understand what we're
what we're voting on
>> in full.
>> Yeah. So on the 20th um we're voting on
the um 10 consolidations uh that are
tied to uh well first you're voting on
the turnaround plans, right? And then
within the turnaround plans, but also
associated with the consolidation plans,
there are consolidations and then
there are also the consolidations that
are tied to um program moves. So that is
the the bundle of of like actions.
>> So those are three I think separate um
kind of things. the the taps um the
consolidations and boundaries tied to
the taps and then the the programmatic
moves um and and changes the boundary
changes and the consolidations tied to
balance enrollment. That was the TBD
um that I referenced when I was kind of
[snorts] addressing um all of it. Uh and
I think that's kind of based on a
conversation from the trustees as to you
know when the appropriate time to bring
it back is. Um, as I said before, the
work is going to continue. Um, you know,
it's it's it's important for me to
ensure that the the input from the
community, um, the analysis is
considered and we progress the work.
It's something that we're going to do.
Um, it's a function of when we bring it
back.
>> I say
>> that sounds like what you want is
certainty on the timeline as far as when
we get it back. And I think that's a
conversation that
>> I do want certainty on the timeline. Um
and sooner rather
>> um than later.
>> Um
>> and what I've heard and you know what
thousands of people have have heard um
is that all of this ties together and
works together. And so
I'm having
difficulty
understanding
the pulling a like how the pulling apart
is possible.
>> Can I bring
>> Yeah, sure. Trusty Hunter,
>> here is my question. Um,
I know that your desire for process is
to validate all of the information that
you received and that was included to
make sure that voices were heard
>> and not not just validate to also
consider which means I have to analyze.
Okay?
>> Right? So, so if if community gives me a
plan or an idea like I mean I've heard
ideas this week about when monastery and
I've heard ideas about other things. Um
it's not validating the idea. It's it's
deter doing the analysis to actually see
if I can incorporate it into the plan.
>> Okay. There's two different things. What
I'm So I'm not talking about new stuff.
I'm talking about I know you had some
concern about things that we'd already
received.
>> What did I misunderstand? There were
things that were um
we we as a administration I as the
superintendent wanted to ensure were um
analyzed
uh and assessed to determine whether
they could be incorporated into the
plan.
>> Okay. So that's the only piece I'm
talking about right now because that
from what I understood is why we pulled
out the three.
>> Correct.
>> What I'm asking is
>> and the and the boundary changes
>> and the boundary chang that bundle.
Thank you for helping me with that. My
question is how long do you need to do
that
because can you do it by the 20th?
>> It cannot be done by the 20th.
>> No, it's just it's
>> and then and then chair, can I uh check
with our legal counsel? Is this um
>> yeah I
>> on
>> for purpose
>> the agenda topic or
>> it it is I mean it's right now we're
talking about the agenda preview and so
I think the the thread here is we're
trying to figure out what exactly is
going to go on that agenda on the 20th
but even if we're getting a little loose
on that we already have item 4.1 still
this is a posted agenda topic elsewhere
we're just maybe having an expansive
discussion of of what's going to go on
the agenda. for the 20th. Do you see
what I mean?
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So that the 20th um So the 20th is
not the 20th, it's the 14th. Yes.
>> I mean so just I mean
>> um and [snorts]
there is a lot happening right now. Um
and you know I I don't have the same
staff that I had four days ago. Just so
I I am moving. I am working. uh that you
asked that the 20th is possible. Um the
20th not 20th is not possible um given
where we are. Um
it doesn't mean a different date is not
possible. It just mean I just it's just
not possible to hit the 20th given what
we've gone through the last five days.
>> I felt it was important to Oops. I
apologize. I felt it was important to
ask for a couple of reasons. One um
a community needs to know we have people
hanging in the balance, right? and they
they're going to they're going to make
decisions based on the information that
we give them. And right now they're only
going to have half that information with
half a vote. Okay. I'm also asking
because an outcry from the community is
like what the hell, right? And I really
think that we owe them like I felt that
I owed them to ask can this be brought
back? And you're telling me that with
what you need to do and I understand I
get that but I I felt that I needed to
ask.
So, um, and the way Trustee Hunter
asked, I really, um, appreciate that it
is how sort of how much time do you
need? And, you know, if I sort of looked
back and did the math on how far
of a runway we had to get to November
20th, it was short. So, we have two
voting meetings left this semester.
Um we have November for uh 20th and
presumably December something.
>> Um
>> December tw yeah yeah like merry
Christmas or something you know it's
it's going to be close to you know the
end of the year. Um
what I would want to see in the interest
of giving the administration the optimal
runway for planning for the next school
year and what I would want to see for uh
community to be settled um well as
settled as we could be in this really
difficult process. Um and also for
community to be quite frankly reassured
um that this because when there was a
communication about three things, you
know, three schools being named, it felt
to some on a close read that oh this was
a slowdown and a process would continue.
>> Yep.
>> But even that became like what process?
What does that mean? Does that mean
it's going to continue till 2030?
>> No.
>> You know, I mean, I'm I'm just saying
that this invited
>> Yeah.
>> uh
all sorts of questions and then others
quite frankly,
>> you know, reading the message, didn't
get that portion of the memo, so to
speak, that on a quick read, what you
see is it feels like these three have
been pulled. And so, you know, many many
many people what they read, what they
perceived was it's pulled. Um, if the
administration
can granted you're down a couple of
staff, but if the administration can
establish a cadence anywhere near the
pace we've been working at, you have an
extra month. Um, I guess what I would
like to see is that this become a one,
two, one voting meeting, next voting
meeting, buntto done. [snorts] Um,
I guess that's what how I would that's
what I would like to see. Um, otherwise,
I have real questions and real concerns
about this dragging out.
>> Yeah.
>> And Yeah. So, I guess I'll stop there
and and wait for a response or your
thoughts. I mean I mean my response is
I I this work has to get done. I mean
there's there's there's no doubt. Um,
you know, I I hesitate to to just offer
a quick like response and a timeline
because it is
I mean every single idea I mean even the
ones that I got this week that that many
of you the trustees were at are
requiring
analysis reconfigurations
student movement um and
>> understood and I have some coming from
my constituents as well.
>> Yeah. And so and so I'm I'm so if I
think about the the taps and and the
program moves, you know, I want to make
sure that those are where they need to
be and that we are um the administration
that I am extremely comfortable that
we've done everything possible to get
them as as aligned to who we are and
with all the committee input. And then
while that's progressing um here this
week as we progress like provide a
timeline based on the feedback from our
trustees as to and also our bandwidth to
progress the work like what is the next
milestone. Um I mean I this is I want to
be really clear like this is not
stopping. This work is going to
continue. It's something we've been
committed to. I I have said time and
time again, feeder pattern alignment,
balance boundaries, you know, and if in
the consolidations there within like
that's all part of the work. Um it's
unfortunate this occurred this way. I'm
again very disappointed.
>> Uh and so I do want to get this back on
track. I just can't give you a specific
time. I mean, it's it's just really hard
to to do that at this moment.
>> Understood. So, what I what I'll look
for and request is a little clarity and
articulation as to what exactly we're
voting for next week with the tap piece
because I think now it says t well my
screen's
>> to sleep uh that and that my request
that I would
>> timeline
>> want
specific proactive as soon as possible
response to is um
my expectation is that we would do it
this semester that we would have the
whole plan covered between these two
next voting meetings. And so, and if
not, why not? But that would be my very
strong um request and almost um a
condition of possible ability to really
move forward.
>> Understood.
>> Trusty Hunter. U the last thing that
I'll just ask since we have the time is
you mentioned this and our community has
the you probably should have received
several documents uh from when but one
specifically that was giving us very
many different options to to meet that
request and then the the two groups at
Maplewood and Campbell have also put
together some information that um I
ensured that um everybody received they
probably sent it to you too but that um
that be taken into consideration and
then like there there's there's still
some questions to be answered. Thank
you.
>> Yeah. And and I think this is one of the
things like you know the like the win um
ideas. I mean I all of them you know we
look at them two or three we know pretty
with certainty fairly quickly that those
are probably not ones we can support.
And there's one or two that, you know,
with the right, you know, people
engaged, like there's something that we
could probably consider. And I think
that's that's my commitment is to do
that work so that we can find something
that threads the 10,000 needles to f to
find something that doesn't
increase, you know, harm, address the
taps, balance enrollment, and also
stabilize a program if that's something
we choose to do moving forward. And I
think that's just what makes us
>> Well, thank you. And I'll probably will
after tomorrow morning, we'll be
bringing you something from Pickle. So,
just so you know. [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> Um, okay. Anything else about this one?
All right. Thank you. And I want to say
thank you to all of our community
members who we asked for creativity and
um solutions that benefited the whole
community and our community has shown up
in a really big way. So, thank you. we
have a lot of knowledge and expertise
and love and creativity in our community
and that is one of our superpowers. So,
thank you um and thank you to um our
audit committee too for um the Gibson
audit, the bilingual ESL program audit.
Uh any questions about section Oh, no.
We're moving on to section 13 now. Um
and uh can you please introduce the next
item?
Uh yes, President Boswell. Um
I'd like to um our next item is a
presentation on the bilingual ESL
program audit uh final report. Our
partners with Gibson Consulting have
provided a recorded presentation in
advance of today's meeting that that is
included in our agenda item tonight and
shared a presentation with backup data.
Uh tonight we'll have Will Hardaway, uh
MNA Rasmuson, and Gleb Ferman joining us
virtually to answer any questions from
our board members. Um I was on YouTube
earlier um and you know watched it for
the second time. Um so I appreciate uh
the the presentation um and also saw the
number of people that had watched it. So
maybe some questions
>> [snorts]
>> team um Gibson team um the trustees um
may have some questions.
>> Hi, thank you for being with us um to
the audit team and thank you for the
report. Um
lots of thorough information. Really
appreciated. Lots of interesting
insights. Um so trustees, any questions
about this?
>> Yes.
Right. So, I have a question about
which of our programs are serving
emergent bilingual students well and how
do we know?
>> So, are you speaking specifically about
campuses? Are you speaking about
two-way, one way of our campuses?
>> Um, yes. And types of programming. Mhm.
>> Uh so this report um and the
presentation wasn't specific to that. I
mean I think that we could get some data
and information on on specific campuses
um and different programs like pert with
like pertaining to the programs that
they do have. Is that the question that
you're asking?
>> Do I mean so do is that not something we
can answer today?
>> The Gibson audit I don't wasn't
structured that way. Um
we're happy to retrieve the data.
>> Does the the administration does can the
administration answer that question
>> today? Yeah. Any staff?
>> There's over 50 program I mean
yes or or auditors who have looked at um
different campuses.
Well, as
uh superintendent Sig mentioned, this
audit was structured to look at the dual
language bilingual and ESL program
specifically. So, those were the
programs that we evaluated.
>> Great. Um, yes. So, I would like to ask
about the the wall-to-wall dual language
programs and are they serving emergent
bilingual students well? Are emergent
bilingual students in those programs?
um successful
more or do they have stronger student
outcomes the same or
>> Yeah. And that was covered in the
presentation. So they should be able to
answer that question.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> Yeah. So the main finding related to the
wall campuses was that the demographics
don't reflect a prioritization of
emerging bilingual students. that those
campuses by and large have uh fewer
emergent bilingual students than
district averages. They have more white
students, fewer Hispanic students, fewer
African-American students, fewer
economically disadvantaged students.
>> And then what are your recommendations
around the wall-to-wall dual language
programs?
specifically around the wall to wall. Uh
the larger recommendation for that piece
of the audit is to redesign the dual
language program and a component of that
would be to
um position our wall to wall campuses in
a way that better aligns with serving
emerging bilingual students.
>> Okay.
Thank you.
Anyone
else? Trusty Foster.
>> Sure. I guess this is and we have Gibson
with us and I'm really grateful for the
work and I missed the video link. So I'm
so sorry in the documents and I was like
video what video and I see that it was
in board doc. So I really apologize um
for not being prepared on that but on
that part of it and I will go back and
watch the video. Um but the audit, you
know, came with really pointed
recommendations and um putting the
administration on the spot a little bit
because I, you know, like to preview my
questions, you know, for your all's
capacity to prep, but what I'm really
interested in is the articulation
between here are the set of
recommendations and what do our how do
our new pro all this work that we're
doing right now, does it articulate? If
so, how does it articulate? Um, one that
was just raised was the imbalance. I
think our plan is Yeah. So, if you could
just speak to that for a minute, the
recommendations and how
our work with these plans that we're
going to vote on speak to those
recommendations.
>> Uh, yeah. So, um, uh, we spoke briefly
about just the student makeup at our,
um, wall-to-wall um, programs, for
example. So that is something that uh we
are uh addressing um in the
consolidation plans so that that is
centered more on emergent bilingual
students and provides greater access to
those students. Um and again talked a
little bit about and that in policy
tonight. So that's one of the ways that
we've begun to address it and in
addition to actually making those
changes and consolidation so that we
have a true 50-50 model
>> um and that both students and and as as
the uh Gibson report pulls out uh dual
language in the research in two-way dual
language is the most effective model.
It's not always the most feasible model
uh in many districts, but is in research
the most effective model. And it allows
both native English speakers, native
Spanish speakers to really have lots of
language brokering in the classroom that
diminishes when there's a dominant
language in the classroom. Um so, uh
that that's part of what we've done with
those shifts in student populations. Um,
another thing that uh it addresses as
well, we talked a little bit uh earlier
uh about earlier is the just the amount
of bilingual certified teachers that we
have and that are needed to run um an
extensive um any bilingual education and
in our case a dual language education
model. um that becomes a little more
difficult when uh we have as many
programs at different campuses and and
staffing of course it's a extra
certification that's more difficult to
get and so uh staffing for bilingual
certified teachers is more difficult um
and so that that's another thing being
being addressed. Um and those are those
are a few things of of those pieces.
There are lots of other uh
recommendations. So, and so to be clear,
among the recommendations, there was um
as Gibson uh consulting said, you know,
a a redesign of the of the programming.
Um but a part of that was a look at the
balance within the campuses. You just
mentioned that. A piece of it was the
staffing allocation and I think you've
begun to touch on that. Um there's also
a clear prioritization
of emergent bilingual students. Um
that piece I want to I guess continue to
to hear about. And then there was pieces
about family engagement
um especially of our I guess uh the
families of our emergent bilingual
students but in general. Um, and then
also reporting to MAK and and having our
uh really nice lines of communication
and data flow and that sort of thing.
And so I mean this so many of our
conversations tonight were kind of
linked because we can go to our taps for
part of this and we can go here, we can
go here there. But in all these cases
that I just found this report
illuminative and it just raises the
question immediately okay this great
resource
to what extent are we actually having it
drive our work and are we going to be
able to speak to community and turn to
community and say this is how we've
addressed recommendation from chapter 4
yeah you know etc etc
>> yeah so so that's a great question and
I'm excited too so as soon as we started
to have convers conversations with um
Will and his team, we could already see
like how that was going to set our
direction, right, moving forward. And
we've been working on those pieces.
Another piece that came out where
there's that in intersectionality just
to kind of break a little bit is
feeders, right? So, it talked about
feeders, which is one things that we
were trying to do with the larger plan
as well.
>> Um but we we are working on um policy
today as we talked about it. If you'll
notice like the very top part of the
policy that we're proposing uh to update
it does uh start to say that the intent
right and the focus is on emergent
bilingual students. So that's there also
um to your point also um talking about
yes family engagement. So, one of the
things that um also came out in the
report is that as a as a department,
right, and as a district, we do have
opportunities where we're sharing
information out. I think the distinction
was that how are we then um
planning or or setting the expectation
for campuses to to also share that
information. So kind of having more of a
direct line like while we're offering
information, right? Or we have
opportunities to share information with
the community, what is that line between
district and campus and how are we
working together at the campus level to
be able to provide that information to
families as well. Right. And again, as
to your point, that's also aligned to a
conversation that we had a a little
while ago that we heard about making
sure that we're communicating with
families so that families know
everything that's going on, right?
Thank you.
[clears throat]
>> Thank you. Additional questions.
Trusty Whitley Chu. Um,
so how many two-way dual language
programs do we have in Austin ISD
currently?
>> Okay.
Is there an I mean I mean do you want
the exact number
>> or if you give me a definition of one I
can
>> I could tell you because I have data yes
probably if yes so if I had to estimate
maybe 10 that have a configuration where
they have um emergent bilingual and
non-emergent bilingual students
happening again I'm just kind of
guessing right now um we do one of the
things that that I do want to point out
a a shift that we've made a few years
ago for all of our dual language
programs, we have more than 50 of them,
was that even though we've got um
campuses that really have large numbers
of emergent bilingual students and other
campuses that have a mixture of emergent
and non-emergent bilingual students that
families can can apply to go to any dual
language campus. So, um, so that's
important and that was all about access,
right? So, making sure that if a family
moved into an area and they were
non-emergent bilingual that they could
still apply to join that program. So, I
just wanted to share that.
>> I would say in practice I've I that that
isn't happening in our district. And um
so you know I'm looking at schools that
have I think 26 of our schools have over
90% of the population
um in served in dual language is
um emergent bilingual. So those students
are being are don't have access to to
peers who speak English. Um so what what
I am hearing in in practice is families
who live in an attended zone um who
they might even be bilingual at home or
be a heritage speaker um but if they are
you know not not classified as emergent
bilingual um do not have access to the
program. And so like is it centering um
emergent bilingual students
to
not
have access to English-speaking peers?
Like is that centering them? Is that
>> So I I want to make a little bit of a
distinction about
>> two-way and one way and and maybe some
misunderstandings about it.
>> One way dual language is a very
effective dual language program
>> in our district. Which one ways are very
effective?
>> I'm speaking about the program in
general. [clears throat]
>> One way is is an effective program. Uh
two-way has some added benefits to dual
language that one way does not. But that
doesn't necessarily preclude one way
from being uh an effective program.
Also, the reason that they're called
emergent bilingual is it honors the fact
that they do speak English as well. And
I know they don't have the same access
to English speaking peers, as many
English-speaking peers in their
classrooms as you would in a two-way
dual language. If it's actually a 50-50
makeup of those students, um it you
still have access to English instruction
and to peers who speak English. They're
just not native uh English speakers like
you would have in a two dual langu
two-way dual language program.
So in in a so in a place where an
effective one-way dual link. So um if
you don't have those answers today, I
would love to have um evidence of which
of our programs are effectively um
serving emergent bilingual students um
and campuses.
Thank you.
>> Thank you, Trusty Koffman.
>> And and what how does this time count
for or against us? this time counts
against us. Um
>> yes,
>> even though we're talking about a bunch
of our students. Thank you.
>> Okay. So, um thank you again for this
very detailed and deep review. Um I just
have a handful of questions particularly
around staffing. So I wanted to ask our
um our Gibson friends what um whether
when you talk about the student the
emergent bilingual participation in the
program and sharing the recommendation
that we establish enrollment targets to
achieve 75% enrollment by year two and
90% by year three. those the the numbers
you're looking at to measure
um emerging bilingual participation in
the program. Is that it looks like
that's preK through 12. Is that accurate
that you're looking at that as
percentage of emerging bilingual
students in preK through 12 who are
currently enrolled in a dual language
program?
the those target percentages would just
be established for right now the prek
through six um if that is the target but
we do have at Austin a prek12
uh dual language program and so we would
establish 75 90% ultimately 100% being
served in the dual language the
bilingual education program
because okay
and so um thank you for that then
we do but that is I take your point
though because and we do try to
differentiate because it is optional of
course on from the state level and at
the secondary level students simply
don't have the same types of access to
dual language programming as they do at
the elementary level
>> so what I don't understand is that on
the um the the target you recommend is
75% but on figure 19 you show that in
elementary we already are at almost 80%
we're at 80% participation so I don't
really understand why we're setting a
target that's 5% lower than our current
reality
>> that would be for the entire prek
through 12 would be those those 7590
targets
>> okay is that standard practice in Texas
to look at participation in dual
language as far [snorts] as you pre-K
through 12 as the, you know, target and
goal.
>> Well, it's for M. I'll let you chime in,
but the dual language framework
established by TEA recommends 100% of
emergent bilingual students are enrolled
in the bilingual education program. And
so this would add a scaffolding to
getting to that 100% number, at least
closer to because right now we're
sitting at 50%. Pre-K through 12.
>> Okay. Um, as far as how that number
compares to our comparison districts, I
didn't see a comparison for that. Was
there a comparison of what those
percentages in our in the comparison
districts have currently with preK?
We did not look at peer district numbers
as far as emergent bilingual enrolled in
their bilingual education programs. Now,
>> okay. So, I just want to acknowledge
that there is tremendous improvement
needed in access to our programming and
for implementation of the program and
most importantly with results of the
program. Um, but I would want to just be
clear to the public that that this is
not a standard like this is not a ding
on Austin that we are currently at 80%
participation with emerging bilingual
students in elementary but only 50%
overall because that's not a that's
really not a that is you're not you're
unlikely to find any districts in Texas
that are at 90% participation prek
through 12. I just want to point that
out. Um, and then I just wanted to ask
your opinion on the staffing piece. So,
when we talked earlier about the the how
the revised chapter 89 several years ago
allows for a partner teacher with ESL
and dual language in grade levels that
it has a 50/50 break um language
allocation. Is that a recommendation
that you would I don't see that
recommendation in here, but would you
agree with the recommendation that we
should establish practices that um staff
you because of our shortages of
bilingual teachers that we establish
practices to to consistently have
partner teachers in third through fifth
grade so we can spread our bilingual
teachers across more campuses?
>> Mana, do you want to respond to that?
>> Yes, Dr. Kuffman. the the
recommendations were based on the
campuses that had a large number of
emerging bilingual students and uh many
of those positions uh they have
long-term substitutes uh versus some of
the campuses that were two-way and had
uh certified bilingual teachers.
>> Right. So I think that's one issue is
where the current bilingual teachers are
allocated. But I I I'm just wondering
would you agree with the recommendation
that we should
make use of the partner teacher model in
order to make sure we have bio teachers
available to strategically place at
those campuses.
>> Are we talking about two-way campuses?
>> Any
to be able to ensure that every emerging
bilingual student has a certified
bilingual teacher in their program
>> if they're partnering and it's a oneway
as long as they have the certification
because now we're not talking about a
two-way where it's an ESL. Is that what
you're trying to get into oneway uh dual
campuses?
>> Yes. To have a partner teacher model at
oneway dual language campuses in third
through fifth grade so that we are um
kind of doubling the reach that we have
with our bilingual teachers.
>> Okay. Yes. With an ESL partner if that's
that will be acceptable as long as
they're certified. Yes.
>> Okay.
>> And Dr. I would add I I think we need to
be as creative as we possibly can and
that's certainly one of the solutions
but that staffing was the I'll
underscore point from the report was the
singular issue brought to us by staff
members around their difficulties
implementing an effective dual language
program.
>> Okay. Thank you so much. I appreciate
it. Good to see you Dr. Rasmosen.
>> Good to see you Dr.
>> Thank you. Anyone else?
All right. Thank you so much um to our
auditors and thank you to our staff for
this uh information. Um next item item
on our agenda is third uh 14.1 part of
our commitment to discussing student
achievement. We have a presentation on
scorecold go scorecard goal one our
third grade literacy. And before we hear
our presentation we need to confirm that
our monitoring report is complete. The
following questions help us determine if
the monitoring report is effective or
not.
>> TA
>> Oh, sorry. We have a TEA approved order
update before that. Sorry. Thank you. I
will come back to this one.
>> Uh, thank you, President uh Boswell and
um Board of Trustees. I'd like to
welcome up Dr. Cherry Lee, interim
assistant superintendent of special
education and health services and
Christina Ethridge, interim executive
director for campus support and
instructional delivery to share the
Texas education order uh update uh
quarterly update. So um
take it away team.
>> Thank you. Good evening members of the
board and superintendent.
I'm Cherry Lee and like uh
superintendent said, I'm the interim
assistant superintendent of special
education and health services and I'm
joined this evening by Christa Ethridge
who's serving as our interim executive
director of special education for campus
support and instructional delivery. And
Christa brings a lot of experience here
in Austin ISD. She served as a special
education teacher. She served as a
campus administrator and as a district
leader, but this is her first time here
tonight. So, I wanted to introduce her.
and I'd like Christa to share a few
words about herself.
>> Thank you, Dr. Lee, and good evening,
trustees and superintendent Sigura. Um,
I'm honored to be serving in this
interim role supporting special
education. Um, like Cherry said, having
spent 23 years in Austin ISD, I've had
the opportunity to work across various
classrooms, um, campuses, and district
leadership. I'm also an AISD parent, so
I understand firsthand the importance of
supporting both students and families
and look forward to continuing the work
alongside our dedicated team. Thank you.
So, this excuse me, this evening, we're
pleased to share our quarterly update on
our strategic plan and we're going to be
highlighting the significant progress
made and we'll outline key priorities
and implementation steps happening this
year and beyond.
As a brief summarization, the district
was required to create a strategic plan
as required per the TEA agreed order and
for reference in early 2024, Stson and
Associates conducted a third-party
[snorts] audit which informed our
development of the plan. We submitted
the draft to TEA in April, published the
finalized document in June of 2024, and
we've presented quarterly updates to the
board since then.
>> Cold unsweetened.
The plan is designed to build an
inclusive, legally compliant, and
responsive system of services that
promotes collaboration among educators,
families, and the community to improve
outcomes for all students. At its core,
the plan establishes a clear and
cohesive service model that strengthens
inclusion, accountability, and student
success. It's anchored by five key goals
that are shown here on the screen that
are supported by 142 actionable
strategies, each focused on measurable
results. And on this slide, you can see
those five goals. And the plan is also
available for review on our external
website.
During tonight's update, we will
highlight evidence of the actions
completed and that are still underway
from the 2425 school year, demonstrating
our progress from planning to
implementation. And we'll also outline
our key priorities and focus areas. And
although we'll be talking about
strategies and completion rates and
metrics, I want to be clear, the focus
is always on students and families. Our
teachers, our campus leaders, our
families, and our students are at the
heart of the plan. Our district team
role is to empower, to support, and to
partner with campus leaders and staff so
that every school can effectively serve
and meet the needs of their students.
So, let's begin by setting the stage for
where we are in this work and where
we're headed as we continue implementing
systematic change. First, I want to
highlight our overall progress.
Across the five key areas of the plan,
our team has completed 66 of the 142
identified actions. And the chart on
this slide provides a visual snapshot of
that progress. And as you can see,
nearly 47% of the actions have been
fully completed with almost 50%
currently in progress. And this does
clearly reflect our shift from planning
to active implementation. But it's
important to note that many of these
strategies are ongoing by design and
they do require consistent and sustained
effort over time. Our goal is not simply
to check off items from a list, but to
build a supportive system of special
education services that continuously
improves and the few few actions that
are marked as not started or in revision
are intentionally scheduled for
implementation this year.
So since September of 2023 when we began
our work as identified in the TEA agreed
order, we focused on stabilizing special
education services in Austin ISD and
that did include getting caught up on
initial evaluations and requiring
extensive training for campus leaders
and staff. and the training and the
stabilization of our evaluation process
provided a strong start to our 2425
school year and allowed us to address
the actions identified within the plan.
[snorts]
During that school year, we established
clear standards for highquality IEP
development and review. We strengthened
campus implementation of family
engagement. We finalized our evaluation
and our MTSS manuals. We launched
professional development on special
education compliance. We formalized
communication channels to promote
inclusive practices. And we really
focused on parent partnership.
The progress we've made so far reflects
intentional cross-dep departmental
collaboration and a shared commitment to
building the systems and structures that
will sustain meaningful long-term
impacts for our students.
>> [clears throat]
>> So now that we've described the overall
scope of the plan, we'll take a closer
look at some of our accomplishments from
the 24-25 school year. So two goals from
this strategic plan. Goal one, which is
communicating a clear and inclusive
vision through shared ownership and goal
four, establishing highquality standards
for the development and implementation
of IEPs.
in particular were instrumental in
framing the strong structures that we
need to sustain our work. So last year
we completed multiple actions within
goals one and four and those included um
establishing clear and district-wide
commu communication cadences through
parent newsletters, the superintendent's
message and the daily news digest for
staff which was the capital. And those
are all designed to promote and model
inclusive practices. We've also focused
on centering disability awareness and
acceptance within the district's
calendar events and communications. We
focused on integrating inclusive
practices into professional learning for
both general and special education
teachers. We've also worked to advance
our CFAC or our special education family
advisory committee meetings through the
creation of the inclusion workg groups
and the transition workg groupoups which
expand opportunities for meaningful
parent and staff collaboration.
And we're also working to establish
accessible and annual learning
opportunities for families. Christa is
now going to share some very specific
details about our current and ongoing
actions related to family engagement,
our inclusive vision, and the continued
development and implementation of those
highquality IEPs.
Thank you, Dr. Lee. Building on our
focus on family and community
connections, I'd like to highlight some
of the ways our special education
department has expanded family
engagement this year.
Earlier during the August and September
special education board updates, the
board received information on family
engagement, and today I will be sharing
the latest updates and progress in that
area. One of the strongest pillars of
our strategic plan is building authentic
two-way partnerships with families. To
that end, we've launched several
initiatives designed to make information
more accessible, consistent, and
empowering for parents and caregivers.
At the center of these efforts is our
virtual family empower hour series which
has become a cornerstone of our
outreach. These weekly sessions create
transparent and accessible learning
opportunities for families of students
with disabilities directly supporting
goal one of our strategic plan.
Communicate a clear and inclusive vision
through shared ownership.
This year alone, we've hosted 24 empower
hour sessions covering nine key topics
from understanding child find process, a
parents guide to map growth scores,
accessibility supports for Chromebook,
navigating the Texas dyslexia handbook,
and 18 plus transition services.
Each session is offered twice weekly at
noon and 6 pm with interpretation
available to ensure equitable access.
We're seeing consistent strong
participation with over 300 families so
far and the feedback has been
overwhelmingly positive. Parents tell us
these sessions have helped them feel
organized and confident when advocating
for their child and better prepared for
parent teacher conferences and art
meetings. Staff members are also invited
to attend these sessions and we've
received positive feedback from campus
and district staff who join the learning
opportunities.
Building on that success, we recently
introduced Empower Hour on the Road,
offering in-person sessions at two
campuses in partnership with our parent
support specialists. This came directly
from family feedback, requesting more
face-to-face opportunities.
Our commitment to empowering families
doesn't stop at information sessions. It
extends to hands-on experiences that
help families take actionable steps. One
great example of this was our special
education transition fair held on
September 27th at Buouie High School.
This event saw over 200 participants and
offered families a meaningful
opportunity to actively plan for life
after high school. We connected families
with over 50 community partners and
agencies offering direct support and
information on critical transition areas
such as employment, post-secary
education and training, independent
living, and recreation and leisure.
The feedback from families was
overwhelmingly positive, underscoring
the importance of this annual event as a
trusted high impact resource that helps
families navigate the transition to
adulthood with confidence.
>> [clears throat]
>> In addition to these events, we've
created a family learning video library
on our website, launched a quarterly
family connections newsletter, and
expanded our outreach through weekly
social media posts and updates on the
main AISD website, ensuring families can
access resources anytime, anywhere.
>> [snorts]
>> In addition to creating meaningful
opportunities for family engagement, our
team partnered with Vela families to
provide a specialized training session
led by Maria Hernandez on October 21st.
All 70 district parent support
specialists participated in this
important professional development
focusing on strategies to support
families navigating special education
and section 504 services.
[clears throat]
The session equipped staff with
essential tools for understanding
evaluations, IEPs, and accommodations
while emphasizing compassion,
empowerment, and access to resources in
both English and Spanish to meet the
needs of our diverse parent community.
For spring 2026, we are excited about
offering additional sessions to include
strategies for families to support
positive behavior, learning routines at
home, and summer enrichment, including
bolstering reading and writing skills.
All of these initiatives are helping to
strengthen trust, build understanding,
and ensure our families feel informed,
supported, and included in every step of
their child's educational journey.
One of our main priorities this year has
been building consistent systems for
family engagement. For background, in
previous years, we developed and imple
implemented standardized AR committee
training and guidance for all campus
staff to ensure families experience a
clear, welcoming, and professional
process during every interaction with
their child's ARD team. This included
finalized protocols for parent
communication before, during, and after
AR meetings. [snorts]
Building on that foundation, this year
we are focusing on consistent proactive
family engagement and compliance.
A key initiative has been our mandatory
beginning of year family outreach where
every special education c case manager
sent a spe a personalized introduction
letter to all families using
standardized English and Spanish
templates. These letters clarify the
case manager's role as the family's
primary contact, outline IEP meeting and
progress reporting processes, and
reinforce open lines of communication.
The district also supported this effort
by sending a special education welcome
letter, providing a higher level
overview of family engagement
opportunities, provote promoting the
quarterly family connections newsletter,
sharing special education website
resources, and introducing the
confidential services at the
OMBbudzman's office.
Communications were sent electronically
with print copies provided as needed to
ensure all families received them.
Looking ahead, we are partnering with
the inclusion workg groupoup in SEFAC to
develop a problem solving guide for
campuses.
This guide built on evidence-based and
culturally responsive strategies will
help proactively address common
communication challenges, enable equit
equitable access to information, and
support shared decision-making for all
AR committee members.
This resource will help strengthen
procedural compliance and enhance the
overall effectiveness of the ART
process, ultimately supporting improved
student outcomes.
As we continue highlighting progress on
our strategic plan, I'll now share
evidence of completion for goal four,
building systems for effective early
childhood special education or ECSE
services.
This goal centers on ensuring that our
youngest learners with disabilities have
access to highquality aligned early
learning experiences.
To give a concrete example of this
foundational work in action, the ECSE
team began the 2425 school year by
developing comprehensive curricular
assessment and instructional frameworks
that align directly with district and
state standards. By our September 22nd
target date, all foundational materials
were finalized and distributed to staff.
This included curricular expectations,
assessment protocols, and instructional
models that promote both compliance and
instructional quality.
As part of our collaborative
professional development efforts, ECIC
teachers trained alongside preK teachers
in the Frog Street curriculum, ensuring
alignment and consistency across early
learning classrooms.
They also attend monthly ECSE cohort
meetings focused on service specific
topics such as early literacy, language
development, and behavior supports
to ensure curriculum alignment.
The team also developed a year at a
glance with embedded accommodations and
modifications fully aligned with the
district's prek year at a glance. This
tool helps teachers plan instruction
that integrates IEP goals into daily
classroom routines.
In the area of assessment
implementation, all ECSE teachers p
participated in targeted training on the
use of CLI engage assessments to support
datadriven instruction and progress
monitoring.
These assessments now inform both
individual student supports and
classroom level planning
to maintain coherence and
accountability. across the year. The
team also introduced an arc of learning
for ECSE providers, a datadriven
framework that outlines processes for
instruction, IEP development, progress
monitoring, and compliance. [snorts]
This ensures that instructional
decisions remain grounded in evidence
and aligned districtwide.
Family engagement is also embedded
throughout ECSE programming. Teachers
were provided with strategies and tools
to maintain ongoing communication with
families, ensuring that parents remain
active partners in their child's early
ch early learning journey.
Finally, to support continuous
improvement and leadership alignment,
the ECSE team developed walkthrough
tools and principal communication
structures.
The new ECSE classroom observation
checklist and feedback templates help
principles and district leaders conduct
focused classroom observations and
provide actionable coaching to teachers.
Expectations [snorts]
for inclusion, compliance, and quality
instruction were shared with principles
prior to the start of the year, helping
campuses begin with clarity and
consistency.
In short, we're not just making plans.
We're building systems that ensure every
ECSE classroom across the district
delivers compliant, inclusive, and
instructionally rich experiences for our
youngest learners and their families.
[clears throat]
Continuing with our focus on early
learning, I'd like to share an update on
our efforts to ensure that our youngest
learners receive highquality specialized
instruction that sets the foundation for
long-term success.
To achieve goal two, high quality
instruction, and goal four, high-quality
IEPs, we invest heavily in specialized
training and ongoing support for our
ECSE teachers.
Our approach is twofold. We provide
intensive professional learning days
paired with job embedded coaching and
support. This ensures that our teachers
are experts in the most developmentally
appropriate instructional practices,
delivering highfidelity instruction that
directly supports student success.
This year on November 4th, we held a
concentrated professional learning day
for preK teachers. PreK3 and ECSE
teachers attended a virtual session on
the foundations of literacy, a playful
approach, while preK4 teachers engaged
in making data work for you. A preK
teachers guide CLI engage.
Both sessions focused on helping
teachers use assessment data and
curriculum to provide individualized
targeted instruction
to support daily instruction. ECSE
teachers continue to have access to
highquality instructional resources
including Frog Street star autism
support and learning without tears.
These curricula enha enhance
supplemental instruction and promote
student success because they allow ECSE
teachers to provide more scaffolded
support aligned with IEP goals.
Beyond instruction, we are focused on
smooth transitions and student outcomes,
ensuring that least restrictive
environment considerations are
documented and monitored as students
transition from ECSE services into
kindergarten, ensuring continuity and
alignment with IEP goals.
[clears throat] Finally, we are
continuing to pursue external funding to
expand professional development
opportunities for our staff. Last year,
the empowering ECSE grant allowed
teachers to attend specialized trainings
at region 13. And this year, we are
applying again to provide even more
high-quality learning opportunities for
our ECSE teaching team.
Together, these efforts ensure that our
youngest learners receive instruction
that is rigorous, individualized, and
aligned with best practices, setting the
stage for long-term success as they move
through their educational journey.
>> Thank you, Christa. And um I had the
opportunity this summer to attend our
special education institute and I went
to the one of our ECSE sessions and I
did not want to leave. It was so
powerful. It was all about literacy. It
was aligned with the science of teaching
reading. Um it was meaningful. It
created a really strong professional
learning community for our ECSE teachers
who oftent time may be the only ECSE
teacher serving at their campus. And so
we're really um encouraging them and
guiding them to partner closely with
their prek teachers so that we do have
that um inclusive environment and
opportunity for our students and we
build those PLC's for our ECSE teachers
with the prek teacher which is is what
we want to see and where we're going.
Okay. So the 2526 school year marks our
transition into full implementation like
we've been saying with a strong focus on
highquality teaching and learning. To
strengthen implementation of the
high-quality services, we've launched
three key initiatives this year as shown
on this slide. So first, we're
implementing a PLC model for our special
education teachers. We know that
engaging in regular professional
learning communities sees improved
student outcomes. So based on campus
leader feedback from 2425,
our campus support coordinators host
monthly check-ins with the campus
leaders. Last year they were holding two
a month. Now this year they're just
holding one. But that second campus
check-in is where our coordinators are
holding in-person PLC's with the campus
case managers. So each PLC follows a
consistent structure that balances
compliance with IEP development and
implementation along with instructional
practices. So within the PLC's, we're
currently focusing on district-wide
improvements in the present levels of
academic achievement and functional
performance statements within the IEP.
I've spoken about these statements
before, but they describe students
academic and functional needs, and they
incorporate parent and teacher input,
academic and communication progress, and
relevant data from students evaluations,
but they're really formative. They guide
the development of the IEP goals and the
determination of appropriate services.
So, it's important that special
education teachers have the skills they
need to write strong PLA statements.
During the PLC's, our case managers
collaboratively review PLA statements
using our IEP rigor and review rubric to
calibrate the completeness and the
quality of statements. And this process
contributes to IEP consistency and
alignment across our campuses and also
is a driver of continuous improvement.
And the sessions allow campuses to
receive personalized guidance based on
campus needs as well. So to date, we've
conducted 176 PLC's across the district,
covering topics that include
accommodations and modifications,
IEP goal writing, and progress
monitoring. So far, teacher feedback
regarding the PLC's has been positive.
We've had to make some adjustments here
and there, and we continue to refine the
process based on staff input, which is
vital to matching support with real-time
needs of staff. Looking ahead, PLC's
will focus on topics like data
collection and analysis, transition
planning, and high leverage
instructional strategies.
Like I said, the PLC's can be adjusted
based on campus data and administrator
and staff feedback.
Second, we host monthly virtual special
education learning labs, as you see
there, that middle component. These are
also led by our district staff members
and they're required for all spe special
education teachers and the sessions
provide important updates related to
compliance instructional resources and
professional development opportunities.
Our related service providers and our
speech pathologists are also invited as
well and often join
PLC's connect directly uh excuse me yeah
connect directly to strategies included
in our monthly learning labs. So during
those monthly learning labs, we're
touching on topics that are reinforced
through PLC's and that really helps to
um increase classroom application to
improve student outcomes of
evidence-based strategies.
So we'll go to that last bullet there.
Uh special education lunch and learn
with our campus administrators. So these
lunch and learns just help us to expand
professional learning opportunities um
for our campus administrators. They're
optional, but so far um we held our
first uh lunch and learn in October and
we had 30 campus administrators from AC
across schools. [snorts] Also want to
point out that in addition to our PL PLC
models, our learning labs, our
administrator lunch and learns, we've
continued to expand professional
learning opportunities for special
education teachers and dyslexia
interventionists to strengthen
instructional quality and program
fidelity and student outcomes. Um, I
want to point out that our behavior and
our autism team members at the district
level have provided training to more
than a thousand uh teachers and staff
through sessions including behavior 411,
our functional behavior assessment and
behavior intervention planning training,
deescalation strategies, and a training
on how to develop the autism supplement
within that IEP.
So, I also want to point out, and we
previously shared this at our August and
September board meetings where we
presented that we provide technical
assistance to support staff staff's use
of our new frontline special education
program management system. This does
require us to continue to partner with
our IT team and our vendor to refine the
platform based on user feedback, which
we're receiving during these technical
assistance sessions. Really, it's an
ongoing process to make system
improvements. And I I recognized this
before and I'm going to say it again. I
want to thank every Austin ISD staff
member, all of the campus special
education teachers, speech pathologists,
our campus principles and assistant
principles, our 504 coordinators for
their tremendous efforts in learning and
implementing the new system. It's a huge
lift. Um the transition continues to
require sustained efforts um as we work
through all of the data migration
refinements.
All right. So the bar chart displayed on
the screen shows the total number of
actions
142 which are identified within our
strategic plan. And it's important to
continue to stress that the majority of
these actions are ongoing and do require
sustained focus over time. So we're not
looking at like a defined endpoint of
the strategic plan. We're really looking
at continuing these uh efforts through
monitoring and adjustment based on input
and feedback from staff and families to
ensure long-term success. The plan is a
living document and adjustments can be
made as necessary to align the work
across the district um which is going to
include consolidation planning and
additional support for our turnaround
campuses.
Of note, one of the recommendations from
our special education family advisory
committee was to create a more
formalized tracking system to monitor
the completions of the actions in the
strategic plan. And our superintendent
also lifted that need as well. So our
team developed a Gant chart which is a
visual tool that helps us to plan and
track and really manage pro projects
over time. Think of it as a roadmap for
this initiative showing what tasks need
to happen when and then who is
responsible. So within the strategic
plan that we created, we don't actually
have the person responsible assigned. So
we've been able to do that within this
Gant chart that we've created. And it's
really helping us to support the
management of the plan to identify
responsible parties in the work and
ensure that all of the strategies and
actions that require cross departmental
collaboration are clearly depicted which
really helps us to support our internal
management.
We'll continue to share updates on our
strategic plan with SEFAC as well,
including this Gant chart. So, our uh
SEFAC members can also monitor and
review our pro uh progress and ask for
updates.
So, in the 2526 school year, one of our
district priorities as identified in
goal two of our strategic plan is
ensuring that every student has access
to highquality tier one instruction or
first teach. and you've heard that
tonight as well. And as a part of this
effort, we are emphasizing across all of
our trainings and resource guidance
development that students receiving
special education services must have
access to the core curriculum and rich
learning experiences. To support these
efforts, our special education team
joins our academics team on
instructional walks in general education
classrooms at the elementary and
secondary levels. These walks help
ensure instructional alignment across
classrooms and campuses and inform the
training and coaching we provide based
on our observations. They also allow us
to collect both quantitative and
qualitative data on the implementation
of curricular resources and really look
closely at co-eing models.
To continue our partnership with our
academics team, we'll collaborate on the
development of the district's academic
framework to ensure that inclusive, high
leveraged teaching practices are
embedded within that framework. This
alignment will ensure our special
education teachers receive access to the
same highquality training, curriculum,
and instructional supports as their
general education peers. And students
with disabilities will be considered as
this framework is developed. The
collaboration will also ensure that the
general education curriculum and
instructional framework includes
specific strategies for teachers to
provide instruction that engages diverse
learners and removes barriers to
learning.
By integrating the framework, shared
curriculum expectations and design
principles and professional learning
structures will build a forward-f facing
guiding framework that stresses our
commitment to students with
disabilities. We want them to have
equitable access to rigorous academic
pathways and positive outcomes.
We've also expanded our focus from IEP
compliance, asking did we meet the
timelines to the incorporation of
instructional quality, asking instead,
is the instruction
and producing the desired results for
our students. Our fidelity of
implementation walkthrough process
operationalizes highquality IEP
implementation by defining observable
standards.
The walkthrough tool that we've
developed is designed to assess the
quality and effectiveness of
instructional environments and supports.
It provides evidence of how well
classrooms are structured to promote
engagement, independence, and access to
highquality instruction for students.
We're really looking for a couple of key
uh components. We're looking at
classroom setup in the physical
environment of the classroom. We're
looking at schedules. We're looking at
behavior management. We're looking at
visual and communication supports,
specific instructional practices and
materials.
And this information is used to support
coaching conversations with staff. And
actually Kristen and I were just um on a
campus yesterday um walking through
classrooms and observing these
components.
So our second departmental priority
addresses ongoing and expanded efforts
to improve student outcomes to ensure
all annual arts are held on timeline and
that we continue to maintain qualified
and certified staff to provide special
education services. So goals three and
five in the strategic plan encompass
these goals. Now we're going to talk
more about our special education
evaluation metrics identified in goal
three in our January board presentation,
but I do want to highlight a few updates
related to evaluation now, which
actually I heard earlier in today's
board or tonight's board meeting. So to
date, we have hired and onboarded 38
speech language pathologists this school
year.
We've also onboarded 14 occupational
therapists, 17 mental health specialists
who provide our counseling services, 37
educational diagnosticians, and 32
school psychologists. While we're still
actively hiring, we're seeing increased
campus level support for students and
staff. We've also significantly reduced
our spend on contracted services and are
projected to spend around 70% less on
contracted special education services
for this school year as compared to
2425.
This hiring effort has required
tremendous recruitment efforts from our
team. They've been directly supported by
our special education leadership team
who's been actively recruiting,
interviewing, hiring, and onboarding.
Dr. Baker is attending our state
conference for school psychologists and
she is definitely recruiting there as
well. We still have positions open and
available. Um but again, a key part of
these hiring efforts does include
training all of our service providers on
our frontline special education
management system so we can maintain in
compliance.
I do want to uh shout out and celebrate
our school psych psychologist. Um, this
week is actually National School
Psychology Week and collectively we
employ almost 70 school psychologists
across our school district.
We actually have other districts
reaching out and saying what are you
doing? How are you how are you employing
these people? So, I do want to uh thank
the board as well for increasing um that
salary structure for those personnel
because that's definitely helped with
the recruitment efforts as well. All
right. So in goal five, we're actively
implementing strategies to develop uh
robust teacher pipelines and refine our
resource allocation to support staffing
stability and retention, which is a huge
component. Our recruitment team has a
strategic partnership with university
instructors, which is a fasttrack
alternative certification program that
supports our district in recruiting
teacher residents. These are Austin ISD
employees and um we hope that these
employees continue to stay in our system
after they get certified. Our talent
engagement and development team is also
in the process of reviewing the House
Bill 2 lasso funding that supports
teacher residencies and grow our own
talent pipeline. Now the application is
due in December and districts will be
notified in February of their approved
approved allocations. Uh so just wanted
to share those updates as well.
So in closing, uh this year has been
defined by momental monumental
foundational achievement. We've moved 66
actions within the strategic plan to
completion and we've successfully
transitioned the majority of the work
into the sustained implementation phase.
But our focus for 2025 and 2026 and
beyond is clear. Right? We have to
continue to prioritize training and
coaching staff members to deliver
highquality instruction. We have to
continue to partner with our academics
team to build a clear academic framework
inclusive of supports and scaffolds to
ensure students with disabilities have
access to and benefit from the core
curriculum. And we have to continue to
monitor all of our AR timelines and our
evaluation timelines and support staff
members in ensuring that those timelines
are met. We've also got to be responsive
to our staff members on their needs,
right? And and really listen to their
recommendations around our frontline
digital management system as well as
school consolidations because we want to
ensure that we're partnering with our
educators and school leaders and
families to build co cohesive systems of
support.
As we close, I'd like to share that
Austin ISD will celebrate inclusive
schools week from December 8th to the
12th. And this year's theme is children
first, building a stronger future
tomorrow. The celebration highlights the
importance of every child's well-being
and belonging. And in alignment with our
strategic plan, campuses are encouraged
to participate in activities that
promote inclusion, strengthen community,
and reflect on inclusive practices
through December and January. And we're
providing those resources to our
campuses. And we'll talk more to our
principles at our next ATX bridge
meeting about opportunities
opportunities that they have to
celebrate with their campuses.
So
>> sorry. Um we thank you and we now
welcome any feedback or questions or
comments from the board or the
superintendent. So thank you.
Um I I want to start I I mean it has
been
a real really really tough I don't know
this has been like the hardest time I
would say like for for trustees they we
are going out there um and talking to
people and like
>> I I just really want like to like
acknowledge my my colleagues like when
we you came in as a board together and
then added two like amazing colleagues.
We came in to 2022.
>> Um like how how many um school
psychologists did we have
superintendent?
>> We had 23 evaluation staff members but
that would encompass diagnosticians and
school psychologists. I mean, we were in
so it was such a terrible situation and
we were like my colleagues and were so
so committed to doing everything they
could and that is like why
we hired Matias Cigur because he had
we had faith that if someone could
figure this out um because it It was so
so so bad. It was so complicated. It
seemed impossible. It seemed absolutely
impossible um to fix this.
>> Yeah.
>> And
it it didn't it didn't matter if it was
impossible. We just knew we had to do it
for kids.
>> And
um you know, I I would call school
psychologists, you know, for because
they they were not sending
interns to us at that time. they would
they would send them past Austin ISD.
They said no, we will not do that to our
students. We have a you know quality
program and I was like okay what what
needs to happen and you know I would
just I'd call people and so and so yes
the salary was increased and that's that
is a fair salary for a very very
difficult in- demand job. Um and but
it's not just that like our our school
psychologists because we have people who
stayed in spite of the impossible
workload. It does not feel good um to
not be to not have the support to do
what you know needs to be done. [snorts]
And
so it's also like the working condition.
So when you're paying people enough and
you have enough people to do the work um
it makes the work more doable. it helps
you to do a good job. And so what we've
done there is is amazing. And if we can
do that for our teachers
um and figure out how to how to do that
too, like we we've done this before.
We're in such a hard situation. So I I
just felt really it was uplifting at the
end to hear that to think about where we
we came. And so I just I just really
really thank you guys. Like I know it
was it was hard
>> work.
>> Yeah, it has been. And we're going to
talk more about evaluation specifically
in January, but it's you know, it's it's
um yes, we have um we have in-person
district personnel now providing that
full service model of evaluation. So
last year, you know, we were working
with, you know, 150 contractors as well
as as staff because we just had that
need. And because you guys approved
additional positions, we've been able to
hire um internally. And so we're
offering that full service model mean
meaning principles and campus teams have
diagnosticians and school psychologists
on campus which really which really
helps um improve implementation as well
because you have a community of special
education service providers on the
campus working together right our speech
pathologists our school psychologists
our occupational therapists our case
managers it's that multidisciplinary
evaluation team approach to serving kids
which is best is what we
So, thank you.
>> Well, no, thank you. Thank you very
much.
>> Thank you.
>> It's a work in progress. There's always
work to be done. We're always welcome.
I know. Yeah.
>> Exactly.
>> And and that's it's just making this a
place that evaluators want to come work
that school psychologists want to be
like that is not something that I think
anyone could have imagined three years
ago, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Like I just Yeah.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> So, thanks
I think that was well said at the end.
Like it's it is something that I don't
know that we could have imagined uh
honestly with the mass exodus we had
like right before it. I mean it was
>> Yes. Wasn't
>> pretty wild.
>> Yeah.
>> Have a plan.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Trusty Hunter, did I see your hand?
>> We know Fernando has a question.
>> We'll try to be ready.
Um uh two things. One I want to lift up
and uh just say how appreciative I am. I
went to
>> the um transition sort of my like mini
fair at LBJ and was really able to see
our students who received special
special education services really start
thinking about like what does a job look
like? What if I can't work eight hours?
and the the the group of people who were
there that was just really sort of um
helping them, right? Um and I I have
friends who, you know, who have children
who receive special education services
and my child receives special education
services and it's not the same, right?
um when your student is on a spectrum
and maybe you're on this end and you're
able to go and get a job but maybe this
end there's going to be like the fact
that we're finding or that the whole
team because it wasn't just us it was
like this it was a workforce and other
>> group Texas workforce
>> yes and that we're finding positions for
meaningful positions I will share one
more story and then I will get to a
[clears throat] concern I think um that
one of our Facebook um viewers shared on
Facebook [snorts] but um my I don't know
if you know my husband's blind from
birth. And one of the things that he
always like swore, he's like, "I'm not
going to make brooms." Because that's
like the only job that he's from
Tennessee where they just put blind
people in a factory and they would
literally make brooms. And he was just
like, "I'm not going to make brooms."
And nor should he because he has three
degrees and we have debt. Um so he he
should not be making brooms, but um
he's, you know, went through what used
to be called DARS and all of that. But
all of that to say, I know how powerful
it is. um when there's meaningful work
for people who have a disability and so
he now works for the state of Texas
really great insurance um and because I
got needs right high maintenance but um
he's got a great job at the state of
Texas um he works for uh the talking
book program which we also share so if
our students are using those books he's
probably he also um has done some
volunteer work at Chris Cole teaching
braille and that those sorts of things
and so I really just appreciated that
for our students
There's an end, but it's not an end,
right? They're not just going to go home
and sit in their parents. We don't have
basements here, but you know what I
mean. They're actually going to get to
go out and have meaningful, gainful
employment, and I appreciated that.
>> Thank you for that. I do I I want to
invite your husband to come talk to, you
know, to our students and our teachers
on a disability panel. That would be
really powerful. Thank you for sharing
that. We have
>> He used to do it for my my my kids back
like when they were in school and he'd
bring like the little braille cards,
right? Um and then he he's done like
reading for Miss Dance's class at
Maplewood where he'll bring like um a
cited braille book. So happy to do any
of those. I'm volunteering him by the
way um to do all those things.
>> Well, and I also thank you for talking
about the talking book program. We are
actually required to tell students or
families of students who have disability
or suspected disabil suspected of
dyslexia that they have free access to
the talking book program. It's a really
powerful program.
>> BART is great. I'm not great. Um and
then the thing that's a little bit more
on on the um serious side um is one of
the parents mentioned and I think this
is not particular to special education
services but we do have this big plan
right now where we are really trying to
communicate and engage parents and I
think um one of the parents shared it's
very powerful um she said uh engagement
is not information sharing.
>> That's right.
>> And it's two-way and I was like that's
right. Um, and so I just really want to
encourage I I appreciate the things that
you're doing and I see that you know and
like I said the the meeting that I just
went to like two Saturdays ago I think
it was was very much information sharing
but in a way that parents were able to
comm it was like so what about this and
what about that? Well my situation's
different. Um and so um I think that
that's just my that's good for us to be
mindful of all the time is that
sometimes we're like here dump now you
figure it It's like it's that like now
that I gave that information to you,
what do you think? How can you were you
able to digest all of it? Are there
smaller pieces I need to break it in?
Are when you walk away, do you
understand?
>> Slowing down during the learning.
>> It is. Trusty Singh asked a very good
question about like do our parents
really understand? And the answer is no.
There are parents that still don't know
we're going to be closing schools. Like
they they're just not in that loop,
right? We swim in it and it's again like
it's oxygen. We don't even know because
we're in it so much. Um, again, thank
you so much for it was the the
transition program, it was the
communication and uh an appreciation for
again because it was not awesome because
it feels like eight years ago, but it
was just three, not even three years
ago. Yeah.
>> When like we were sworn in and we went
and got sat in that room and they're
like, "So, you should probably know."
And from there to now, it's I mean that
was a herculean task. I mean, and I know
that it's not complete, but uh lots to
continue to do, always better
refinements. We're humans,
unfortunately, but um our kids deserve
the absolute best, and our kids who need
more deserve our absolute best, also.
Thank you.
>> Great. Thank you.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. two years and two months.
>> Oh wow. Yeah. Um I'm gonna give Trist
deoste the chance to go last. So I will
just say really quickly um it is really
great to hear from families that um they
don't find themselves with a child who
suddenly they discover needs special
education services and have to figure it
out on their own.
>> Yeah.
>> In the way families have before. There's
still a support network and a grapevine,
but it's not a kind of I'm not hearing
the same kind of desperation. If I'm so
alone and the only way I did it was to
go figure it out that there is support,
people are feeling that.
>> I really appreciate that. I'm hearing
that people feel that with transition
services. I think we were famously bad
at transition services for a while in
the same way that I think people didn't
want to send um you know, teachers and
training to us. And I think I'm just
hearing so much positive from families
that they're getting the support they
need, that they feel seen and understood
and feel like their kids um are getting
what they need and like families, you
know, through families getting what they
need to help their kids navigate this
system. So, thank you. I mean, that it
is profound
>> um some of the changes. So, really just
want to share gratitude.
>> Thank you. And really, I mean, that
hinges on trained teachers that have the
resources that they need. So that's our
goal at the district level is to really
equip the teachers
>> to have what they need to help our
students.
>> Yeah. And it's the outreach programs. It
is absolutely that family opportunities
and the resource fair and the transition
fair and the
>> just making [snorts] sure that there's a
lot happening so people can kind of jump
into that stream when they find out they
need it. So I'm hearing that.
>> Thank you
>> loudly from people. So thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> That's it from me.
>> Okay. I don't [laughter] I don't really
have to be the last if anybody else has
questions. Um
well, so I'll start with the thank yous
and this appreciate all the information
that that's in here. Um you know, I I I
do have questions. I wanted to kind of
frame it and by acknowledging, you know,
a lot of this is foundational work,
structural work kind of in align with
alignment with all the other stuff that
we've been doing is is tends tends to be
very systemic and structural um
>> as it needs to be I think for for
addressing a lot of the improvements
that we're looking for. I kind of want
to frame some of these um because I
think it's helpful for the community as
well, but you know um with the
consolidations and the turnarounds and
all that stuff that's going to be coming
up um it's kind of I I think maybe uh
putting it lately a stress test for a
lot of the foundational work that you've
been doing. And so I'm I'm going to try
and tie in some of those pieces uh as as
we're addressing. So, you know, for my
first question, you know, with the
expanded family engagements and the
efforts that you've been having around
the communication and, you know, um kind
of the key accomplishments, can you
speak a little bit how you're
anticipating that work um kind of how
how we're taking advantage of that in
the spring, you know, as we go through
the transition pieces. How do you see
those tying in?
>> I think that's a great question. We're
going to create some additional focused
opportunities for families whose
students might be transitioning to
really consider social emotional um
challenges or or concerns that families
may have with their students um knowing
and understanding that they will be
shifting to a new school. That's also
going to include um you know reaching
out to staff as well to determine what
concerns they have. What concerns are
they hearing from their students and
their communities, right? because we're
going to have to build guidance for not
only families but for our staff as well
to support families and to support
families through the AR process as well.
Um right now um we've you know when
we're looking at the proposed um
schools that that may be consolidated if
we're looking at those 10 schools um
we're looking at about 850 students
receiving special education services
that would be moving to a new campus. So
we've initially identified those
students. um we're doing a deeper um
aggregation or disagregation of the data
to look at students that may be on
centralized placements or have
specialized services. Um it's going to
be important to consider um the entire
group, but also look at students that
have specialized needs or more complex
needs and really consider how we're
going to support families and staff as
they transition to new schools to
support the services.
>> Yeah.
>> So along those lines then um
where was it? I guess towards the end of
the report when when you're talking
about those staffing and program
allocations,
>> you know, um is that playing a part in
those discussions or you know trying to
think um what the right way to frame
that is but you know because that's a
process that we're you know I think
simil similar to boundary changes and
things every so often you're going to
update right you're going to say do we
need a scores program here or you know
how how you're adjusting those
centralized placements.
>> Yes. Um, so is that structurally
something that you're already confident
in or is that like the process that
we're designing out? I know there's a
lot of
>> I would say both. I feel like we're
confident in it, but we're also um, you
know, constantly receiving feedback and
input from our teachers, especially our
teachers at those schools that are being
consolidated because it's really
important to hear their voice in this
process to help us guide the plan. Um, I
don't think any of us, you know, most of
us sitting here haven't um, directly
supported schools being consolidated,
right? So, we're really having to lean
on our staff members, our campus
leaders, and our parents to help support
us as we um as we plan supports for our
students. Um I do want to say that um at
our uh wallto-wall dual language
campuses, the proposed campuses, I would
say, we are planning on a full continuum
of supports, meaning those wall-to-wall
campuses would be offering early
childhood services as well as our life
skills services. Um, we're also
continuing and we do have a full
continuum of services at all middle
schools and high schools. So, I do want
to say that now we do not have
centralized placements or need
centralized placements because we have a
full continuum of services. Um, we also
are planning on having um behavior
support. So, the SPS and the score
services across all of our elementary
school uh campuses. Now, we could be
considering more uh a centralized
placement for a student who may require
or need a bilingual SPS or score
service, right? So, we that could be um
that could be a consideration for a
centralized placement because we are not
going to be able to offer bilingual SPS
or score services across all of our
campuses. Um or bilingual ECSE or life
skill services across all of our
campuses because they those are so
specialized. So, we're really going to
have to spend um I would say a good
amount amount of planning time um with
our district level staff, but also with
campus staff um considering those
students that require those specialized
services through the consolidations
process. It's going to be ongoing. We're
also partnering with our planning
committee and with it as well so that um
we have and because we we do have a
consistent platform, we're using this
ERP system which houses our uh student
information as well as our special
programs information as well. It's
really going to allow us to uh map uh
students addresses, right, where they're
being reassigned to um with their
specific special education needs, right?
Their service minutes. So, we'll be able
to, you know, pull up um data
spreadsheets with that information which
will help us with staffing. Now, some of
this is dependent on enrollment, too.
When families enroll um if they're
selecting or they're, you know, they're
choosing a priority um transfer for the
wall-to-wall dual language. Um if
they're choosing, you know, to to go to
another campus, like all of those
considerations have to be um reviewed
when we're making those staff placements
based on student enrollment. Okay, that
that's great because that kind of
transitions into, you know, in your
transition plan from the consolidation
part, you're talking about ensuring the
equitable staffing and and
>> absolutely that's
>> that's the type of data that
>> that is the type of data that's going to
help us um determine where our uh
special education teachers and teaching
assistants are going to go. We're also
going to have to carefully consider
placements for our speech pathologists,
our OT's, our PTs. So, you know, it's a
very complex process because we do have
so many staff. We have 2500 staff
members that support special education
services and that does include teaching
assistants, special education teachers,
and then all of those related service
providers and speech pathologists. So,
for those uh you know 10 consolidated
schools and all of the reassignments,
it's it's not only students, right? It's
it's the staff that support those
students so we can maintain that
continuity of services. It will be a
complex process. Um and we're planning
early. we've already started, right? So,
we've already started that process of
planning.
>> Okay. I appreciate that because I know
some of the feedback I had been getting
is, you know, concern for people know,
you know, is my TA going to track with
the change or is the, you know, the life
schools teacher going to track with the
change.
>> But, um, you know, if I'm if I'm hearing
you correctly, you know, that's going to
get a little more complicated. the same
as people worrying about other
programming changes or or school changes
because it's going to depend on the
actual students that are going to get
zoned for the campus or you know which
programming you're putting there. So you
might have to move staff depending on
where the need is, right?
>> That's exactly right. Okay.
>> I [snorts] mean we are going to do our
best to have continuity for our
students, right? So that the case
managers, the dyslexia interventionist,
the you know teaching assistants move
with students. That may not always be
possible, right? Some may be re going to
another location, not with the cluster
of students because it's not a a
onetoone, right? It's not all of the
students at one school are going to
another location. So, there is going to
have to be um some split there, but
we'll have to make those decisions once
we have that enrollment those those
enrollment measures. So, we are
encouraging families to enroll early.
So, that the earlier we have that data,
that's going to help us support with
staffing and reassignments. I also want
to state that we are not planning a
reduction in force at all. So, we're
continuing and we're planning for all of
our special education teachers and TAs
um to to move and find new homes. So I I
think that's a really important thing to
highlight what you're saying there both
about um the early enrollment and the
potential splits because I don't know
that the special education families are
are really understanding that yet
because it kind of mirrors the potential
uh upset is going to mirror the same as
um you know communities that are getting
splits on on the feeder patterns and the
zoning.
>> Yes. you know, if you have to split a
life skills class or, you know, if the
students get separated, but you know, I
think to highlight, not to alarm the
families for for anybody that's
watching, but the the point being that
it's it's related to programmatic
improvement, right? You're saying it's
going to inform the staffing to make
sure you have enough TAs or that you
have the right teachers.
>> Um, but I don't know that families are
going to understand that quite yet. And
it is one of the things, you know, if
I'm understanding you, makes sense. the
earlier they enroll, the more you're
going to have the numbers solidified to
know where that staffing goes. So, I
think some of the families that are
asking, is my TA going to go? Is the
teacher going to go there? Um, you know,
that answer gets more solidified the
more you're confident on what the
enrollment is going to be.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, and so that it's an interesting
chicken in the egg there because I don't
know that that's fully understood that
you're going to, you know, by nature,
you're not going to staff it first and
then assign the kids there. you have to
figure out which kids are there and then
you're going to do the staffing. Um
>> yeah, once the plan is finalized, we're
actually going to be surveying teachers
at consolidated campuses and receiving
campuses. We've actually we started
we've developed the survey, but we're um
you know, we're waiting until the plan
is finalized, but we're going to be
surveying staff and then we'll be um
conducting focus groups as well to help
us with the planning. But we want to
know what their immediate concerns are,
what their needs are, and how we can
best support them. One of the things
that we're already considering is and
we've requested additional funds to um
offer functional pay for uh for special
education case managers to come back
early, like three days early, both
teachers that are going to be received
at campuses and then teachers and staff
members that already at the campuses so
that they can have those three days to
plan to review schedules to determine
how they'll be providing all of those
minutes because this is going to be um
it's going to be really critical for
these staff members to be planning
together because many of our receiving
leaving campuses are going to have
expanded programs. Maybe they weren't
offering early childhood special
education services before, but now they
will be. Maybe they weren't offering
life skill services before, but now they
will be. So, they're going to, you know,
need to be planning with space, with
resources, with materials. We're going
to want to make sure that all of those
materials and resources get to um you
know, the new receiving campuses so that
that folks are prepared to receive
families.
>> Okay. And then, you know, latching on to
that because I want I want to make sure
I keep it focused on on the strategic
plan and not too much on this, but I am
trying to tie things in.
>> Um, so long those that's great that
they're coming in early and um
>> and it it won't be required because the
staff schedules have already been set,
but we're going to offer that functional
pay for these staff members and we're
going to encourage them if they have
that availability to to come into plan.
So I think along those lines then um you
know coming back to Frontline and the
underlying systems that they're going to
be using. I know it's been a big lift to
get everybody moved to Front Line.
>> It's still a lift. We're still working
through a lot of the migration issues,
but we're working through it.
>> Right. So are we building in uh or you
know can you speak more to the the
training for the staff and and making
you know another way to within the
context of it being a stress test? we're
gonna have to do a lot of IEP meetings
in the spring and, you know, adjusting
all these things. Um, you know, are
there any extra resources we're needing
to put in or how are we, you know, how
are we um confident as far as the just
being able to use the system?
>> Yeah, we've actually talked to um staff
members and from family and family
members as well. And one of the things
that we're um recommending we're going
to require actually is for students that
are receiving specializ or centralized
placements, we are going to require an
AR for those students that are moving to
a new campus. It will be optional for
families to request an AR if their
student um will be reassigned to another
campus because they're on a campus where
they're um their their campus is being
uh consolidated. So, we are not going to
require ARDS for every single student
because that could potentially be 862
students that are currently projected to
to attend a receiving school, but then
we have another 372 students that may be
impacted through the dual language
wall-to-wall changes as well. So, that
would put a tremendous stress on
campuses if we were to require them to
conduct an additional 1,200 AR meetings
in the spring. So, right now we're
looking at discussions with families,
supports for families, conversations for
families and with families, but then
requiring arts for students that are uh
will be impacted by or through a
centralized placement. Um, I also want
to I think it was um trusty singing that
you mentioned you said, have families
been emailed about these changes? One of
the things that we'll be doing, we're
planning to send these emails in
February, is for any family member um
whose child is receiving special
education services at a school that's
being consolidated. We are providing
them a personal email as to your
students receiving services, the school
is being consolidated, and this is where
they will be, you know, we were
projecting them to receive services at
their reassignment.
>> Yeah.
Um along those lines, you you had talked
uh about trainings around PLA statements
and uh
>> you know I think those are certainly
going to be critical for students that
are moving to new staff or you know that
the IEP is going to be kind of picked up
by potentially a different case manager
or different teachers are going to be
looking at it and you know those
performance levels tell such a story you
know beyond kind of the goals. um you
know are are [snorts] we specifically
looking at any of those pieces or or
just for the IEP in general like there's
things that we can do through amendments
or or you know just cleaning up IEPs
like is there any kind of need around
that or thought around um making sure
that the IEPs are going to transfer um
because it's also you know we had kind
of high quality IEPs I think was one of
the pieces in the larger plan
>> um so I guess maybe a different way to
phrase that is how much are we tying and
the work towards the high quality IEPs
to have that be part of those students
that are potentially moving to different
campuses.
>> I think that's a really great question
and I think we are going to provide
clear guidances guidance for campuses so
that when they're communicating with
families, it's not only the campus
administrator that feels confident
communicating about um the children's,
you know, transition, but it's also case
managers as well. We want to have a
consistent framework across all of the
campuses that are being consolidated so
that parents are receiving a consistent
message and they feel confident in this
process. This is difficult enough,
right? So, we here at the district level
need to make sure our campus
administrators and our case managers
have that information, right? They they
know where their students are being
projected. They feel confident in having
these discussions in our meetings or in
other parent meetings as well in the
spring. So, we'll be working on that
guidance as soon as the plan is
finalized.
And so yeah, I think maybe the just just
to rephrase it for myself, but I think
um you know on your slide 11, I think it
was on the core work um 2526, you know,
the
>> ensure the fulfillment of evaluation
requirements makes sense to me as far as
ones where where everything's either in
progress or complete.
>> Yeah. And so, um, really the implement
high quality instruction and the improve
student outcomes and accountability,
those two, like how we're going to keep
those in progress while we're doing all
this extra work. And so, you've kind of
already answered that question some. I
wanted to make sure I was tying it back
>> to the slides from what you were working
there. In that um, same vein though, you
know, the the area that has the most red
on it um, is the high quality standards
for the IEPs. And so can you speak a
little bit to, you know, the work that
we're still going to be doing on that
piece?
>> Absolutely. Yeah, that last one it, you
know, it deals with the development of
the IEPs and then the implementation of
the IEPs. I mean, that is just ongoing
work. That is ongoing work and we're
really moving to that implementation
model and phase. I will say we've had a
couple of additional lifts, right? We've
we've had, you know, transitioning to
this new frontline system. Previous to
that, we did a whole lot of training.
Some of it was asynchronous and not best
practice, but that was required by the
TEA agreed order. We really tried to
shift some of that asynchronous training
to um you know personalize it for Austin
ISD. But um you are right. I mean the
work ahead of us and the work that will
you know continue is that implementation
is really focusing on teachers ability
to be able to provide highquality
services using the curricular resources
with fidelity to be able to communicate
the progress with their families. um you
know and to be able to document that um
not only in a legally compliant way but
in a meaningful way within that IEP and
you are right I mean we're the PLA is so
critical to to the IEP because it is
telling um the story of a student's
development and their progress and their
continued needs and that is exactly
right it's going to help the receiving
campuses and receiving case managers and
staff members be able to understand the
student right to be able to support the
student um so all of that is correct and
all of that is really where we are. Um
I'm looking forward to you know the the
majority of our training at the
beginning of this school year in August
um wasn't the professional learning
around instructional uh quality and
implementation of services. It was
around frontline right so this year
we're balancing you know supporting case
managers with using frontline and then
also building in that opportunity for
them to get trained on you know more
specific components of instruction.
Um, so then along those lines, um, could
you speak a little more about the the
PLC models that you've been using and if
you have any specific plans around the
TAP schools, consolidation schools as
far as, you know, how PLC's are are
going to go into that piece. I feel like
you spoke a little bit about focus on
some of those schools.
>> Yeah. And I mean, right now we have, you
know, three three of our middle school
campuses are turnaround schools. So one
of the things that we've done here at
the district level is to reduce the
number of schools um that our
coordinators who are supporting
turnaround campuses uh directly support.
So let's say an instructional specialist
supports 30 campuses, we're reducing
that tremendously so that they can
increase their uh visits and their
support of teachers at the turnaround
campuses. And that's been really helpful
and meaningful so that um the staff at
our turnaround uh schools um have more
personalized PLC time um opportunities
to ask questions, opportunities for
coaching. Some of our specialists are
actually, you know, providing direct
services to students right now at our
turnaround and they're coaching and
they're modeling for staff members
there. So I think to your question, I
mean one of the most important parts or
I think one of the most effective um
strategies that we've seen and that
we're implementing right now is to
increase support from our district level
staff for coaching purposes. Right now
our instructional specialists at our
turnaround schools and all of our
campuses are typically and primarily
focused on general education supports.
Right? That doesn't mean that they're
not um you know positively impacting
students that are receiving special
education within general education, but
it's our our specialists at the district
level that are providing that coaching
for our special education teachers
specifically. Yeah. So, that's one of
the strategies that we're using and
actually um we're working with Josh and
our um assistant superintendent of of
school leadership in developing those
turnaround strategies specific to
special education. But that's one
component is developing meaningful PLC's
for these staff members.
>> Yeah.
>> And could you speak a little bit more uh
to the walkthrough tool and and how
that's being used?
>> Yeah, absolutely. So, um when we partner
with our academics team, we're using the
MTSS tools and rubrics that they have
looking at those features of high
quality effective instruction. That's
just a general education walkthrough
tool. When we are using the walkthrough
tool that we spoke of tonight, um it is
developed specifically for our team.
Campus administrators could use it too,
but we're really um evaluating uh our
special education teachers in both
inclusive settings, but also in more
specialized settings. So, we're looking
for specific features of instruction
that we would be expecting our special
education teachers to be providing. It
is a digital form. So, it allows us to
go through classrooms and be on campuses
and use phones or iPads to quickly, you
know, take down information. Um, because
then we're also able to take that
information and we're able to review it
at a campus level, at a district level.
What specific areas do we to like add
additional professional learning on
because we're seeing weaknesses here?
And we're also able to communicate that
information with staff themselves, but
with principles, too.
>> So, is data from that tool something
that we can see in future reports?
Absolutely.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah,
>> I think that Yeah, that would be great.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> Um
I another one I I wanted to um call out
the TA tote teacher pipeline.
>> Um one I think that's great. I I was a
TA, I became a teacher, and then I was a
lead teacher. Um so I I I definitely
appreciate the the thought there and I I
think TAs can become
>> really good teachers modestly, I would
say. Um,
>> but
yeah, I guess how how broad is that
program or like how how how much buyin
are we getting on that program? Like how
many how many TAs are
>> Oh, good.
>> involving in it.
>> Our friend Miss Hosac is coming up to
provide more information.
>> I was just trying to find a way to get
Randy up.
>> Yeah. Yay. We got her up here.
>> I appreciate that. I was feeling left
out. Um right now we are approaching
about 40 in the district and so those
are not just special education but
majority special education. Um we also
have um some of them that are going to
be also in our bilingual teacher
pipeline program. So
>> awesome.
>> We're we're very excited about that.
>> Excellent. And how long has that been
going on?
>> Approximately uh what week is it of
school? What that many weeks? So we we
just started at this this school with
this partner. say
>> and 40 already.
>> Yes, sir. We started out with 30 and our
our vendor was uh our partner was able
to to come up with 30 and they they're a
n they have a really like a large
digital footprint uh in the recruitment
space and so um they are very quick,
very agile and uh have uh filled we
filled 30 quickly and then um I have I
have made friends with the CFO many
times to ask for more because we are
having success in that platform. Is is
that equivalent to, you know, any of the
other emergency alternative
certification type things? Like how
quickly does the TA um eligible for a
teaching position?
>> It's a great question. So, this is um
like I said, it's our first year, but to
be very fair, this was one of uh it was
really an Austin ISD special. And what I
mean by that is they brought us a
product and said, "Hey, we can do this
thing." Um but they it was going to
remain their employee and I very much
wanted to have AISD employees come on um
because at the end of the day if the the
worst case scenario happens I still get
to retain them as a TA.
>> Yeah.
>> And so um but the the beautiful thing
about this program is that we are
bringing them on. So they're helping
from the recruitment. um they are the
certification program and they also
provide the first year of instructional
coaching and they are they are aligning
to what our expectations are for the
district. So they're kind of an end
toend service for us for these for our
novice teachers for for this pipeline.
So um we're we're incredibly excited
about what we're seeing so far.
>> And is I guess um just functionally or
are we finding like those TAs are going
to stay on the same campus and become a
teacher there? They're getting
reassigned or how how is that playing
out? Also a great question. So, um, we
the the fastest that they can become
that they can probably finish their
certification is three months and we
want them to do that and we've actually
put some skin in the game on that if
that if they can get that within the
first semester that that we will go
ahead issue the contract so that we can
get them up and going in that way. Um,
you know, we would love for them to stay
on that campus if there if there's room
to be able to do that. Um this is also
how we backfilled um when some of the
the polling that we did from campuses to
help staff up our three turnaround
campuses and we you know begged our our
folks to go over there and help stand
those campuses up. We have actually
backfilled that with with these pipeline
uh so that the teachers can come back
should they choose to do that and then
we can place our residents elsewhere uh
once they are once they're certified.
But it's it's going to be a case by case
basis whether they get to stay. But I
will tell you that we will retain them
as employees.
>> Yeah, that's great. I love it.
>> Me too.
>> Yeah, thank you very much. Um,
now I'm just going down any notes I
still had on the E ECSE teacher
trainings like how how many how big are
those trainings? How much staff are we
training?
>> So, let me give you some metrics here
and Krista may help me out as well. Um,
let me start with our ECSE teachers. I I
wrote I I thought that might be a
question tonight. Um but just overall we
we currently have 26 um ECSE teachers
that are bilingual. Uh we have 39 ECSE
teachers um that are monolingual and
then we have one ECSE teacher that
supports our deaf and heart of hearing
students at Galindo Elementary. So
that's the total number. Um so 66 total
um ECSE service providers across the
district. We provided 10 trainings so
far. Um, at our sped institute this
summer, it was, you know, an optional
training. We had about 10 ECSE teachers
that were there. And then at our monthly
cohort, it is highly recommended that
staff attend. So, typically we have
about 30 to 40 that are attending. Um,
you know, we have a special ECSC
newsletter and emails that go out as
reminders to let that, you know, let
those folks know. Um, Christrista, you
want to add anything else about No.
Yeah. I mean, uh, November 4th was our
professional learning day for staff.
also our culture of voting. But um we
did require ECSE teachers to attain that
to attend the prek training. And again,
it's just an inclusive opportunity. We
really want to ensure that although
we're providing specialized instruction
and services for the ECSE teachers that
they have an opportunity to attend prek
training. We want our ECSE teachers and
we expect them to use the prek
curriculum. They can modify, they can
adjust, they can um use additional tools
and resources, but that's the core
curriculum. That's the foundation and
that's what they need to be using. We
want to give our uh ECSE students um the
best opportunity to enter kindergarten
with the skills they need.
>> And so the the focus on the training for
ECSE
um I'm trying to think how to phrase
this. Is is that a focus that's was just
specifically for ECSE or is this
something that's going to be going
across different domains like you know
kind of the systematic part of it?
>> We highlighted ECSE tonight but yes we h
we provide differentiated training and
that's actually part of the strategic
plan is to provide differentiated
training for service providers. So we've
increased training for the autism
supplement this year. We have two autism
specialists that are are heading those
trainings up. We also have a specific
team that provides support and training
for dyslexia as well. So, some of these
more specialized services, we do provide
specific training. Some of that's
required by law, right? We're required
to provide those trainings by law and
ensure those persons are um prepared um
to provide those services. But yeah, we
just we focus primarily on ACSC tonight.
Yeah. Well, I guess maybe a different
way to to phrase that question is um is
this uh I guess demonstr demonstrative
of our capacity to do training? So like
I I assume there's only so much we can
train on at a time across the district
or
>> because there's only so many district
professional development days that we
can provide the training.
>> Okay.
>> Um [snorts] so that we're somewhat
limited by that. We also provide
optional training in the summer. We
provide these, you know, cohorts for our
ECSE service providers and our life
skill service providers, but we're
somewhat limited by just the amount of
time that we have. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. And then thank you. I I appreciate
your patience with all these questions.
This last
>> piece that I have, but um
>> you know, in the context of of I sped, I
guess, as an outlier across
>> the rest of the district and the rest of
the lifts that we're trying to do. Yeah.
Um, you know, I think a lot of the
successes that we're seeing, you know,
incrementally are at the end of the day
cost money, right? It's stipens and, you
know, all of the rest of it. And so I'm
kind of curious on, you know, filling
all these particularly with the LSSPs
and, you know, the comment about um
really attracting all that staff is um
kind of the cost of getting it right, if
that makes sense. you know, and I know
we're trying to pull back on the
contracts and that that was a big piece
um for the initial lift,
>> but um you know, kind of what is our
increase in [snorts] investment, I
guess, from before any of this was
happening. I don't know if that's a
relevant metric. Um but maybe a
different way to put it would be to, you
know, to continue this success. Is it
going to be continued cost? Like is it
going to continue to increase as we're
increasing our capacity? just, you know,
I think
at the very least so that the public can
understand the investment that it's
taking besides all the hard work that
we're also doing. Um, [snorts] you know,
there is a cost associated with it and I
I kind of think it's worth acknowledging
that.
>> Absolutely. I mean, the majority of the
the funding that we spend um here in
Austin ISD and certainly in our special
education department is on staff, right?
It's on staff and it's on compensation.
But I mean, we do have additional
grants, both state and federal, and we
also apply for additional grants for
teacher training because that's just an
incredibly important part of the piece.
I mean, if you want to retain staff, you
have to provide high quality training so
that staff have the tools and the skills
that they need to be successful because
successful teachers are more likely to
stay, right? Successful speech
pathologists are more likely to stay.
So, we have an arc of learning here in
our department that we um we we call it
an arc of learning. So what is our arc
of learning for the year for teachers,
for speech pathologists, for OT's um and
we try to be um we try to provide much
of the training in house with the talent
we have here at the district, but there
are times that we, you know, want to
pull in outside providers, providers
from region 13. We also may send staff
members to region 13 or other regional
service centers, um you know, or or
other training entities or we may bring
in staff to provide specific training.
Um so yes that the amount of money we
have is limited and finite but at the
same time we try to align the budgetary
means that we have with our priorities
which is to equip you know teachers with
the with the tools and the skills they
need. I think one thing that's really
exciting about the academic vision is
that alignment with general ed and
special education. Um, and one of the
things I was just in a classroom
actually uh yesterday or the day before
um and I was just observing instruction
and and one of our special education
teachers was using one of the tiered
resources as part of their special educ
service delivery model and they were
modifying that tiered resource to meet
the needs of that student. And that's
what we want to see. You know, we want
our special education teachers to have
access to every tool that's available
for all children to meet the needs of
their students. And so in this case, um,
this resource did not cost the campus
any money. They already had it. They
were already using it. The teacher had
already received training and been
provided that training. Um, and you
know, that's what we want to see. We
want to see that alignment. We want to
see our teachers using the resources
that we have. But yes, we are
additionally spending our funds to um,
align the arc of learning that I'm
calling it, right? Um, and mapping those
uh, that training to the needs that
we're hearing from our staff members.
Thanks. Uh I appreciate all of it. Um
you know I I want to highlight just to
book end one more thing is you know I
appreciate the you know the effort to
hire highly qualified but also be
training up um you know bringing up from
within the ranks and so you know I I do
think that's a really good way to bridge
the gap between the two ends. Um, so I
appreciate that work and and really look
forward to,
>> you know, um, capitalizing on all this
work as we go through the, you know, the
additional new work that's going to come
up during the spring. Um, but I
appreciate that we have, um, you know,
bones to be building on as we go through
all the rest of this. So, thank you.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> Thank you, trustees. Any other
questions?
>> All right. Thank you so much for this
update, for all of the information, for
all of the work. really appreciate it.
Um,
Miss Ethridge, thank you for joining us.
Yeah, appreciate it. All right. Um, now
we are up for 14.1 student achievement.
Um, our next item is part of our
commitment to discussing student
achievement and we have a presentation
on score goal scorecard goal one third
grade literacy. Um, thank you for
everyone who is still with us to help
present this. Before we hear our
presentation, we need to confirm that
our monitoring report is complete. Uh,
the following questions help us
determine if the monitoring report is
effective or not according to Lonear
governance. Does the monitoring report
clearly show which specific goal or
interim goal is being monitored? Does
the monitoring report show data for the
three previous reporting periods,
preferably on a line graph? Does the
monitoring report clearly show the
current reporting period? Does the
target reporting periods, annual
targets, and the deadline target? Does
the monitoring report clearly show the
superintendent's current view via a
defined set of indicators of the systems
performance relative to the goal? Does
the monitoring report clearly show
supporting documentation
that supports the students understanding
of system performance? If the system is
not meeting the target or the
superintendent's understanding of the
systems performance indicates
implementation is not on track, does the
report clearly describe systemic root
causes, strategic responses and
rationale and any needed next steps? So,
does anyone have evidence that the
elements of an effective monitoring
report are not present?
All right. Um, so we will now turn the
floor to Superintendent Sigura for our
presentation. Thank you.
>> Thank you, President Boswell. Uh, the
team and I will present on the board
monitoring report. I have joining me Dr.
Maryanne Maxwell, assistant
superintendent of academics. Jennifer
Pace, assistant superintendent of
elementary schools, and Liliana
Kendrick, director of elementary
humanities. And so um this is goal one
uh third grade literacy which reads the
percent of third grade students earning
meets grade level or above on the star
reading assessment in English or Spanish
will increase from 47% in June of 2024
to 59% by June of 2029. Uh the goal
progress measure that we use throughout
the year um to track uh kind of our work
in this area. uh second grade literacy
intervention which reads the percent of
second grade students scoring in the
recommended for intervention level on
the NWEA MAP reading achievement score
proficiency indicator below 30
percentile in English and 40th
percentile in Spanish and again this is
one of the ones that we want to see go
lower and lower will decrease from 30%
in June 2024 to 29% by June 2029
uh uh the initiative overall that this
aligns to is early childhood and uh as a
reminder based on the new formatted
um reports. Uh there's an evaluation of
progress statement uh made by the
superintendent regarding kind of the
information that was used to determine
whether we're on track or not. Uh and so
based on the the data and and the work
that the team has done and our um
overall effort, uh I I do believe that
we are on track to meet the third grade
literacy goal. uh with 49% of third
grade students uh uh which have earned
meets grade level or above on the star
reading assessment which is an increase
in 47% in 2324.
Uh data meets the current year targets
and suggest the district uh inputs and
work around improving literacy is
positively impacting student outcomes.
Uh next steps include continuing to
focus on high quality materials and
instruction, professional learning for
staff and expanding coaching
opportunities around observation and
feedback. Uh, one of the things that I
think is um important to note here is um
as you look at the data uh and kind of
see where the um um summit of assessment
kind of uh performance-wise ended up for
our district. Uh it's kind of
interesting to see just the correlation
regarding the goal progress measures.
It's one of the things we always talk
about you making sure our goal progress
measures uh are indicators um you know
of our overall performance and our
predictors. Uh and I think that is
certainly the case here. So, with that,
I'll hand it over to Dr. Maxwell um to
kick us off and take us through the the
presentation.
>> Thank you. Uh good evening again,
Superintendent Sugura and and President
Boswell and and board of trustees. Uh
we're excited to bring this literacy
report to you tonight um to really just
talk about the the sumitive of what um
happened last year in literacy and some
of the things that we've learned and
that we'll be doing moving forward. Um
we're uh we're pleased that we did meet
our target uh set for this year for the
2025 year. This does provide early
evidence that um we're on track to meet
our five-year goal and also early
evidence that some of the things that
we've been putting in place in the
district are successful. Uh [snorts]
some of those are those just a real
focus on our literacy framework and all
the things that are aligned to it and
also a really strong focus on tier one
instruction that of course comes with
MTSS and some supports and things we've
implemented with tier 2 and tier three
instruction as well. Um so we are want
to continue those things that are
working well for us maintaining that
focus and that implementation of
highquality literacy instructional
materials professional learning that is
really targeted and meaningful and
includes literacy practices. That one's
really important because um
instructional materials may change over
the years but literacy practices are
based on research and um those are the
ones that need to be applied no matter
what resource or materials that you're
using. and then expanding our our
coaching model with leadership and with
teachers. And that's talking a little
bit about our our lighthouse schools,
our uh learning lab uh campuses as well.
Then just what we've done together as
school leadership and academics teams to
support our campuses in coaching. We
also wanted to talk a little bit tonight
about why it is that we're tracking
meets uh in the first place and why this
is part of of uh LSG and something the
state focuses on really when they're
looking at districts and their uh
success. So the there's there's of
course did not meets on star and then
there are three various levels of
passing approaches meets and then
masters. Um the meet score on star
really is intended to indicate that a
student has a very high likelihood of
being successful in the next grade or
the next course. um approaches while
it's passing that means that the student
is likely to be successful but will
probably need some areas of intervention
and and some additional supports in the
next grade or the next course. And so
meats is really a better indicator of
success uh that a student would have
independently and also in literacy. It
also includes some more um indicators
like higher uh increasing text complex
complexity really being able to apply
knowledge and skills in multiple
contexts and not just the context of the
assessment. um also means that those
students at the meets level can make
really strong connections across texts.
Do things like explain author's purpose
and that changes a little bit. The verbs
change. It's not just identify the
author's purpose in a passage or the
author's intended message, but really
explain what that is and use text
evidence to support that explanation.
Making inferences, predictions, just a
lot of higher level critical thinking
skills that support students across
content areas. And so that's why uh
we're focusing on the meat score as
well. Um when when we look at our uh
progress monitoring in connection with
the third grade star. So we progress
monitored using our second grade
literacy screener with the MAP growth
assessment. um and were found the same
thing in literacy that we found that we
reported previously in math that there
is a correlation when you're looking at
student achievement percentiles in the
MAP growth assessment and we're looking
at reducing the number of students who
are qualifying for interventions in
those student achievement percentiles
that is correlated to increasing uh star
scores. When we decrease those numbers
uh in our screener then we are
increasing numbers. So we found a nice
correlation between our GPM and the
sumitive which is which is a good thing
to find during the year. That means that
we can trust progress monitoring as it's
happening during the year and that we
can expect that the progress monitoring
results will predict the end ofear
summitive. Uh and so what we see here is
um we've met our target of 49%. Last
year it was 47% so we grew by 2%. Uh,
and also just for a little bit of
context, 49% is on par with where the
state of Texas performed at meets last
year. So the state of Texas 49% of
students scored at meets and we did two
in Austin ISD. Um, and so uh, you can
see next year we've got another increase
in our targets at 52 55%. And as we look
at progress monitoring a little bit more
this year and start reporting on that. I
think our first report on literacy
progress and on monitoring is not
actually until February. Uh we have a
January report on new mercy and I think
a February report on literacy. So we'll
continue to report that. That'll be
beginning of year um progress monitoring
and we'll hopefully see those
correlations again as we go forward. and
then I'll hand it over to um our
humanities director, elementary
humanities director, Miss Lilya
Kendrick, to talk a little bit more
about the breakdown of the data and
analysis and some root causes.
>> Thank you, Dr. Maxwell. And good
morning, board of trustees, Mr.
President and superintendent. Uh good
morning and um yeah, good evening.
>> It's [laughter] morning.
>> It's morning. Um, I'm deeply honored and
humbled to present to you the table. Dr.
Maxwell always talk about You move the
table, Dr. Maxwell. Uh, the table. She
always talks about this, but I'm very
excited to talk about the uh 21 to 2024
and 25 results of the district of the
early literacy. And as I will I will you
will see on on the chart it talks about
the district progress uh towards goal
one and ensure that all the students are
reading on grade level by the end of
third grade. As we look at the five
years the start reading data trends
across the students groups and the key
insight for our root cause analysis. So
I will talk about how the table and how
it's summarized. The third grade
students meeting grade level or above a
start reading assessment in both English
and the Spanish from 202021
through 2024 and 2025.
As you can see in the first row, the
percent of all the students mid-grade
level increasing from 47% to 2023 to
2024 to 49% and 2024 to 2025 meeting the
yearly target established on this cycle.
It is important to notice that these
represent the continued progress
following the post pandemic recovery
efforts of the literacy instruction. As
we can see, the district met in 2025 the
yearly targets with 49% achieving at
above grade level. When we examine the
trends over time, we see that every
student group demonstrate growth for the
previous year. Tonight, we totally
celebrate the collective work or a
dedication of our teachers,
administrators, and academic teams who
have made this progress possible.
As you can look on the table, we can see
that all the students grew from 47% to
49%.
African-American students grew from 23%
to 29%.
Hispanics, Latic students grew from 29%
to 31%.
Our special education students shows an
increase from 22% to 28%.
And emerging bilingual show an increase
of 23% to 24%. And at equict
disadvantages, students show an increase
of 23% to 25%.
Even the modest gains across multiple
subgroups are significant because they
reflect consistent systemwide progress.
So as you can see, we totally analyze
that every subgroup either met or
exceeds 24 and 25 goals. Are the Asian
group maintain a performance of 75%
exceeding the 69% target and our Y
students achieve 76% meeting in 24 and
25 targets. American Indians students
surpass expectations and growth to 78%
and two or more groups shows an increase
of 73% to 75%.
As you can see, these gains are reflect
an impact of collected instruction
commitment and a strategic interventions
and supporting across of all groups.
Having said that, we also know that we
can see how the data is encouraging, but
it is also important to acknowledge the
ongoing variabilities and performance
among the students subop. For example,
the wise students are performing at 76%
while the AfricanAmerican students are
at 29% and our Hispanic Latin students
are at 31% and our special educations
are at 28%.
So as you can see these gaps emphasize
the need for sustaining and a strategic
efforts to close the disparacy through
intentional support and differentiation
teaching.
So now we will talk about how these are
a root cause and how we are dealing with
our ongoing challenges.
As you can see, the achievement gap
still persists and remains an ongoing
work that needs to be uplifted for our
historical underserved students. The
data recognize that the groups are
consistent
and highquality tier one instruction
across all classrooms and campuses. We
want to make sure we have a strong
progress monitor system to identify and
respond to student needs. And we want to
have an intensive support for campuses
with higher concentration of emerging
bilingual African-Americans,
economically disadvantaged, and a
special education students.
So in summary, the data affirms that
we're moving forward, but yet there is
still work ahead to guarantee equitable
literacy growth for all students.
So one of the things that I wanted to
talk about is like as we can see the
growth that we still have a lot
room to grow within our system. And so
one of the next steps that we want to
focus with that is make sure that we're
expanding targeted professional
development with our literacy and
interventions. One of the main things
that we analyze is that this past
Monday, November the 4, we have a
district professional development and we
were able to provide differentiation
training to our teachers. One of the
main things was making sure that we
taught foundational skills for our
bilingual students and teachers that
that support a special students and our
ESL teachers that do foundational skills
as well. our students and three to five
that we want to make sure we do the
comprehension and and addressing the
needs to meeting the STAR test. And of
course, one of the main things we want
to make sure is to continue to look at
the real data about formative
assessments especially when it comes to
targeted instruction for interventions.
One of the big things that we are
working on are making sure the data is
through the readingmies
uh certifications. We are currently
certifying 250 teachers and one of them
we have one of the largest number of
special education. Dr. Chirly just
present to you about a special education
and the importance of closing that and
one of the biggest underserved
population has been our special
education students and as you can see we
grew our percentages but it's still very
uh low percentages that we need to
continue to grow and have our students.
So that's one of the biggest things we
want to highlight. We also want to
highlight that we're straining our dual
language literacy support and ensuring
that all the students are been being
developed and be by literacy.
And lastly, we want to continue to
support coaching and collaborating PLC's
as part of one of the efforts on having
a high quality instruction. So I would
like to close with the data saying that
we want our data to be more than a
progress persistence and promising for a
AIS. We achieve our annual benchmark
begin closing post-pandemic disparities
and see clear evidence that our early
literacy structures are creating a
lasting impact. Our focus remain clear
to ensure that every child regardless
background, language or ability becomes
a confident reader by third grade and
Austin ISD. So thank you for your
continued support and partnership with
this vital and transformative work.
Together we are shaping the bright the
future for our students. And now I am
happy to pass it to Miss Space to talk
about a outlier summary. Thank you. Good
morning, trustees. President Boswell,
Superintendent Suga. Um, thank you for
the opportunity to just highlight some
of our band one and two campuses that
performed above the district average or
showed significant growth. I'm excited
to brag on the great work they're doing.
Despite facing greater challenges in the
support and resource index, these
schools have proven that fidelity to
strong instruction and datadriven
collaboration can close gaps and
accelerate literacy growth. So, Galindo
Elementary has demonstrated remarkable
growth with uh third grade meets grade
level performance and above increasing
from 19% in 2024 to 51% in 2025. and
that's surpassing the district average
of 49%.
The growth reflects a culture of
collaboration among grade level teams
and vertical teams.
Datadriven instruction and responsive
teaching is embedded in the campus
culture.
Weekly PLC's, structured lesson
preparation, and frequent walkthroughs
ensure alignment and better
implementation of highquality
instructional materials during the
literacy blocks.
General education teachers and special
education teachers plan together, co-e,
and they work really intentionally to
scaffold rigorous grade level content.
Teachers implement effective engagement
and behavior strategies, keeping
students focused and really maximizing
learning time. And student goal setting
is a core practice at Galindo that
fosters ownership, motivation, and
accountability for progress.
when uh Montasauri has shown steady
significant growth on the third grade
star reading assessment rising from 17%
at meets and above in 2023
to 35% at meets and above in 2024 and
43% at meets and above in 2025.
This progress reflects the intentional
work launched in 2023 to align the
Montasauri language curriculum with the
science of teaching reading while
maintaining authenticity of the
Montasauri model. The campus leadership
team partnered with our incredible
humanities team and our amazing
multilingual education team, investing a
significant amount of time to align
Monttoauri language curriculum to the
science of teaching reading and to
develop and implement a literacy plan
that blends HM and our intervention
resources, El Camino and Elroximo Paso
into a coherent and systematic approach.
Our literacy partner also provided
support to improve comprehension
instruction and strengthen intervention
groups to accelerate learning so that
students make more than one year growth.
And just wanted to see if either of you
wanted to just add a little bit about
the the work to align the Montasuri
curriculum with our curriculum.
Yeah, I think um Montasauris is so
unique the way we do in AISD and there
has been a lot of work and we have been
working with the principal uh and their
team and their coaching team to make
sure that the teachers have the
resources that they need. Definitely it
was uh disparacy like we show and the
data also showed that the need of
providing a strong materials especially
for our bilingual students and our ESL
learners students that she has a great
number. So we came together, we provided
some resources, we aligned the
curriculum and trying to work with her
with the Montasauri model and how it
also reading required explicit and
systematic instruction for or some other
students. So we were able to align
provide her the materials she um grabbed
the materials we kind of continue to
provide professional development and
their teams took it and that's how the
instruction has been happen and I think
that's also have been an impact making
sure that this numbers are changing on
making sure the students are reading.
>> Yeah, thank you. It was a big lift and
it is paying off. Um, early literacy
indicators show a decline in the
percentage of kinder and first grade
students flagged at risk for dyslexia,
signaling stronger foundational reading
skills. And additionally, at um, when
Montasauri, the lower elementary team,
it's now in its third year together, and
that's been a driving force. They've
been able to engage in ongoing
professional learning and coaching
cycles and targeting tutoring to
accelerate growth.
Blackshere Elementary has demonstrated
strong literacy progress as well um with
the meat's grade level or above
performance increasing from 41% in 2024
to 51% in 2025 also surpassing the
district average of 49%.
and the team uh there consistently used
highquality instructional materials
supported by regular observation and
feedback cycles and they have a robust
data tracking system that really informs
instruction in real time.
Additionally, departmentalization
um allowed the third grade team to
deepen their expertise in content um
enhancing instructional quality. And
similar to uh what they do in math, they
use a station rotate rotation model.
Even in the literacy block as well as a
system for writing and typing practice
as part of the weekly schedule. Writing
has also been embedded across science
and social studies um which reinforced
literacy skills in multiple contexts and
they have strong student teacher
relationships and active engagement
strategies kept students motivated and
on task.
And finally, Campbell Elementary, our
media and performing arts school,
demonstrated exceptional third grade
literacy growth, increasing meets grade
level and above performance from 33% in
2024 to 53% in 2025, also surpassing the
district average.
Implementing highquality instructional
materials contributed to their success
along with datadriven small groupoup
instruction. The campus has a strong
system for PLC's and the leadership team
conducted regular feed observation and
feedback cycles.
Interventionists and instructional
coaches partnered with teachers to
deliver targeted support and close
learning gaps. And despite a staffing
vacancy, Campbell benefited from a
pre-ervice teacher from Austin Community
College to provide additional classroom
support during core instruction and
intervention which resulted in
accelerated student learning.
And then I want to mention a few other
campuses although below the diff
district average. Um Hart, Andrews,
Jordan, Wooten, and Zavala saw a
doubledigit increase in the percent of
students scoring at meets or above on
the third grade star reading test. Um
Hart was at 15% in 2024 and 28% in 2025.
Um Andrews grew from 11% to 22%. Jordan
from 5% to 16%, Wooten from 13% to 24%
and Zavala from 20% to 32%.
So this is just an uh demonstrates that
when such strong systems and instruction
is intentional, students thrive no
matter the challenges. The campuses
remind us that progress is predictable
when we stay focused on tier one uh data
driven instruction and collaboration.
Any additional thoughts before going to
next steps?
So next steps for our literacy focus. Um
we want to have a clear and consistent
communication of instructional
expectations for all campuses. Uh we'll
continue ensuring every classroom
provides rigorous grade level literacy
instruction every day which is not just
using HQIM but using it as intended. We
will continue to work on that. Um, it
also includes consistent communication
of expectations such as our detailed
posted schedules and fidelity to
highquality instructional materials and
supporting um providing supports that
help students access complex text.
Targeted meaningful professional
learning for all uh teachers and
instructional leaders. Teachers,
coaches, and leaders will engage in
targeting ongo targeted ongoing
professional learning centered on the
AISD literacy curriculum
and effective practices, especially
through instructional rounds and
coaching, observation, and feedback
cycles. and PLC's [snorts]
will remain a hub for improving lesson
delivery, data analysis, and alignment
to our HQIM.
We'll provide an ongoing investment in
campus leaders as instructional leaders.
You've heard us mention this, but we've
expanded our Lighthouse Schools
initiative from last year, now having
six campuses that are serving as
lighthouse uh serving as learning labs
for 37 schools. um leadership teams to
come together for hands-on professional
learning and application.
These lighthouse campuses receive
support in effective coaching,
leadership structures, and PLC practices
that accelerate student outcomes.
At the district level, executive
directors will continue monthly
professional learning focused on
contentbased coaching and conducting
instructional rounds to calibrate
expectations across campuses. and we
have really been enjoying that just
getting to observe alongside curriculum
and really coming out and debriefing and
thinking about what is the highest
leverage action step um to move the
work.
Additionally, we'll use the support and
resource index and school improvement
designations to differentiate support.
This includes increased coaching
frequency
um aligned resource allocation and
focused monitoring of campuses and
student group uh student groups not yet
showing equitable progress.
Lighthouse schools have been
strategically located to support
campuses serving our highest need and
historically underserved students.
And finally, we want to strengthen
family engagement and partnerships. will
expand family engagement and literacy.
Continuing to share the multicultural uh
multilingual curriculum newsletters for
each unit with strategies and book
recommendations and community
connections. And schools will um host
literacy nights, book fairs, and
workshops that actually equip families
to support reading at home.
Y'all like to share any additional
thoughts on next steps?
Um, I guess just to mention too, we
changed actually the way that we're
sending out the um newsletter this year.
We had we had sent it through campuses
last year and instead of doing that this
year, we just um worked with our
communications department and are
sending it out at the district level.
Um, and so I' I've actually even
received more feedback or comments on
that this year that people are receiving
it and they they see it and um are
making some connections to what their
students what their children are
learning and able to help with a few
activities at home. So that I think that
was a good shift.
>> Can I just say something about that?
>> Of course. Uh one of the things that I
have received is from the parents reach
out the first unit that went out a
parent re uh emailed me back and says I
really appreciate the newsletter that
has been sending home so that I can find
out what my student is learning and the
newsletter actually answered the
questions about how can I support my
child at home in kindergarten and he
helped me to know what to do with it. So
I really appreciate and I enjoyed the
letter. So I thought that was very neat.
We have a lot of questions. Trusty
Hunter said, "What are we doing?" And
how two-way communication and has been
and we just sent the newsletter for unit
4 that started this week and actually a
partner she it's a partner in the city
that partners with the librarians and
she was very uh thrilled with the
letters because she has a student in
AISD and she goes, "Could you please
reach out to me? I want them to know
that their students can check out their
books with their AISD account and that
will be great to add on the newsletter."
So I scheduled a meeting with her next
week to tell me more about so that we
can continue to add that. So it has been
a very powerful and amazing way to send
those at the district level and get back
the community back about how can we
continue to enri students at the
district level. So yes
>> and I think that concludes our report
and we'd be happy to answer any
questions.
>> Fantastic. Thank you all so much. Um a
lot of positive stuff here. Thank you.
Um, who wants to start? Trustee Hunter.
>> Quickly, I just wanted to know um the
the teacher that you mentioned, I'm
going to claim her. Um,
Miss, uh, Alveter Manriquez, uh, is
mine. So, I know she's a good teacher
because I made her. [laughter]
So, uh, she is she's be a great
bilingual teacher also, which is what
she really wanted. So, I'm excited about
that. She had the chance. Um, actually
had two residents at Campbell. Um the
question I have is one is a wondering
because you mentioned the um readingmies
and so I'm just wondering do because
that seems like that takes you out of
the like it's think teachers have I've
never heard good things about it first
of all but if you get it like let's say
you're a college graduate and you take
STR in college do you still have to do
the readingmies?
Yes.
>> Figure out a way around that because
that is if we could save y'all some time
like we could give them to you and
they're like ready to go.
>> Let me think about that one. But um so I
was just wondering I was like oh you
have to go through that and then you
still have to go to reading academy.
>> Previously typically the state would
sort of do something like this in the
meantime but then once uh teacher prep
caught up and then there was a
certification involved with it. Usually
once teachers were certified in that you
didn't attend those anymore. That did
not happen with readingmies. We'll also
be starting mathmies implementing those
in a couple of years. That's new in
legislation.
>> That's good. That's good. It's not a bad
thing. It's a good thing.
>> I will say when it was first rolled out,
it was all virtual. Um and you were a
reading specialist in Round Rock at the
time and um it uh and we're grading all
of those artifacts and doing all of
that. So, it was a lot of hours on the
computer. Now that it's the
comprehensive model, it's much more in
person. And not only do they come in
person for uh professional development,
but our um reading academy specialists
go out to the campuses and coach the
teachers in the classrooms. So they'll
observe instruction and they can do some
coaching and observe sort of do some
coaching. And so it's a it's much more
personal and um Miss Kendrick mentioned
a large percentage of this year's are
special education teachers because we've
been hiring a lot and so now they're
going through the readingmies. Uh, and
so, um, we're those coaches are instead
of them just getting the same training
everyone else does, they do get that,
but then they also get coaching where
the, uh, reading academy specialists can
actually individualize that to how
they're working with their special
education students, which is a little
bit different than what the classroom
teacher is delivering depending on the
on the model. Yeah.
>> So, I think it's we're seeing the
results and I think it's a confluence of
all of it, right? It's uh EC36 having
the STR and then it's like um having HQI
I'm doing a lot of initials but it's
HQIM and it's fidelity to that. And so I
think all of that is is giving us but I
I still have this like lingering
question. So how do we accelerate
progress in third grade for that that's
persistent gap for African-Americans,
Hispanic emerging bilingual, students
with special education services and
ecois. Like how do we we've done it now
right? we pushed. So like how do we like
push up further? Because what was the
story before is that it would be
whatever number we'd miss it and be
like, "Oh, next year's even higher."
It's like we need to make this year.
Well, now we've made that. So how do we
accelerate it?
>> So that that is actually a question. I
mentioned this I think um I don't know
when I so uh on Monday uh we'll actually
be reviewing um the progress recent
progress monitoring that we've done some
things we've seen in the classroom but
also working with our partner [snorts]
um and and again a very large number of
you know random classrooms randomized
classrooms all across the district 22
campuses I think [snorts] um and that's
one of the things that we're focusing on
so not only do we see all the these
things but specifically with the student
population
[snorts]
>> seeing in classrooms. What are we seeing
in classrooms together that might be
contributing to this so that we can dig
deeper into that root cause? That was
one of the things that we had talked
about at the end of last year. We really
want a better root cause on this so that
we can get some better strategies that
address that. Is it dynamics in the
classroom? Is it um instruction at at uh
you know certain campuses or is it is it
not enough peer engagement? You know, is
the engagement not where it needs to be?
Um lots of questions. um is it a
programming uh contribution with for
emergent bilingual like all of those
questions that we have. So that's that's
part of the thing that we're really
focusing on this year with our classroom
observations, our progress monitoring um
and some of the work that we're doing in
our lighthouse campuses as well. So
we're we're learning about that a little
more on Monday to start the year um and
adjust the strategies as we go. Um I I
love the improvement. I mean, I I I I'm
always happy for that and I I want to,
you know, give kudos to everyone for
that work and and all of our campuses
for that work, but it is something that
we have to do if we really are going to
see equity at the end of the five years
or at least getting closer to equity. I
know that it's hard to get equity in
five years when we have centuries of uh
lack of equity, but I think that with
the right systems, we can get a heck of
a lot closer than we are right now.
>> Excellent. Um my second question is um
we've talked about HQIM and now
monitoring that having a more
centralized focus of that. Can you like
um through the two-part question like
how is the district measuring it and if
you are can you tell me right now like
80% of all campuses are
>> 88% of
>> 88 oh 88% of campuses are using it in
comprehension 100%
>> [snorts]
>> um is what we found and then
foundational skills uh it was a little
lower like in the lower 80s
uh because there are some campuses for
foundational skills that are using a
different program but they are using HMH
for comprehension
Because typically if you like really
great reading as an example, it just has
the foundational skills piece but not
the comprehension piece that goes with
it. And so they're still using HMH for
comprehension.
>> Okay.
>> And it's also interesting Dr. Maxwell um
kind of the progression. So like fall
because because we assess um where we
are and so this is the third year that
we put that data. Right. So we did fall
24, spring 24, and then fall 25.
>> So we're at 88. Go ahead.
spring uh 2024, spring 2025, then spring
2020. I said that wrong. It's late,
y'all. [laughter]
>> Did you say this is the fourth round?
This is actually the fourth round. Yeah.
>> Okay. And but it's been progressing
every like every semester. It it
actually has been moving um which is to
where we are now
>> which is which has been really really
great. And then the comment that um uh
Leon made about maybe it was Dr.
Maxwell. I I don't my my brain's melting
right now around um incorporating um our
special education educators like into
the training like I wonder do you think
that's one of the reasons that you're
seeing the growth um in that student
population on this table? Like I mean
because right now I mean like so you
know a target was last year were at 22
23 23 24 was 22 um our target was 23 and
we were at 28. Like what are the things
that you think are kind of driving that?
I shouldn't be asking questions, but I
was just building off your question
really.
>> Um, just I don't know. We talk about it.
We've talked about it a lot. I just want
to make sure that it gets out there
because it's it's good to share.
>> The population that we're talking about
now, uh, the students that we're the
teachers that we're coaching, this is
going to be uh, the teachers that we're
coaching um, are in readingmies right
now. And so this would have been, you
know, from last year's
>> even get better should be better. So, I
think it's Yeah, I think actually we're
going to continue to see those
improvements and and um you know, we're
already exceeding targets several years
out. So, I just but that's no no matter
like we should just continue to see
those improvements still. Um but so much
of this has to do with the fact that our
special education students are in our
classrooms. They're they're they're yes,
they're serviced by special education
teachers, but they are also served by
our core classroom teachers. And so when
both of those things start to get better
um and we get more clear on um
expectations for our special education
students and how we can support that how
the core teacher can support that then
you'll see the numbers move too and I
think that was a lot of last year's
work.
>> And can I also [snorts] say um last year
we also collaborated along with the uh
special education team and the dyslexia
department to make sure that we were
aligning the resources for the HQIM. We
also have a lot of correlation and make
sure that we were all speaking the same
language. We're all talking about a
structure literacy. We were talking
about science or reading and making sure
that we we're going to emphasize that
instruction and provide the feedback. We
also have a lot of meetings together. We
look at map reading growth as well as
map reading fluency and map growth as
part of our assessments. We correlate
our data. We're making sure that we are
providing and we're also screening for
dyslexia early as we are required on the
lower grades to see and we can identify
the students early so that we can
provide the services that they need and
then interventions. So we're not waiting
for the students to take so long. We are
addressing the issue early so that we
can provide those services. So I also
have to say to Dr. Jerie and her team
with the academic like she mentions we
we have partnered to do the work and
that's what we need to do continue to
partner on doing the work. Yeah. Um and
oh sorry no no
>> I was just going to add that you know
last year we we were really working on
refining our MTSS systems and so we were
really intentional about
>> having tier 2 and three interventions
like scheduled in our daily blocks and
not um pulling students out of tier one
instruction. And I just think that that
intentionality too um made a big
difference in um students receiving
special education accessing core
instruction, grade level instruction.
>> Okay. And my final question, and it's
always
it costs money, right, to do all of
these things. Um and I know that we've
prioritized uh band one and band two
campuses. How are um like I guess the
question ultimately is do you need more?
I'm sure the answer will always be yes,
but what what as we're moving and
thinking and shifting, what where can we
support you more because we want to see
those numbers improve?
Um, well, I mean, we've talked a little
bit about our uh some of our
instructional materials dilemma, and I
always go back to that because that they
are incredibly expensive [snorts]
uh and just the way that the state is
funding that differently now. Um, we
have leaned into some of the resources
that the ED fund has provided um to be
able to purchase some materials, some
extra materials for teachers that uh we
[snorts] didn't use instructional
materials a lotment for um or or um the
the borrowing [snorts] from the general
fund um that we've done before as well.
Um so materials are are always an issue.
Um you know of course uh as a support
for teachers um content interventionists
um are are you know they they I think
they've made a huge difference on our
campuses as well. Some campuses had them
but now more campuses have them more
strategically uh more strategically
placed. Um and so those are always a
huge help when the teacher has to
provide tier one instruction tier 2
interventions and sometimes tier three
interventions. That's a big load on the
teacher. It really is. And so content
interventions make a big difference.
>> Any other thoughts on specific funding?
>> No, I think just
continue um just like Dr. Maxwell said,
they're very expensive. So, one of the
things that we're looking forward to
see, and I'm waiting to see what the
state will vote at the end of this
month, what materials are going to come
out on the list will be decodables, uh
will be manipulatives to make sure that
we have more books in the hands of the
kids that they align. And so, you know,
books are expensive.
>> Yeah.
>> But they are needed for our kids to
read. So, uh probably also manipulative
is what they can do the letters and they
can create all, you know, manipulative
boards. That's also the other piece that
we need. Just like math needs
manipulatives,
>> literacy needs manipulatives. And so
that probably will be a next step for us
to continue to look and see what the
step adopts and see how can we find more
more funds to provide more resources in
decodable books in classrooms.
>> Excellent. Thank you. And then finally,
I I know that we know here that that we
see the movement, but I I wanted to
share uh community sentiment that that
you may hear and it's, you know, it's so
low. Why do you expect so little of our
kids? And the explanation when we go and
say it's because they started so much
further behind and it really doesn't
ever land well with our community
members. And that's why I'm really ready
to see that accelerate because we
already know what our children can do
and we want to just see that and we wish
that you know we could just look at the
whole child and say we approve but
unfortunately um as our superintendent
has said we are judged by the one test
on that one day one time of year but
what we really care about is that kids
can read. Kids love reading which means
they will continue to read which means
they will continue to learn. Thank you.
>> Yeah trusty. Um because I'm often having
to answer that question. Um and so we do
hear it a lot and uh I think what's
really great is we're still like pretty
early on and a lot of the systems and a
lot of the work is really just now
beginning to to show that it's it's
responding the way that we would expect.
And so though this is is is promising,
you know, I would expect only for it to
improve, especially given what we've
done last year and just the stability of
the system. And so I'm actually really
encouraged where, you know, I I know I
never want to move targets. I mean, I
always talk about that, but once you get
two years and you really do see like now
we're like past our fiveyear horizon,
like, okay, now let's go like, you know,
I I just it's like you want to get those
first two years because you you wonder
if it's a quick start
>> and then the system responds quickly,
but is it going to settle down or is it
a resource issue? But um yeah, I I think
we're thinking the way you are. We want
to see it I mean like move the way Dr.
Hoffman talks about, you know, like like
in I'm just really excited. Like I feel
like we're got to stay the course,
continue on, you be bold. Um but yeah,
we want to see what you want and it's
unfortunate where we started. Uh but we
think we can get to where we all want to
be. Um we just got to keep going.
[snorts]
>> Thank you, Trusty Singh.
I was just going to say like I'm really
encouraged by these results and you
always talk about superintendent how
we're starting to see you know
um the impact of some of these systemic
changes we've made with uh you know
investing in our teachers and the
science of reading and and special
education. So I am really excited to see
um this and just thank you so much for
the work. I was curious to know um so in
the table um it shows the annual um the
annual results on the star test and so I
was wondering have I and I don't think
it goes back to precoid but I was
curious to know if that's something that
you all are tracking as well to see if
we've um you know
gone back to to like how far we are from
precoid levels. You don't have to answer
now, but that is just something that
might be interesting to include um in
our in our reports. [snorts]
Um if we're if TA will allow us to do
that.
>> Um yeah, I mean we we can certainly look
I know we um early on in our time
together we we talked about like
pre-COVID, postcoid and getting back to
pre-COVID
>> um numbers. Um I wonder if there's a
different way to to show that. I mean if
if it's star assessment um you know
given you know kind of what's changed we
can certainly make that comparison
um
>> you know I we can look at that [snorts]
trying to think um what are the data
sets we could use to make that
comparison
>> I mean I think it would just be looking
for like one previous one earlier year
>> just [snorts] on meets and exceeds and
just kind of because that's mean I mean
is that just kind of see what was
>> just to kind of see if we're back up it
would be helpful to know that. Um,
>> of course we [clears throat] could look
at that including
>> say I would say like an neighbor like
yeah is that the same assessment? So I'd
almost want to use like neighbor I I
think there's probably some if I was
going to track something like year over
year I know it's not every year but
>> um because it's been so much change I we
can do it. I just
>> Yeah. I mean maybe it's more but just
like is there a simple way to answer
like hey are we back up to precoid
levels? I don't know exactly how we
would be able to
>> I'd use me for that. We have that. I
mean, I can I can go back that far.
>> Okay, that would be helpful. [snorts]
>> I think we could include that. I know
the state looks at that. Uh reading I
believe is statewide for the meats
level. I don't know about all grade
levels just I was looking at this today
and then but they're not yet for math.
Um so, you know, you see some
variability there as well, but I think
we could look back at the scores and
just make a simple comparison.
>> Okay, great. Well, I really appreciate
the presentation and all the work and I
thought that the um the outliers um
definitely told an interesting story.
So, that was really well done. So, thank
you. I don't really have a question that
you you answered them all in your
presentation. So, [snorts]
>> thank you.
>> Excellent. Thank you.
>> Oh, sure.
All right.
Hey, thank you so much. Um I wanted to
know who is struggling the most.
>> You mean in general in our observations
or according to this data set that we
provided?
>> According to this data set that you
provided.
>> Well uh so that's what we mentioned I
think a little bit in our report.
There's continues to be a very large gap
with our African-American students and
our Hispanic students. uh not as much
compared to all students but compared to
some of the highest performing ones and
that have typically been high
performing. So um I think those students
are um certainly struggling the most. Um
I think uh economically disadvantaged is
a little bit of a you know uh a little
bit harder to disagregate just because
there are so many populations involved
with that. Um our emergent bilingual
too. I would really like to see I I like
to see some movements of course in those
scores, but uh would like to see more as
we um get deeper into fidelity of
programming uh and and working with the
curriculum structures that we put in
place that really support um dual
language programming.
>> Thank [snorts] you. Um who is not
included in the data?
Um,
I don't know. I mean, right now, I would
say in this data that we have that we
report, uh, it's only a slice of third
grade. Um,
I think our our progress monitoring does
a pretty good job of telling the story
of what's happening in um, the primary
years and K and K2. I know we only
report second grade, but as we usually
when we report that, we also say, "Hey,
we're also seeing movement in
kindergarten and first grade." Um, so
third grade helps tell that story a
little bit. It doesn't tell the story as
much as what's happening in fourth and
fifth grade. We're going to see the
benefits of the work that we did um
focusing on early literacy with K2
sooner in third grade. It takes a little
longer there to get to fourth and fifth
grade. They're also reading
significantly more complex texts. um
sometimes it's shocking what a fifth
grader has to has to read or uh be able
to to um understand from some of those
texts. Uh so it doesn't it doesn't tell
the whole story of elementary. It's it's
just a slice of third grade. So it's you
know it's an indicator. Um but certainly
just one of the things that we look at.
>> Thank you. That answered my question.
>> Thank you.
Um yeah, I was curious al along those
lines, you know, if there's something
more um I don't want to say specific,
but like looking forward to see the the
ongoing effects of this work as the
students are metriculating to the higher
grades. um you know we we do have those
those um progress monitors for before
you know is there specific thought on
how we're going to track like the
lasting progress for these students?
So one of the um early things that we
started to do last year um we haven't
done it yet with end of year uh well not
in this in this manner not in the in the
uh sort of sense of what we're looking
at it right now but one of the things we
did last year when we got our first two
um star projections which would have
been from midyear map the winter map and
then also the star interim. We started
looking at those scores, third, fourth,
and fifth grade to see um what the
movement looked like. And we so we found
um third most movement was starting in
third, but we were also seeing some
positive movement in fourth and fifth
grades. And actually, most of it was um
not only a change in students that uh
decrease in students that uh did not
meet um but there was a significant
increase in students that were at the
meets level. So it was almost as if
quite a significant number of students
moved from did not meets and they didn't
just get to approaches, they actually
moved up uh to to meet. So we kind of
saw a pretty a pretty uh significant and
positive shift there. Um it's just kind
of a regular indicator that we look at
all the time. It's definitely one of
while we're still focusing on on early
literacy and those structures and
foundations. It's part of our progress
monitoring as well. Um we're looking at
third through fifth grades. um well,
we're actually looking at sixth through
eighth grades, too, but uh third through
fifth grade um to to to make sure that
we have a a better understanding of
what's happening in those upper grade
levels. There's some differences and and
nuances in instruction and just making
sure those students are successful
because you definitely have to have all
these quality practices and also to be
fair to students. um you know there's
this assessment coming at the end of the
year that may not be the best uh uh
assessment of everything that they know
but we have to be fair to them and you
know ask questions at times that are
aligned with that assessment. So you
have to sort of embed that into your
teaching from time to time um if it's
done well so that it doesn't feel like
or look like or sound like test prep. Um
but those are the kinds of things we
monitor. We're monitoring in the upper
grade levels and of course data as it
comes in. We also have curriculum based
assessments for third through fifth
grade. And so we are setting up systems
now um to moni monitor how those
curriculum based assessments are are
going and working with um our campus
leaders and our teachers on uh data
protocols for them to be able to look at
it and really look at student work
associated with that. So for this case
um you know some student work associated
with how they're answering their
questions and showing their thinking.
Um, and certainly in the writing. In the
writing, I know this is a reading
assessment. We don't talk as much about
the writing. Um, but to know it's it's
difficult to score meets at this on this
assessment without having a really good
extended constructed extended
constructed response that that essay
that they they write. Um, so it has to
be pretty on target. It has to um have
pretty strong language conventions in
it. Um, and so at this meets level, you
can see that students are doing that.
So then I think along those lines, you
were talking about some of the practices
and you know the elements for
implementing this um are are there
takeaways that we're looking at that
then apply to secondary into those later
grades? I know the content changes and
you know the general instructional model
changes, but are there still
foundational elements in this that are
applicable for later that we're carrying
on?
>> Absolutely. I this is um from last year
where we didn't target any of our
professional development on third
through fifth grade. This is all
professional development targeted on K2.
Um but practices you know good practices
cross over and um again we saw some
improvement in last last math last year
we didn't have any professional
development we had a little professional
I don't want to say any we had some
professional development but wasn't our
focus it wasn't our our our our uh area
to to really uh go all out in so this
growth that we're seeing in third grade
was just a result of um administrators
and teachers sharing practices and and
you know that that transferring over to
the upper grades. So yes, quality
practices um at a campus and quality
practices across teachers and PLCs
definitely definitely can uh affect
other grade levels and other content
areas too.
>> Yeah. So then I would say my last
question along those lines you know we
mentioned earlier we're doing some of
those 2A engagements and you know that
piece with the community and going over
you know this type of data and when we
have talked about the adjustments we've
made to the scorecard goals and and the
way that you know that works generally
you know we have these these things
early childhood and then it's really
college career readiness and the idea
being you know that those are kind of
guiding stars that that should you
direct the rest of the curriculum
through it and Um, and so I'm curious as
to, you know, what we can be doing
moving forward to looking to making sure
that that alignment is connecting all
the way through, you know, as as, you
know, it kind of relates to the watching
these students metriculate, but like now
we don't particularly have a middle
school goal in general. you were talking
about writing before as just, you know,
an example, but like um not necessarily
that we have to have another specific
scorecard goal, but like, you know, if
if we're giving thought into how we're
going to make sure that that alignment
connects all the way from third grade to
to college career readiness. Mhm.
So, I think one of the amazing things
that we've seen this year, and it's it's
had some growing pains as well are is um
the better vertical alignment with our
teams. Um I think for things like that,
what we really lean into is uh the good
work that we've started and that we're
um continuing. Um that's the kind of
work that you find it like you lean into
an academic vision, academic framework
for that because that's not just for the
early levels, that's for the entire
district, right? Um and um have already
started those practices moving into
middle school, those same practices. So
it doesn't is not talking about
elementary tonight, but it's not just
staying in elementary. Uh those are the
academic practices that we've put into
place and all the things we've done to
support curriculum instruction and and
that we're building um with our PLC uh
framework in the spring. Um but also the
school leadership practices um Miss Pace
and Dr. Emerson and Dr. Wilson are we
meet regularly
regularly all the time [laughter]
regularly and all the time um to uh talk
about those practices and really share u
not just what's happening academically
in classroom but um the school
leadership practices the executive
director uh practices and how we're
supporting and coaching campuses. Uh it
it's been one of the I think benefits of
kind of the re the re- um structure that
we did over the summer um to really be
able to talk more and and and bring the
teams together and see the vertical
alignment so that we aren't causing gaps
in between you know uh work that we're
doing at the early levels and then just
sort of hoping for great secondary
outcomes but not aligning the work in
between. Right.
>> Yeah.
No. And I would just say also the MTSS
and instructional materials that we put
in place, we collaborated with secondary
to make sure that we align all the
instructional materials like they got
rewards for secondary and we were able
to use the other materials for
elementary. So we are aligning their
systems to your point like we want
elementary to continue to be successful
and if the students are not then we
continue to provide intervention support
for those students and and reading for
middle school and high school.
>> Yeah, I appreciate that. and uh you know
to make it clear for the community and
anybody that's still watching or watches
the replay, but I know that that's come
up when when we've talked about the
scorecard goals is understanding that
it's informing all the work that's
connecting from those pieces. And so I
appreciate you highlighting how that
progress in third grade is being
maintained into how we are projecting it
um you know all the way through high
school. So thank you.
>> Thank you Trusty Coffin. anything
asked and answered. Thank you.
>> Um all right, good. Thank you. I just
have a couple. Um first, thank you for
this. It's exciting to see really
consistent across every student group.
Um really exciting to see that and to
hear how the work really goes back all
the way to the foundations before third
grade. So, thank you for that. Um I just
have a question looking at the data.
um when you look at 202122,
you see numbers that are consistently
higher and then it dips down and comes
back up. And I would love to understand
um your understanding of what you're
seeing there um and and why we're seeing
that and what you expect to see going
ahead which you've made really clear as
you expect to see growth. So I'd love to
understand that pattern. Thank you.
>> Yeah. So we we talked about uh those
changes as well where you see kind of
some ups and downs um and
also um you know some some
inconsistencies I think to across
student populations of whether they're
also going up or down with all
um so again a little bit of uh
indication that um not everything was
necessarily aligned but definitely some
you know good things can happen uh from
year to year. Um there was um a change
in the star assessment at that time uh
what was it 2223
what 2223 and so I think with the
previous star assessment you had a
couple of years with that assessment and
then you had a change in the assessment
in 2223
um changed a lot of the way the passages
were uh written in the kinds of passages
that were included in the assessment. Um
the extended constructed response was a
new part of that uh with other tests
that included like the short constructed
response and all of that. And so you saw
a lot of uh student populations that
struggled with that. Um that was a that
was a little before my time here, but I
do know that that that was typically the
trend with um with testing that year.
>> Thank you. And and looks then like we've
incorporated that and and are moving
steadily. So, thank you.
>> Exciting to see. Um, trustees, any other
questions?
>> All right. Um, thank you so much.
>> Really appreciate the time and the work.
So much exciting to see. Um, and I we
will be so lucky if we have to adjust
some of our jackets because we've won
past them. That would be a beautiful
thing. So, thank you.
>> Appreciate it.
>> Thank you.
>> Good. Well, we are going to um skip our
executive session tonight. There's
nothing um that can't wait and it is
very late. So, um I want to thank my
trustees for this productive
conversation. And now we need to vote on
um accepting the monitoring report. And
as a point of clarity, we're voting to
accept this report as a formal
acknowledgement that we had a
satisfactory conversation with the
superintendent and have a deeper
understanding about how the current re
reality for students lines up with our
vision for them. And at this point, I
will entertain a motion to accept the
report.
>> I move to accept the report.
>> Thank you, Vice President Willie Chu. Is
there a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you, Trustee Singh. Any
discussion?
Having a motion by vice president Willie
Chu, a second by trustee Singh to accept
the monitoring report. All in favor,
please raise your right hand. Motion
passes by all in the dis. Um and thank
you trustees for taking part in this
commitment.
>> I move to adjourn the meeting
>> to our students.
>> Oh, sorry. [laughter]
>> Yes, that you. Um,
I I have a motion from Vice President
Willie Chu to adjourn the meeting. And
the meeting is joured at 10:05 a.m. Um,
thank you all so much and thank you to
our staff very much.